I think I think I'm like I'm getting there, okay? I'm slowly
becoming like more blackpilled and more unhinged. And eventually
I'll have spent so little time around the rest of humanity and
only streaming to you guys that I will be able to say the level
of unhinged that he does. Okay, eventually. I literally say if
you watch the Sunday video, you'd know that this is Sunday's
talking point, you'd know about all of this. It's very very funny
that he actually he actually totally totally [__]
this up in like an embarrassingly this is like Idubbbz tier actually
right this is like anything you any criticism you can make of
Idubbbz this is like significantly more embarrassing classic
Willie Mac the videos I gave criticism on right cuz somebody
was like oh he's like talking to Kelly right now and and like
Kelly wasn't Kelly's uh Kelly's what Kelly wasn't convincing
him okay I totally went in there and convinced him like hey if
you'd asked about the stuff going be good. We're going to have
a very long reaction here anyway, so I think it's I think it's
not going to be too big a deal. I think I'm good to watch the
video here. Kelly, what do you Are you good? We can start. Mac,
how many times have you watched this video, Kelly? Be honest.
Uh, twice. This is Kelly Jean's third viewing.
True. And then and then it's my first viewing. And then she's
going to go she's going to make points and she's going to go
I'm right. And then she'll have knowledge of late like later
in the video. It's going to be so up. You have a talk with Willy
Mack about the previous video without watching it first. Yeah.
No, I wasn't I didn't come in to argue with Willy Mack about
anything specific. When I went to argue with Willy Mack on Queen's
stream, I had not watched the full video. No, I'd watched specific
parts, but I'd watched the parts I argued about. Yeah. So, I
Yeah. Also, I was just pointing out that his argument the the
only argument I actually came in to argue was the uh the Kelly
one. That's what I joined Queen's stream for. And he immediately
conceded that and said, "Oh, yeah. I should have actually clarified
on these fronts. Hold on. I need to shut my phone off. Well,
well, the is k fabe. Kelly has to kay fabe. What does that mean?
Would be right either way. Usually. Yes. Oh, boy. Yeah. The only
argument I came in to have with Willy Mac was Oh, sorry. Go ahead.
Yeah, I was going to say me being correct does not equal Kelly
W in most instances. In fact, just saying nothing is usually
more of a W for me. Okay. By the way, um, everything I said to
Willie Mack, I was totally correct about. I was 100% correct
about, okay? And I was absolutely willing to discuss that with
him multiple times. I totally said, "Hey, if you want to come
in, I only ask cuz Willie brought it up as an own, I guess."
Oh, well, we'll get there. We'll get there and we'll see what
what's going on there. We'll see if um Willie Mack is an honest
actor or not. Cuz like realistically, I think I was extremely
fair to him like after the fact. And maybe I shouldn't have been.
Maybe being fair with people actually only gets you on the internet
and you should just try to kill them at any cost. This is what
I've been saying for months and you're like we'll see. We'll
see. I like being fair. Okay. I mean, define fair. We're still
more fair than he is, right? So, like how fair do you want us
to be? Okay. Uh, fair enough. We'll see. We'll see how it goes
cuz uh it's like fair to the point that it doesn't you right?
But it's hard to know that for sure. So, is Kelly turning hill?
I don't on what?
Ned Stark is dead. Okay.
I like Ned Stark, but Ned Stark is dead. Being good doesn't get
you very far. Okay. Do we have a uh This is really quiet, isn't
it? Have it turned down. I don't. Oh, look. It's document from
Pixie's legal team alleging that he was deleting evidence, specifically
messages with multiple women who have claimed that he shared
videos with them without the participants consent. So, he wasn't
just sharing videos with Rose. He was sending it to other women
who then told Pixie. I had a conversation with Anna, who claims
Destiny sent her videos of girls that she'd never seen before.
So, I've been sent videos. What? I have no way of knowing if
Yeah, this is broadly just known by anybody who has talked to
anyone behind the scenes. There are people I think it's the True
Melma person who's out on Twitter and has said like explicitly,
I was sent non-consensual videos of like Molina and other people.
Like, she's just out there. She said it like, "Hey, I got these
videos as well." These videos were clearly sent to multiple women.
There's not there's there's really no question of this whatsoever.
They were consensually. It puts you in a bit of a tough position
if you're in Anna's position, right? Because like to figure out
who these people are to warn them, you might have to end up sharing
revenge with people unless you're very surreptitiously cropping
things if there is faces involved to try and figure it out. And
then you got to balance. Is it worth doing that? And a lot of
the times it might not be. And yeah, I I don't know. Yeah. Who's
Anna? Annavoir is Anna or Annavar or Kim Marie is somebody who
used to be involved in streaming and had a relationship with
Destiny and basically is sort of the main contention. She's like
one of the main points people bring up to show Destiny's got
like some pattern of abuse where Destiny was like with this woman
while also calling her a stalker like within days of each other
going online calling her a stalker. Um knowing that that upset
her not not 100% knowing or knowing for sure that she had OCD
and that she had she felt compelled to go and correct any like
minor comment from him, but still knowing that she was like,
you know, maybe not in full control of her ability to respond.
I think that was pretty clear. through a lot of this and and
engaging in a relationship with them at the same time. That's
very very questionable.
So yeah, Kelly, you have anything to add? Definitely not. I have
no way of knowing if they Kelly was reading a comment. She wasn't
listening to the question, but it's fine. Or consensually
like recorded or sent. In my last video, I made clear that if
Destiny wanted to be taken seriously again, he'd have to own
up to what he did. He's always preaching about accountability.
But now when it's his time to finally own up, he doesn't. Instead,
he tells me he's going to drop the manifesto to end all manifestos.
I was not very confident as the evidence against him was already
damning. He literally admitted fault. Aaron tells Destiny, "You
distributed it non-consensually." And Destiny replies, "Yeah,
I know. I have damaged her severely." He tells Pixie, "Uh, I'm
so sorry. There's literally zero excuse." But he tries to recontextualize
this in our interview. When I sent that message to Pixie, I was
like, "Um, I feeling horrible. Like, I'm so sorry. Like, I've
psychologically damaged you. like this is horrible. Whatever.
I do feel I I wish Willy I hope Willie asks him. Are we going
to ban people for trying to spoil? Is that sped up? Oh, I don't
think it's sped up. Hold on. Is it? No, it's it's regular speed.
And I don't think we're going to ban people like try not to spoil,
guys, if you if you can help it. Okay. Um yeah, try not to. Oh
my god. All of you are very far off.
So with uh with Willie Mac here, what he really should be asking
is like, okay, then why did you tell Aaron that you violated
her trust? Or was it Aaron? I think it was Aaron that you violated
her trust in the worst possible way. Why was that something you
said specifically? I violated her trust in the worst possible
way. What does that mean? How did you violate her trust in the
worst possible way by somebody else getting hacked when you had
permission to share the video? That is totally inongruent with
everything being said here. But he's saying it feel horrible.
It has nothing to do with whether or not I consider this on the
video. I also really hope that Willie points that out in the
video at least. He has to point it out in the video, right? He
wouldn't be like enough to not point it out in the video. I'm
almost positive. Can I quickly
Yeah, go. I need to need to respond to this. I am not Cersei.
And in this situation specifically, who would you say Destiny
is? I say Destiny's being a Joffrey.
I literally don't care. You don't care about Game of Thrones?
No. Okay. Well, if Destiny is Joffrey, I'm going to be Oena.
Okay. Run. Okay. Okay. All right. Yo, I just got horrible at
something. We'll see. We'll see. Deius, we'll see. I was involved
in ended up leaking publicly. Like even Okay, I got I got linked
one of the clips that Willie did and he is um like he's actually
so bad at his job that he used me quoting somebody else as proof
that of proof of something that he could easily like sort of
make the argument on. He's actually like so embarrassingly bad
at his job. It's really funny, but we'll get there. Okay, I got
I linked a clip and I'm like, wait, does he did he just like
totally out of context take something and try to make a point
like a complete [__] Complete uh Yes, he did. But
I think most of the video, from what I've heard, most of the
video is actually not that bad. So, I don't want to get into
that too much. Okay. Even if she would have said like even if
that wouldn't have been sent to anybody, if somebody would have
like hacked my Google Drive, I would have said the exact same
thing. So, was this manifesto good? Well, it seems to have persuaded
much of his own community with many of the top comments praising
him. However, when you get down to the meat of the argument he's
making, Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. We don't have to We don't
have to dislike the video because Willie dislikes me. That doesn't
have to happen. That doesn't have to happen. It doesn't change
anything. I confront him about doxing allegations as well as
converse with people from his past. This is the Destiny Manifesto
where there's DMs about you saying like, "Hey, I wish this person
has this person been doxed yet." Yeah. I um for Anna that's or
just uh by the way guys we're on Twitch so if you say things
that are even close to Twitch to in the kick chat you will be
banned. You will not be unbanned. Just good luck if I if I choke
the house. Bro, I swear to God if I quit streaming I'm going
to go on an assassination mission. Okay, this will start disappearing
one at a time. Okay, that's why this Well, that seems pretty
psychotic to just go ahead and threaten violence massively like
that. Uh yeah, cool cool cool. Brother, can we get through the
intro? Cool. Stopped three
The intro. Nope. That's That's what's going to happen. By the
way, Kelly wanted two more people here reacting to this with
us, and she wanted this video to take a thousand years. But yeah,
we'll skip
spends a lot of time clarifying that he is the biggest victim
of these leaks. Incredibly bizarre how many people are fixated
on insisting that I'm not a victim in this when I was the primary
target of the entire revenge posting. While other people were
undeniably harmed by these leaks, they were seen as collateral
damage to the publisher of the material and the website providing
hosting for it in the goal to attack me. Whether it was through
reputation, monetary harm, or just some other form of sadistic
humiliation, nobody is denying that you are also a victim. Nobody
is denying that the hacker is a bad guy. But the only reason
there is collateral damage is you. If you didn't non-consensually
share these girls images, there would be nothing for the hacker
to leak. I feel like he knows this. He's just Wait, you're skipping
video? No, I skipped the Aura advertisement trying to mitigate
accountability in front of his audience. In Destiny's video,
he does provide some background information on the hacker who
goes by the name Solo. Solo messaged me sometime in the morning
and said that he was unhappy with how the coverage of the leaks
had been so far. He felt as though people weren't giving it enough
attention. So, he was going to leak more from my logs with Rose
if I didn't allow him to come on my stream and speak with me.
I don't exactly remember what the message to me was as I just
woken up, read it, and then responded briefly before going back
to sleep. The next time I checked my messages with him, everything
had been deleted. Luckily, I have the messages. The messages
are solar demanding. Destiny talk to him on stream or else he's
going to leak all the mega levels of sweeping by. Yeah, we did.
We didn't sweep anything. We were just like, hey, violating this
person's consent would be insane. The DMs and videos he shared
with Rose. He also threatens to release Rose's real age, saying,
"You were negligent in verifying her age even after you joked
about her looking so young that you would need her ID to make
sure she was really even 18." The only other time I heard this
allegation of Rose being potentially underage is when I interviewed
Kelly Jean. He he tweeted like a bit over a week. Well, listen,
listen. That's probably expected. We should probably expect that.
Ah, Kelly, did you really Did you really make this allegation,
Kelly?
Noation I made. The allegation I made is we don't know who who
she is or what her age is. That was the point, right? It's not
that she is underage. is that we don't know.
Okay, wait, hold on. He did say that you basically called Hold
on. Week ago that the rose girl was an only fans girl. She's
not. She never She never had an Only Fans. She was never on any
platform that could have verified her identity. Why is she known
as like a fansly only fans eagirl? She sold nudes via Twitter.
So, it's not it's not that we're trying to say Destiny's a it's
that we're saying Destiny is reckless. I'm going to be real.
She does end up doing that. It's very much what she would imply.
She'd list all I do not Wait, did you call Okay, why did he say
that? I'm not sure. So, I I sent him a message earlier and we
had we did speak a bit, but he didn't reply to me as to why he
thought that. I It might be a little bit of miscommunication.
I'm not sure.
Well, surely listen, Willie Mack is a journalist who does on
the ground interviews. He gets firstirhand accounts. Okay. obviously
all this evidence for why Destiny should have been suspicious
which actually I think he probably is gonna prove it but I should
probably be sus more suspicious of Kelly but that she was underage
also didn't bother to check someone's like age right it's like
a she never should she claim she was underage
she said she was 19 to him that is true but she also said or
18 or 19 I think she said in messages she was 18 and then turned
19 is most likely the case she was also saying oh I can't she
was saying to Destiny I can't come see you cuz my parents won't
let me. So, there was like a lot of like um within these messages
sort of tone indicators that this is a very young person. So,
when someone says only fans, they're spreading a piece of misinformation
in his benefit. Because if she did do Only Fans, he could say,
"Well, that this website, which is known for verifying people's
identity and age, uh oh, did Willie didn't say she was an Only
Fans girl, did he?" Cuz that's the only reason you would reject
this obviously true argument, right? Did Willie say she was on
Only Fans? It was Nicholas that said it. Um I don't know if he
perpetuated it specifically or other people did. I was just making
it clear cuz a lot of people have perpetuated that misinformation
cuz like the the only reason you you'd be shaking your head here
cuz you just shook his head when hearing like clearly true
information that is is that you had perpetuated that that misinformation,
the Only Fans thing, and you go, "No, no, no. that wasn't really
like misleading people, but it's like, yeah, no, obviously it
would be like the person did not do any amount of due diligence
here. Well, that this website, which is known for verifying people's
identity and age, uh, says she's 19. Therefore, it's reasonable
to think that she's 19. In this case, I personally feel like
that is too convoluted of an argument. And if she lied about
her age, I'm probably not going to hold him accountable unless
I see evidence that
Okay. Um, okay. is very obvious that she's lying or he asked
for ID or some and she's going no though he does do that. He
kind of he makes he makes a message saying I I'll have Yes. I'll
have to find I believe that is Solo that says that right like
you joked about IDing her. Yeah. Yeah. I think this miscommunication
comes from Okay. Yeah. Well, it's I I mean I haven't heard Destiny
content or like Yeah. basically says it's untrue. So of what
when he mentions when he mentions identity Kelly never proves
this. She links me to the hacker telling Destiny she was underage
and Destiny replies saying she told him she was of age selling
not safe for work material. When we started talking she told
me she was of age. The solo guy on Kiwi Farms says as much. I
don't think she's underage. I don't think she was ever underage.
Well, I mean except for when she was underage but before I talked
to her. When navigating Kiwi Farms, the hacker himself would
clarify in a later post to Rose's knowledge Destiny did not know
her real age. And even if he did, he did not make it known to
her. I don't believe Destiny is a Now. Apparently, there are
DMs jokingly asking for ID, commenting on how young she looks.
If I go to a club and I someone underage, it doesn't matter that
I ask for their age. If they turn out to be younger, you're still
going to get prosecuted the same way. I don't think anybody's
implying. I mean, unless you think eight anybody being attracted
to anybody below the age of 18 makes you automatically, which
would be unless you think the consequences that's like not the
argument being made. Kelly's making a statutory law argument.
Go ahead. Yeah. The consequences that I'm talking about are not
being a right. There are things that you can do in life that
are bad that don't make you. And in this case, the issue is that
someone under 18 has distributed which would be CP potentially
and you have saved it and potentially sent it other people. Oh,
that's actually an even better argument. Yeah. And also you have
then um sent non-consentual
uh to them as well. Right. So there's two issues there. if someone
is under 18. Uh, again, we don't know. It's I don't think he's
a I think he's a reckless. But that's the argument I'm making.
And the argument I'm making right here is um that the responsibility
to verify identification if you're the adult is it's always on
you. Sure. What would I say here? I'd say probably the idea that
he was paying for CP is uh fairly off-putting. Um how much should
he be blamed for it? I don't know. If he's joking, if you're
repeatedly joking about how young she looks and how her parents
need to like let her go and hang out with you and stuff, I feel
like it's like a little odd. It's like a little like it's weird
to lean into it when the person's that young. I don't know. It's
It's kind of gross. But just quickly to the big person, the age
of consent is 16 in the UK as well. Okay. But I just said under
age there. I didn't say if you [__] someone that's
17 in a club, did I? I said the onus is on you to check these
things and if you're not doing it then you're just going to suffer
the consequences if you're playing constant Russian roulette
with random online. You deserve the consequences. Sure. This
one like I don't super care about. I would just say it probably
is weird that he would have been talking to this woman who's
under 18. Like if it came out if it came out. Um I don't know
if we'll ever find out who that is. I would imagine I would imagine
Destiny found out who it is. I I I'm almost positive Destiny
would know who this person is at this point. I don't even know
if he does. No, I think I think he hired a private eye. He said
he hired a private eye at some point in the past. And I I think
I found this person. Why hasn't he bragged about it yet then?
True, true, true. Why hasn't he bragged about it yet? That's
very interesting. Uh we'll see. We'll see eventually. I'm sure
eventually things will come out. We will see. We will see. Anyway,
we we can keep going here. I don't think this is like I don't
think this makes Kelly look unhinged. I don't think it like like
I think Willy's I I don't know why Willie wants to make Kelly
look like she's arguing something totally insane. That seems
to be the direction he's leaning in. I don't think she's arguing
something totally insane. But I mean, it's a Willie Mack video.
There'll be bad arguments. There will be complete incapability
of there will be a complete incapability of of engaging with
hypothetical or you know any chain of re reasoning that's beyond
like one link. So way it'll happen. It's like the onus is on
you. You can use that as a defense only to a point especially
if there are if there are other reasons to believe this person
could be underage as there is in this case um or at least you
are not sure. No, I don't think we can confirm their identity.
So, Rose's boyfriend says she was 17 at the time, and I don't
know if she says she was 18 or 19 at the time of sending things.
I get what you're getting at. I need more before I'm comfortable
going that far. Kelly wasn't able to ever find me this message,
so I asked Destiny about it. Did she ever engage with you or
like show you like a site where maybe it did
for age verification at any point? No. Oh, Destiny's going to
be super I think Oh, this is a good question from Willie. I don't
know if he realizes it. This is a fantastic question from Willie
because Destiny is now sitting here and he's like, if I answer
this question honestly, I look kind of bad. But if I lie, then
that gives the solo person the chance to leak more DMs of mine
where I basically to prove that like I didn't do this. I think
that's what he's concerned about right now. Pretty sure the PI
was for figuring out who the leaker's ID was. Vuve, would you
not send your private eye like any information you had about
the girl who had the account so that they could go and track
from there? How could you find the the quote unquote hacker without
finding it without talking to the girl or without seeing the
girl first? She would have the most knowledge about who had compromised
her account. No, that's I think you're just engaging in like
level one reasoning there. You didn't think past the first level.
Yeah. Anyway, I'm trying to think of how much
Well, the answer is Yes. Yes. Yeah. So, like she was like an
active user of um I think Tinder to find some and Tinder does
um is an 18 or uh what? Tinder does not verify IDs. Wait, what?
Tinder doesn't verify IDs. What? There's a ton of underage people
on Twitter. What? Yes. Or sorry, Tinder. Tinder Tinder doesn't
verify properly either. Yeah, I know that there's a ton of underage
people on Tinder. Why is he pretending when he 18-year-olds that
he doesn't know that? I guarantee you if he was an 18-year-old
he just met from Tinder, he's checking that ID. He absolutely
knows. He absolutely knows this.
Yeah, I did put some like evidence of that in the Discord just
here if you wanted to like bring it up on the stream because
Do we need evidence of that? Like that's actually just a completely
thing to say. I think it's good to have like a visual demonstration
of how stupid he is. But you can always just Google does Tinder
always verify age. This is like saying no. No, nobody under 18
has ever accessed a site. There's a button there that says leave
if you're under 18. Nobody. What do you mean? Of course, everybody
who's ever accessed a site is over 18. Okay.
Yeah, it's very stupid. And he should know better. If I have
to be ultra good faith to Destiny, possibly because he's a notable
person, he has done the identif like the ID
verification, but he's not enough to think everyone does that.
Well, no, no, I'm saying when you see somebody who's like youngish
on Tinder, every single person knows. I know this. Uh Darius
knows this. I've watched Darius get by this. Like Darius basically
asks somebody who's like young, he's like, "Wait, how old are
you?" And they're like, "Yeah, I'm like 17." and he's like ends
the conversation, right? I've watched it happen. I know there
are people who are 16, 17 on Tinder. Everybody knows this. Tinder
does use ID to verify your over 18 in some locations. It does
in some locations, yes, but it doesn't in all locations, and
it broadly didn't in 2022 when this happened, when they met.
It really didn't. And also, there are two levels of verification.
There is just like photo verification. So, if you look older,
you might still not have to send in your ID. So, it's like, yeah,
it's cool. Really?
That's Willie would know this, wouldn't he? Willie would definitely
know this, right? That Tinder doesn't verify age. That most places
Tinder does not verify age. And you could definitely get on Tinder
without age verification. He would point that out. But, uh, to
be fair, he said he didn't know and that he might be considering
I think he might be considering doing some other stuff. So, yeah.
But a little bit disappointing he didn't find that out. But,
yeah. Yas says, "Hey, yes, you can use it without verification,
but when you verify, you get a blue check mark." How did you
verify, Yas? Did you verify by sending your ID in or did you
verify by like giving them a a Facebook profile? Which one?
There's like two verific.
Okay. But I don't think most people do this. The blue check mark
is just taking a picture. I I like I don't need to. Uh, and Yas
called me dumb for not knowing that. Yeah. Okay. Oh, man. I might
lose it. Quite literally it said it like a few minutes ago, so
I don't I might lose it. Older app. And Destiny sent me messages
he had with Rose and her talking about using Tinder. I haven't
used Tinder in like 8 years, so I don't know. Google says it
verifies age. There needs to be more tangible ev
The minimum age requirement for Tinder, depending on your location.
Yeah. Okay. This is Wait. So, just look at either his location
or Rose's location. You're located in the United States and participate
in our ID verification process. Well, if you do, what what is
this highlight? Is this what is this to? This is totally unrelated
to If you're located in the United States and participate voluntarily
in our ID verification process, your information will be used
to undergo a registered vendor check. What is If you're located
in the United States, this is not related to whether or not you
have to ID verify. Why is this here? Is this person incapable
of reading the the screenshots they put into their video? Is
this person actually like is he saying is he making a joke about
Destiny being a registered defender? And I know if so that's
very funny, but I don't think it was intentional. Dude, dude,
dude, dude, dude, dude, dude, dude, dude. There's no way. What?
What is this? What is this highlighting? Like, this makes a point.
this guy. You can also just Google tend to always verify age
and then it's it makes it clear on various like links that it's
it's an optional thing. It's like it'll base it on like do the
AI robots on Tinder think you look abnormally young or have you
changed your birthday like a bunch of times? Then they're going
to be like oh that's kind of sus. Then they might force some
but um otherwise probably not. This is like three different chains
of of stuff. And realistically, if you do any amount of research,
you can find out what state Rose is in, and you could just look
up whether or not the age verification is a requirement there.
The age verification, as I as far as I know, is like the like
a tiny tiny minority of states forced this and probably only
recently. It's just wild that you would Yeah. Not in 2002 uh
22.
This is like not the case. the Only Fans stuff has gotten more
stringent in the past couple of years as well, but I would still
say it was like a decent way to like, yeah, if someone's verified
on Only Fans, you know, they're they're not under 18. But, uh,
there's like a few other websites that also have pretty stringent
like verification.
And there are other things that you can do, but like I think
the point I'm trying to make is just like the level of recklessness
that he engaged in doing this is just like beyond the pale, especially
for someone in his position.
Maybe I don't like I whatever. I I sorry. It's like it's probably
beyond the pale for somebody who has as much to lose as he does.
Like it's I don't necessarily know that I'm like well this person
was selling nudes and you like I could see how you I don't necessarily
think like that's the most criticizable part. Like I could I
I didn't have and by the way I'll just say I didn't think that
this person was underage. I didn't think it was likely they were
underage when I talked to Destiny about this before um before
stuff had gotten leaked, right? Before any nudes had gotten leaked.
And I didn't think like oh she got lied to him about her her
age. I didn't have like a lot of criticism for that. I don't
have a lot of criticism for that. If if it's whatever cuz you're
a man. I got to be honest. All of the people that are being like
having this opinion of being blas about it, you're all men. From
my perspective, it's horrific and I think that you should grow
up if you're in your 30s. I'll just behaving like this with potential
children. I'll make sure my opinion's on the record, okay? And
we can uh go from there. I'm but I'm fine with your opinion if
that's how you feel about it. Okay. I need to grab some water
and use the bathroom. I'll be 2 seconds, but I can pause if you
want to have commentary, Kelly. Okay. and I'm listening. So,
if I have commentary, I'll come back and say it too. Back it
up just a little bit. Fine. And Tinder does um is an 18 or older
app. And Dustin sent me messages he had with Rose and her talking
about using Tinder. I haven't used Tinder in like 8 years, so
I don't know. Google says it verifies age. There needs to be
more tangible evidence. Right now, the worst case scenario is
that she might have lied to him. And that's the end of the good
news for Destiny. Like, yes, congrats. You're not a But the few
extra wins he racks up during his manifesto are just so insignificant.
You know, yes, Pixie did ask for a comical amount of money. Her
first demand letter to me was for a a total apology and then
at least $15 million in compensation. Just randomly
the or did he just have a stroke? I'm not entirely sure. Mystical.
He muted it. You stupid. God, he's so dumb. No, I wasn't at my
computer. I was I was getting water and stuff. Um, but I had
to pause there because just to be clear, the 15 million number
here, okay, the 15 million number is that's not meant to be a
real like demand. That's meant to be like the the engaging point
for starting negotiations. That's like if if literally everything
we could possibly want happens, this is what we want, right?
That is not the true engagement point. That's not true like a
true number they were seeking. It's not the number they put in
in uh court. It's it's literally just the the if everything we've
alleged here is true and you show no remorse and there is nothing
else like maximum penalties. This is what we think we could get.
Right. It's it's like a negotiating point. It's just it's so
insane. And by the way, it's not supposed to be public. It can't
prejudice a jury. Like if if this was a jury trial or something.
No, sorry. Sorry. Can't prejudice a jury. It can't prejudice
anything. It is not meant to be. It's not valid evidence in court
that somebody's like trying to extort you. It's not valid evidence
of anything. It is It's supposed to be completely off the record.
It's in incredibly bad taste to leak this. Now, Destiny's lawyer
probably told him to do it, but you you're not supposed to leak
pre-trial negotiations. You're not supposed to do it. So, I just
want to make that clear with the 15 million. This isn't This
isn't like a real demand. That's not like what Pixie actually
would have asked for in court. People weaponizing the news against
you is wrong. Too hard. The stuff we've already spoken about
a million times. is now in an impossible position. A revenge
point of me was still being blasted across the internet with
a family members, including my 13-year-old son, being spammed
with explicit videos of me, sometimes even by popular social
media personalities like Justin Minkx. I guess it's cuz I'm a
guy at school. I'm trying to get better, but the image of Destiny
sucking that is ruining it based. And then this is just her casually,
you know, replying to tweets uh of mine. You know, it's good.
Yeah, I think posting revenge of Destiny is up.
Yep. Literally everybody is like, "Hey, that's up that Minkx
was posting revenge of you. That's actually really up. Minkx,
what a loser. How is that relevant to you sending of people without
their consent? How is that relevant? How is that relevant?" Getting
some good uh getting some good Twitter engagement here. Not that
anybody gives a because she's a girl and I'm a guy, but you know,
it's all good. Sue her. Sue all of them. Hold them accountable.
But why would this make me view the Pixie situation any differently?
What you're complaining about is what Pixie and everyone else
you shared videos of has to go through now, too. You chose to
share videos of yourself with an egirl. They didn't. You made
that decision for them. He acts like this is a risk everybody
signed up for, which is not true. For people who are extremely
concerned with our privacy or material, oh my god, Lily got through
a sentence and said something correct. It's crazy. Possibly leaking.
I generally just recommend that we don't record anything at all
as there's always some risk that stuff can leak. What he's not
acknowledging is the risk was him. I'm seeing Destiny in his
DGG chat saying he's not going to sue the hacker anymore. I'm
probably not going to push it any farther since it's just bad
publicity for me now. And Pixie is forcing us both to waste tens
of thousands of dollars fighting each other now. Lol W. So I'm
like again we've obviously talked about it. So Destiny Destiny
got stabbed. Destiny stabbed Pixie. And Destiny's like, "Wait,
wait, wait, wait. Oh, sorry. Destiny got stabbed and Pixie got
stabbed by the same person." Okay. And then Destiny pulled out
a knife and stabbed Pixie. Okay. Technically, you stab first,
but in any case, he'd done some harm to Pixie, right? He had
violated Pixie's consent. He had sent stuff away without Pixie's
consent. He had done a violation to Pixie, and he's trying to
go, "Wait, we were violated more by this other party." It's like,
who? Yeah, we don't know who that is. Who? That's not relevant
to the wrong you've done you've done to Pixie, obviously. Why
bring it up? supposed to care about the Saabb story with Minkx
and Kiwi Farms hosting his nudes when he doesn't even want to
pursue the culprits anymore. It's incredibly bizarre how many
people are fixated on insisting that I'm not a victim in this
when I was the primary target of the entire revenge posting while
other people were Kelly. Why are you talking in in Kickhat instead
of here? So that you don't keep pausing the video so that you
can keep going. Okay. Undeniably harmed by these. Uh you should
still give commentary. Leaks. They were seen as collateral damage
to the publisher of the material. Pausing the video.
Yeah. So give commentary. you will anything. That's literally
the point. I have been when something new happens.
I haven't said anything. I'll slow down and comment on everything.
So, you might as well get your words in cuz I'm going to be commenting.
If you want to just sit here and say nothing for a while, that's
fine. But I'm going to pause on stuff where I have thoughts.
I don't care if it's new or not. I'm not going through this.
I'm just telling you, I'm not going through this fast cuz people
are coming on later. Okay, go ahead. No, I'm not saying you should
go faster, but me speaking is going to make it slower and you're
causing an argument for no reason. And also I have given commentary
when something has been new but I don't feel it's adding much
by going over like the old stuff again that's been gone over
like 10 times already. Oh I'm going to always keep posting and
the website providing hosting for it in the goal to attack me
whether it was through reputation monetary harm or just some
other form of sadistic humiliation. You were the primary target
but the collateral damage is because of you. Destiny never acknowledges
this. He has the money to do it all. He's mad at Pixie though
because in her story he's not the victim. He's the bad guy. Now
Pixie took him to court. And part of when you do that is you
don't get an instant public facing apology. I understand that.
But instead of staying quiet, Destiny claims he had implied consent
because Pixie sent a video of herself with another guy before.
With that out of the way, conversations guessing as to what if
she didn't, then that's a massive claim and dishonest, especially
the victim points about people gropers sending it to his kids.
A thing he brought on with his recklessness, all the more reason
to not engage in the conduct he did. Sure. I don't know what
the if she didn't part. Whether or not any of the leaked material
was consensually shared was a hot topic of discussion. Following
the initial leaks, she's wild if she actually posted him on the
the Felicie pipeline. Oh, Minkx. Sure. Yeah, but we disavow Minkx.
Pixie would send messages to people to tell them that she had
never sent videos of other people to me before and she portrayed
herself in her Substack as though I was the first person to ever
suggest this to her and I was the first person she ever recorded
material with. Um, I know that she's messaged people with stuff
like this. To me, her lying about the nature of their would only
make her a hypocrite. It doesn't make sharing other people's
nudes without their consent. Okay. He doesn't even know if she
didn't have consent. Pixie was comfortable sending me videos
of her and other identifiable men. Uh Pixie definitely had consent.
Obviously, she had consent, by the way. Oh, sorry. Did I Oh,
[__] There's a there's another log here where Okay.
He doesn't even know if she didn't have there's a log from the
manifesto I want to highlight. Was comfortable sending me videos
of her and other identifiable men with them even having saved
the videos on their own phones. Take a video with some guy. I
can send you later if you're interested. So, hold on. Hold on.
So Destiny goes, "I took videos of some guy." But that's not
what Pixie says, is it? Why would he do that? Why would he make
that error there? Pixie sent me videos with some guy. She said,
"Want to send me videos with some guy." It's not some guy, is
it? I took videos with the guy. Well, that doesn't sound like
a one night stand or a one-off thing, does it? The guy. The guy.
It's like she's referenced a guy to Destiny multiple times.
the guy. And Destiny goes, you Destiny goes, "Well, a guy.
Sure, I'll send them to you." I I totally can know. Uh, Fallen
Artorius. I totally can know. You might not be able to know.
I can know,
but that's fine. When I get them. At no point in any of these
conversations did Pixie ever mention. Just he has to do that
disingenuous malicious lie to try to twist the narrative, right?
So, he has to do things like that. having explicit consent from
any of these other men to share these videos with me. I have
no way of contacting them today to find out if she did. All this
to say, consent was being reasonably understood by both sides
of this situation. What do you mean? How? He's assuming that
she didn't have permission from this guy when he has no reason
to believe that. And in what world does this give him consent
to share her nudes? This makes no sense. This was the manifestos
to end all manifestos. And it's literally debunked by his own
logic in our interview. One of the leaks on Kiwi Farms was a
[__] recording that happened with a guy he met on
Grinder. And the recording allegedly starts before he walks into
the guy's apartment. And if you read the DM of Destiny sharing
the video to Rose, he says, "Wait, does Willie not Has Willie
not listen to this recording? That's crazy. This is just the
end." Again, audio scuffed because my phone was in my pocket,
implying that the video was secretly recorded. Here is Destiny's
defense. Well, why would he have it in his pocket and not record
the thing with the video? It must be because he's not letting
the person know. He's secretly recording. Yeah, sure. So, like,
so here, okay, so let me preface this by saying the only reason
that recording that you're talking about is leaked is because
I think all the girls that started messaging afterwards who like,
"Oh my god, this might be nonexual, blah, blah, blah." I think
that group of people started leaking to Kiwi Farms of hookups
that nobody is alleging anything wrong has happened. So, it's
very Oh my god. Oh my god. Is that bad? Wait, is that a bad thing?
This is I am I am shocked that Willie is capable of understanding
and formulating this argument. I can see it. What he's arguing
is well he just said Destiny's Destiny's argument is undone by
our interview later. And now he's talking about the interview
where Destiny says well nobody alleged any wrongdoing there.
Why would that be brought up at all? Well your manifesto Destiny
is basically doing the that exact thing to Pixie. You're saying
oh well I don't know if her boyfriend consented and I made a
bunch of assumptions. It's like nobody alleged any wrong doing
their Destiny. Why would you assume that there was no consent?
And then you ask for that charity on the audio, but you don't
give that charity to Pixie. In fact, you publicize with Pixie.
Oh, it's almost like you don't have any principles. You don't
care about this at all, and you're just trying to win desperately.
I'm I'm very shocked that Willie could actually like thread this
needle. Annoying. And that what you're talking about like literally
audio that entire thing is now just public for no reason. So
that is revenge of me posted that everybody's just spreading
cuz it's [__] epic and hilarious. Okay, that makes
sense to me. If the guy involved isn't claiming wrongdoing at
this point, who cares? It's irrelevant. That being said, generally
with guys on gr there are guys that I've spoken with and some
people like, hey, are you happy or are you comfortable recording
stuff? Do you want to do video? Most guys aren't comfortable
with video. A couple have been obviously, hence my leaks. Um,
some guys are like, "Okay, cool." You know, like audio is fine.
I don't care as long as you can't identify. That's why I don't
even know how many of my things have been linked to at this point,
but like it's pretty obvious the guy can like see my phone or
he said like, "Oh, whatever." Um, I think for that particular
one now, I think this recording was like,
by the way, in this recording, Destiny pulls out his phone after
he comes and stops the recording with the guy like I I mean,
you don't know for sure the guy is still in the room, but literally
in the room in the room where he gets blown, he pulls his phone
out and stops recording. So, like if the guy was really upset
or really concerned about the phone being pulled out, why the
did Destiny pull it out and stop recording? Can somebody explain
that to me? I I would just love for somebody to explain that.
Can someone explain how the [__] how how that could
possibly make sense? This guy was terrified of me recording uh
his face or seeing the phone actually. But also, I pulled the
phone out. I I pulled the phone out and I stopped the recording.
Wait, what? Okay. I mean, okay, I guess. I guess so. five years
or four years ago, so I don't remember. But for this particular
guy, um he had said, "Listen, if you want to record audio, that's
fine, but like don't pull your phone out. I don't want to see
it. I'm like really paranoid about my face getting recorded."
And I'm like, "Okay, I'll just probably start it before I come
to the apartment." He's like, "That's fine. Just like don't pull
your phone out cuz that would like just like such just an obvious
and lie. You'd have to be you'd actually have to have like an
ADIQ to believe this or lower. You'd have to be like the dumbest
human being on Earth to believe this. After all of the other
things, you'd have to be so stupid." He's just like paranoid
about like me recording his face. Like, okay, that was the hookup
story for that dude. But it's really gay to talk about this because
well, one, it's actually gay. But then two, also nobody's alleging
like any wrongdoing for any of these hookups. So, it's like really
weird that because other people are literally leaking and spreading
for me and then they're having me like describe like this work,
so I know it's consensual. Like, nobody's even making an allegation
of this. Like I don't know if this is going to turn into like
every single like I don't know if people are going to start leaking
every single video I've ever recorded and they're like I need
you to explain to me like what was like no you're going to make
an allegation about this. Why the [__] was I talking
about all my hookups is cringe and gross and weird but that's
my So apparently you shouldn't make any allegations or any assumptions
about those hookups. But Destiny could totally say well I assume
Pixie didn't have consent and sent me this video. I just assume
Pixie is a horrible person. Yeah. I mean that's for them. Yeah.
If and I'm I'm going to publish that allegation online that she
didn't have consent for that. Uh-huh. He's not complaining about
it. Then how do we know?
That is like actual slander. That's like if you if you want an
example of someone being defamatory and slanderous, that's it.
Such a
But that same logic entirely debunks Destiny's implied consent
defense for Pixie because that guy's not out here complaining.
In fact, Pixie claims she had consent from him, actual consent
to send those videos. She writes, "This is false. This guy was
my ex who consented to sharing. I was not recording random one
night stands. I'll be real, the DMs she links don't really prove
anything. But then a guy named Tom asked the question is the
DMs are actually incredibly convincing if you know the the context.
We've gone through them. Basically, Pixie says, "Hey, how could
anybody know about this?" And he doesn't say anyone else would
know from his end, right? As in if he had consent to share the
videos, he would have said, "Well, I shared it with this person
and this person and this person, and they would know." So the
the texts on her end are actually very convincing if you understand
any context there at all. But Willie doesn't. So is whether or
not you had consent to share the videos. She clarifies, "I had
consent. I believe the courts will exonerate me." So Destiny's
entire defense of calling Pixie a hypocrite is debunked by his
own logic. It comes off as incredibly desperate. She says, "Destiny,
you are now using intimate details of my life against me. I need
you to stop. You've already shared some of my most intimate moments
for the world to see. Why are you forcing me to share more?"
Another defense Destiny alludes to in his response is that he
was part of the scandalous videos, therefore that makes it okay
to share. In a way, Pixie is kind of like the perfect victim.
It seems like she shared nudes with you. You shared them with
a third party. That party got hacked. It all leaks.
Wait, I want to clarify a couple things. Hold on just real quick.
I've never sent nudes that somebody sent me to somebody else.
I've never done that before. It's really weird. I've only ever
sent videos that I'm in. Now, sometimes those videos are with
other people, but like in terms of me sending anything to another
person. It's like it's because I'm in it, not because somebody
else is in it. Just to be super clear on that. To some people
that doesn't matter. for other people. That's like a really big
point because when that post was written for
Okay, I'm going to say it. There's no reason to make that argument,
right? There's no reason to do that in a in an interview you
think will be going public. The only reason he'd make that argument.
I don't think I don't think there's any distinction to make there.
That distinction is purely one thing and it's obvious and Willy's
going to call it out cuz it's obvious to me. Uh I guarantee Queen's
on the same page. If I go watch Queen's VOD, he's going to say
the same thing. All Destiny is trying to do here is make sure
that he continues to get nudes from other people. That's this
is for like other people. This is like a PSA. Hey, if you share
nudes with me, I don't actually share those around. I only share
videos around with me in them. That's all that is. That's very
obvious. That's by the way, that's a mind readad. That is not
like literally obvious and proven. In fact, that is my interpretation
of why he would say there would say that. But anyway, he was
men want to make videos with him ever again or even just that
he's not secretly recording them. I don't but he can't get Yeah.
Yeah. He can't get away with that. But I He's trying to say that
if you send me nudes, you know, you have this frictionless relationship
with me online, you send me nudes, you can keep doing that. You
can keep doing that. It's okay. Like he wanted to show my body
off and blah blah blah. That's not true at all. Like she's not
even naked in that video. That doesn't make any difference to
me. He violated the person's trust in sharing the intimate video
in the first place. Him being part of it or not changes nothing.
Wait one second. Did he just say she's not even naked in that
video? Is he talking about Pixie? Wait, did he That post was
written for Pixie. It was written like he wanted to show my body
off and blah blah blah. That's not true at all. Like she's not
even naked in that video. That doesn't What? That's obviously
false. And obviously Destiny knows that's false because I believe
one of the DMs between Destiny and Pixie says something along
the lines of, "I'm telling people my breasts are look different
than that and that's how you know it's not me." She says that
to Destiny in DMs. Why would Why would Destiny accept that argument
in DMs from her or her saying that or not point out that like,
"Hey, you your your your breasts weren't showing." What? What?
What? What? What is is he saying she's not naked because she
didn't like have her literal like legs spread? Is he?
I don't know. That's just like a I think that's just an open
lie. I am baffled. Yeah, I Why is brother lying? I don't Yeah,
it's just a open lie and she's engaging in like a act so I don't
even know how that would help but okay. Make any difference to
me. he violated the person's trust in sharing the intimate video
in the first place. Him being part of it or not changes nothing.
It seems like the only reason he would bring this up is if he
felt like there was some sort of legal distinction and talking
about anything that's related like
specific and then you say if it can be allowed in the Have you
seen the leaks? Why would I have to have seen the leaks when
I've seen the DMs? I I literally just cited to you why he would
know this without having seen the leaks myself. Why would you
then ask if I've seen the leaks? no video or not. Cuz if not,
I'm not trying to anybody. Okay. Sucking ones were forced upon
you via Twitter against your will. So, I'll just say that much.
Jesus, you very much clarified your part of these videos, too.
Guess what I'm wondering is, does that make a legal distinction?
Is that why you clarified them? There's two Oh, I see where Willy's
going. That's probably a good question. I don't think that's
what it is at all. I think that's him trying to make sure that
he's protecting his like nude his like frictionless nude Discord
girl pipeline. I think that's more where that's coming from.
Like, hey, you don't have to worry about me violating your trust.
I only violate trust when I'm in the videos. I don't know if
like is there a different argument around that? Not under the
Florida laws from what I remember or the federal law, right?
Because you need consent from the other person no matter what.
Like the fact that you're in there doesn't make a difference
legally as far as I know. Yeah, I'm I'm pretty sure the fact
that you're in the video doesn't make a difference under the
Florida laws. Definitely not under the federal law. I don't believe
under the Florida law either. Parts that are really important
that I'm okay comfortable talking about. So, for one part of
legal distinction here, and this is annoying cuz it applies legally
and it applies morally, I think, and I guess it applies to the
PR angle, too. Like I have never ever in my life like tried to
like um like [__] on somebody by like sharing like
a revenge thing of them. You're talking about like the maliciousness
of it, right? Yeah. Because some people saying like, "Oh, I was
trying to like humiliate, you know, like I was trying to humiliate."
No. Never in my life have I done. So, by his definition,
what I did, which I didn't actually do, but had anyone actually
posted any of Lena's like publicly available to purchase, that
was revenge by his definition. So, actually by his definition,
he has me by posting my only fans content everywhere. I haven't
posted a single photo of Lena or otherwise. Um yeah before that
like by his definition of saying you posted revenge of her. Yeah.
By his definition he's posted revenge of you. Yeah. 100%. Yeah.
He's a he's a completely disingenuous. Yeah. I mean we've seen
it a lot. This is actual hypocrisy. It's exceptional.
Yeah. Just in case you have like a very low IQ and you don't
understand the argument. Um, Destiny argued that Kelly posted
revenge of his girlfriend because he's a [__] And
what he thinks Kelly did was somehow I think he blamed Kelly
for a post somewhere where people posted her like paid sort of
like kind of a piracy thing. And then Destiny posted Kelly's
paid only fans content in his own chat. And so by by Destiny
saying that he thinks Kelly revenge his girlfriend, he has also
revenged Kelly. But um he's just a disingenuous so I don't even
know how and I've never posted any of her stuff ever. I have
spoken about it cuz it's funny but I not posted anything or linked
to it either. All right that I would never do well I mean there
was um 14 years ago the one blue tea girl. That was behavior
of me for sure. Blue tea was somebody that Destiny and then shared
their nudes with his buddies. At least according to Ryan Beard's
video an old forum post I could find online. just thought it
would be funny to share this woman's private nudes with his friends
and joke about howing hideous her face. This one is uh guys I
was really young when this happened. I think he was what was
he 23 23 24 compared to her beautiful body and he also insulted
her because he thought she looked like Shrek. So he shared a
woman's private nudes without consent for the purpose of degrading
her. In response, Blue Tea hacked Destiny's Twitter and tweeted
out pictures of his she didn't deserve any of that. That was
me being a or whatever. Like I agree that. Um but like I never
mind. Oh, you guys want me to point out that he mocked Pixie's
technique in the DM? Yeah, he did. So you could say that's humiliating.
I don't know if that quite counts, but maybe it does. Maybe.
I mean, maybe you could argue it does. Like I'm never like sending
videos or pictures like, "Oh yeah, this is going to humiliate
this person." Huh? Like that's just insane. Okay, that claim
is insane. Nothing that's leaked from my logs implies that. I've
never had a conversation leaked that implies that I would ever
do that to somebody. Like that's just wild. Wait, the blue tea
conversation literally does do that. Oh, Will. Oh, Willie trapped
him. Willie might have trapped him. Hey, you did that with Blue
Tea, right? Um, yeah. Just Just to be clear, these Uh-huh. cuz
I have not seen the videos. Just to be clear, there is videos
of pixies that were leaked. She was not aware that you shared
these with Rose. I can't speak to that. I will clarify one thing.
Fair enough. Um, it's video. It's one singular video. The Blue
Tea drama happened in 2012. And if he was caught sharing nudes
then and he was caught sharing nudes now, that means he was probably
sharing nudes in all the years in between. In fact, right after
the Pixie drama blew I mean he just obviously has been. I mean
when you get the you get like Anavar who sent stuff um the mama
girl who has sent stuff like it's just I have a lot of anecdotal
evidence that he's just always been sharing not just not nudes
but like videos and stuff too. It does seem like like the stuff
I've heard about seems to be videos he's in but it's still without
the consent of the people participating the videos. So blew up
in January. DMs from a girl named Hannah showing Destiny seemingly
still trying to share news, saying, "Oof, I guess now that some
stuff is leaked. Lo, if you want videos of me eating, I got them."
She laughs and then says, "Haha, no, don't show me that." Those
are super private. I can't imagine how it feels having something
so private be public, even if you were Polly. Now, this is crazy
because behind the scenes, Pixie is saying he ruined her life
and is posting her note to him less than a month earlier. And
if he was still doing this, that is psychotic behavior. Now,
Destiny would claim that this was all just edgy jokes that took
place when they were flirting. He deleted his DM. So, I mean,
you can say it's just edgy jokes, but it seems kind of up to
to be like, I violated this person's trust in the in the worst
possible way. And then direct them to the place with all of that
content for looking for that content explicitly. Seems kind of
crazy. That's just me. I think it seems kind of crazy. So, it's
hard to understand the full context. There's this is like half
on the record, off record. I don't give a figure out what you
want to put on. Okay. But here's a lot of dark humor. Okay. I've
made jokes about a lot of things that people come back and try
to make me sound like a sociopath. Like me and my kid's mom used
to be physically abusive towards each other. Um, and some people
will link clips of me talking about it 10 years ago. I said he
said he used to choke out his ex. Even if he went down to hold
her to stop throwing instead of hitting her, I'm almost 100%
sure everyone would be saying the same. He had to leave her.
He is going, "Yeah, I of course he offered me content while she
was he did. He doesn't really think about other human beings
like they're human beings. That's just that's just facts. That's
just obvious from every everything he does and how he acts."
Dude, I wish I would have filmed my with Rachel. I wouldn't have
any fans today cuz you guys would probably think I'm aing abuser,
too. Guaranteed. Cuz you bettering believe I had to choke her
out a few times. That got crazy. Hell yeah it did. And I guarantee
you that everybody here probably think I'm aing crazy physical
abuser, too. Sure. And like I'm joking when I say this. Or people
say like, "Oh, Destiny's happy that his best friend committed."
Where's the joke? Well, I that's the other thing. Like with the
the doxing thing, he like threatens the docks multiple times.
He's like, "Stop talking about me or I'll dox you people." And
then he we don't stop talking about him and he docks his people.
Tries to dox people. It's like, wait, you weren't joking at all.
You weren't you didn't do that for a legal case. You did that
to intimidate and harass us. It was always a threat. There was
never a joke. And it was never funny. Oh, not funny. H when he
was 20 cuz he jokes about it. It's like I do joke about a lot
of crazy I joke about myself. There's also a sad event. This
So me and Hannah had been chatting maybe for on and off for like
a year. had never been ever, not even remotely on anything ever.
And then as of like, you have the dates on the messages. Was
it like 2 months ago or 3 months ago? It was I think she makes
I think she makes a joke um with about Merc. Oh, and she deleted
all those messages. Very clever. But she makes a joke about Merc,
oh my god, I just saw that crazy girl Murk arguing with her.
And then she's like, just so you know, I would never ever out
any of your advances, lol. And so when I see like, oh, that's
a green light to flirt, I guess. And then I think our next conversation
starts getting more flirty and then she makes a reference to
something.
Okay. I what what I don't understand the relevance here. Okay.
Did the merk content and then she gets like flirty with you about
like videos or like oh like or something or whatever. And I think
I make the joke and I'm like hey listen I videos they're still
up on Kiwi Farms lol. Uh which is true but like why is he talking
about this and saying it here? This is actually Oh, does he?
I guess it's going to be used in court or something. That's okay.
That was the extent of my message. I can't prove anybody right
or wrong here because they both deleted messages. And to be fair
to him, he didn't send anything. But if she said yes to the offer,
would he have? That's Oh, wait, hold on. 1 1925. Isn't that before
any of this came out of my message? I can't prove anybody right.
I thought I thought Hannah messaged him like after this stuff
came out. I didn't realize this was like January 9th. I didn't
realize this was like after or sorry before the President Sunday
videos. I never saw this before. Oh, they were getting before
the President Sunday videos came out. Oh, that's uh that makes
it really different to the offer. Would he have? That's up to
you to decide. Would never I don't want to cuz what he what he
said about the Hannah DMs was that like Hannah was in my Discord
and therefore like she was trying to trap him somehow, right?
But I didn't even I wasn't even like thinking this guy was like
a total scumbag until after the Sunday videos came out and bunch
of went down. You were still yelling at me on the 9th and giving
me a hard time. It's like Kelly, why don't you have empathy for
Destiny by the 9th of January? Well, I would have I trust me.
Yeah, exactly. I had a lot of empathy for this guy before it
came out that he um recorded people non-conensually. Like I thought
this was a sort of a one-off thing, right? I had no idea the
scale that it had gone to. And obviously after that I knew the
scale. I understand you didn't care cuz all you cared about was
Molina, but like I No, I understand. Um I'm not going to What
do you mean only? So you think I didn't know about Pixie then
as well? No, you were mad about it because of the Molina thing.
That's why you were messaging you were talking about and Molina.
Okay. I just I thought basically this was something being handled
in private. That's what I thought about and I was like probably
I don't want to make fun of this guy for like getting his details
exposed.
I didn't realize how prolific a predator he was at the time.
I'm just pointing out we all know it was more than just Mina
at that point. Yeah. So I think probably that's a lot of evidence
that the whole idea that it's like oh I'm a male victim of of
like having my you know contact DMs leaked. It's like I cared
a lot about that. I had a lot of I defended him from Kelly. Right.
It took it took a lot of evidence for me to go oh this guy's
actually just a total scumbag anyway of these people. Okay. But
I will say like I don't want to do any I'm not going to do anything.
Okay. Like there are so many there are so many girls that send
me messages. I'm not even sure who but like there's so many girls
that send me messages like this when everything was leaking.
Okay, hold on. You just sent me something. Let me take a look.
Would find the leaked videos if if I looked, you know, for science.
Damn. So guys, just so you know, I Guys, just so you know, I
Hey, Willie, put this in the video. I want everybody to know
that I Willie, can you make sure everybody knows that I Thank
you. Thank you, Willie. You're still getting hit up even after
Oh man, you you're a dog. You're still getting hit up even after
all this time. Oh my god. Oh my god.
Base labeled an abusive piece of They're still trying to get
Yeah, but I'm just saying I just to give more kind Damn. Damn,
dude. Even when you're like labeled an abusive best predator,
you're still getting hit up. Damn. Damn. It's like the environment
is like everybody back here. Not everybody, but like there's
a lot of corny people. They say like this, whatever. I it's whatever
to me. But like if a message of mine got leaked like that or
I guess like that Hannah girl tried to and it even showed up
in Pixie complaint. He's still offering like no bro people are
hitting me up and they're like flirting with me or whatever.
I'm like hey listen my trips on Kiwi Farms lol. Like that's not
like a sincere offer to send anything and like my is still publicly
hosted so what the do you want me to say? Like, yeah, but it's
it's like people take it way too seriously. Like,
when he references Kiwi Farms and tells people to go there, it's
fine. When uh we talk about Kiwi Farms, we are Kiwi Farms and
we're bad and the devil. Okay. Oh my god, this guy is a complete
on Kiwi Farms, obviously. Yeah, this is maybe the most disingenuous
person. He's just got zero morals, zero anything. Yeah. Yeah,
he obviously he's completely disingenuous on Kiwi Farms. There's
a whole video about it. Hannah girl, right? This is a person
I talked to for a year. No problems whatsoever. After she sends
me that message, I find out like 2 days later, she's also in
Jessica's server. And then she starts spamming my DMs with her
into that server. Like after deleting some of hers. Wait, wait,
wait, wait. Wasn't it the 9th when he was talking when they were
talking? That was like what was that 11 days? That's 11 and 1/2
11 to 11 and 1/2 days before anybody in my server was against
Destiny in any way whatsoever. What are we talking about? Aside
from me, I'm probably Quean cuz Queman's never liked him. But
yeah, uh Queman and I had the exact same public position on this.
You were the person who was too obnoxious to try to protect Pixie's
privacy. Uh excuse me. Firstly, I just said Quimman's never like
destiny. Is that a true statement or not? Okay. Then why be a
and say that then? Cuz you're trying to arandise yourself. You're
trying to So I just had to knock you down a bag real quick. There
you go. Yes.
Exactly. Yes. You're trying to arandise yourself at my expense.
massage. I wasn't little knocking down real quick by these like
random women that I've never had a problem with in my entire
life. Now, I don't know why any woman would trust Destiny enough
to try and hook up with them still after all this, but that is
happening now. Destiny deleting DMs is interesting because Pixie's
legal team we have to show it a second time. We had to show the
DM a second time. Cited him doing this as a way to try and cover
up evidence. On January 21st, 2025, aware of the impending lawsuit
and potential criminal investigation, Bonnel starts destroying
evidence, including deleting messages between him and the plaintiff.
Is this something you have done to try and hide or cover up anything?
Oh, Kger wanted to make it clear that Hannah and Desi didn't
both talk sexually. It was just uh Well, I think I think I would
disagree, Creger. I'd say when Hannah says, "I'd never out your
advances." I like that is an invite to like, "Hey, we could flirt
more." Like, absolutely. It's not an invite to hey send me non-consensual
send me send me links or or references to non-consentual obviously
alerting doesn't have to be super I suppose you can differentiate
this is what I'll say
okay I have a right to delete any message that I want ever okay
number one I think this is like what his lawyers told him I don't
know that that's necessarily true I think there's precedent going
in both directions if he had his lawyers archiving things but
if he if he's destroying chains of evidence I know that you're
allowed to delete evidence if you're if you're destroying like
the actual chain sorry if you're destroying the chain of custody.
I don't know if you're allowed to delete those DMs. You might
have to leave them with a third party. Right. So like unless
his lawyers were supervising this, I don't know. I don't know
that that's actually you're allowed to do that. You you actually
might not be able to do that at all cuz like once you've downloaded
your Discord logs, your archives, what's to prevent you from
editing that HTML, right? I think you get sent like emails to
the dock potentially, but then I think they expire after a certain
point. So yeah, you have to prove that. Well, I'm I'm talking
about um like when you use Discord exporter or whatever like
log exporters.
Sure. I'm talking about like the file they send you like the
file via email, right, after a certain amount of time because
it takes them quite a while to send you that archive. I'm talking
about different things. I'm talking about the actual archiving
clients you'd use like Redact or Discrub or these things you're
talking about. Yes. Discord themselves or something. Yeah. Obviously,
you would just not use those programs. You would send them the
initial file that you got downloaded, right? Because if you haven't
edited it, then it Yeah, you you wouldn't be able to edit it
without it showing up in like the it's not exit data be some
kind of equivalent. I don't know. Also, it does prevent further
victims from coming forward because they lost access to the evidence.
Yeah. Like I'm sure a lot of a lot of people would have evidence
of these crimes and if he just wipes all of his DMs then it's
like oh well they hadn't made an allegation against me yet. Yeah.
You are you are actually wiping out potentially like other people
who have evidence of crimes. You're doing it because you've been
you've been alerted that now people have like some understanding
and are looking to sue you or pursue you criminally. Right. So
number two if somebody wants to talk about records for a court
case. So for instance typically you file a civil suit against
somebody you'll send them like a request for preservation of
evidence. Um, that doesn't mean I can't delete my message on
Discord. It just means that I need to make a backup or an archive
of anything that I have deleted on Discord that's not available
to other people to make sure I have my own records there so that
I can send that if a request has made a discovery. I complied
100% with any preservation evidence request that's been made
to me 100%. So, did um we know that's not true, right? Can you
move me in? Sorry, I asked Ry to give me the perms to move me,
but he told me he didn't me. Yeah, sure. Hello. Hi. How are you?
Good. How are you doing? Not bad. Oh, we're pretty good, I think.
Yeah, pretty good. He's just giving me a male headache, so this
might balance out a bit. How's stuff going on your end? Okay.
Okay. Sorry, I was getting an echo cuz I was I'm sorry. You had
multiple things up. It's okay. Take your time. Donald Trump just
tipped $5. JD, give me one second. Actually, beats the radical
left. Pope Francis hours later hope gone JD strength unbelievable
hope weak very low energy thank you for the donation guys if
you want to donate yourselves you can type exclamation donate
in any of the chats twitch chat kick chat uh probably not Twitter
actually but you can type exclamation exclamation point donate
that will have the kickbot link the streamlabs link you can do
a TTS of your own with a funny AI voice on over on kickbot $5
minimum guys every dollar you spend goes towards more time on
the stream. You if that's not the only way you can donate, by
the way, you can give subs on kick. You could sub with your primer.
You can do so many things. So many different things. And every
dollar goes towards more time on the stream. We are currently,
I guess, $55 away from another two hours on the stream. I combine
those today so we could go longer. Yeah. So, yeah, if you guys
enjoy the content, please go ahead help help out any way you
can. Every dollar counts. All right. Every dollar counts. And
well, what else is there? There was there was all those there's
the Patreon as well. So yeah, give subs on kick, sub individually
on kick. I love individual subs on kick. Those are my favorite
thing ever. Okay, thank you for all of your support. Also, last
but not least, there's Patreon, guys. patreon.com/jlk. If you
want to support me off platform,
super helpful if if you support me off platform, okay, there's
a couple different tiers. Uh 5,5 $100 tiers, okay? $100 tier
gets a special Discord color. Uh Space Ghost, thank you for the
gifted sub to just one guy as well. Um yeah, multiple different
tiers. Thank you very much for your support. Okay. Thank you.
Thank you. Thank you. Sorry, I was trying to improvise a shill
in there while Kimmy was coming in. Uh-huh. Is Top Bronson around?
That's who did the pictures, right? Yeah. Yeah. Maybe he he'll
probably do one at some point if he's here. A little uh also
Yep. Yep. Also, hi. You ready to go? Me? Yes. Okay. Well, how
how have things been on your end? You asked us how we are. We
didn't hear from you. Oh, yeah. Things are really good. I'm learning
how to do child- centered play therapy and uh I have like you
know I'm like doing therapy with like fouryear-olds now. It's
it's going really well. Yeah. A lot of kids with oppositional
defiant disorder. Oh really? Yeah. Yeah. A lot of boys I'm guessing.
Um mostly a lot of boys. Yeah. Some girls too, but they mostly
have like ADHD and autism. The girls that the young girls that
I see. But yeah, no, things are really good and um yeah, I have
some thoughts on the video. Uh I did watch it today. Um I was
able to watch it. Um yeah. Okay, we're only 23 minutes in. So
if you want to hop into the presentation, we're actually watching
it actively right now.
How could you just say KJ Missandre?
Uh because your first your first reaction to being like I'm giving
therapy to these people for oppositional define arc was lots
of boys then. Hey,
boys do have that. It's It's true. Yeah, Kelly's right. More
boys do tend to have oppositional defiant disorder. Or maybe
it's just that they're more often diagnosed with it. I mean,
honestly, something like 50% of the genders commit like 95% of
the oppositional define disorder. Hey, why would you just assume
that I'm being was wrong? Why? When am I ever wrong? I didn't
think you were wrong.
Wrong.
Wait, I didn't think you were wrong. So why would that make me
committing
Uh cuz you have to point it out cuz you were also just talking
about men before this like multiple times. Another instance when
by saying you were giving me a headache that only men don't care
about um some dude a 17-year-old or something and all this other
stuff because the only people that I had been speaking to that
gave those type of I think you said you had a headache because
of male moments or something earlier as well. No, because of
you. Okay. Oh, I do have to just warn you guys. Like I'm going
to So, okay, when the when you play the video and it gets to
the part where it's like the Zirka panel where I'm like crying
and stuff, I'm definitely going to like I'm definitely going
to just step away and mute on that part cuz I don't I don't like
listening to my
Yeah, I understand. Um, we can we can I can message you if if
we get to a pause. We can message you when when it comes up or
when I appreciate that. I do. You're avoiding something else
in this video probably. So I that's fine. Yeah, I can find it.
Video provoke. Cool, cool, cool, cool. Let's go you into
delety. I have complied 100% with any preservation evidence request
that's been made to me 100%. So did some video provoke you into
deleting more messages?
It was either that or before. Yeah, when I when people started
to like paste like for me around, I started No, actually it was
I think in December I think I started running a redact across
my whole account. It took like a month or whatever to finish.
But I like basically every I mean I I hope I hope they get this
stuff in discovery. This is just factually incorrect. He's just
lying here December. I said before January 1st I wiped from every
message cuz I was like I don't know. Um, oh, because my my main
concern, it wasn't actually even related to like Pixie or anything
else, but my main concern was one thing that I didn't think about
um that I have to think about. Um, when people people interpreted
this, I guess if you want, this could be on the record. I don't
care. Um, no, like this everything you said so far regarding
this, I'm assuming is on the record, right? Okay. When I sent
that message to Pixie, I was like, um, I
feel horrible. Like, I'm so sorry. Oh, yes, yes, yes. Hey, lol.
I know you v I violated your trust in the worst way ever. Right?
Why did he say, "Hey, I know I violated your trust in the worst
way ever if he didn't send this non-consensually." Where's the
trust violation? If he had consent to share it,
right? That's the most important part of this to highlight, but
I don't think Nicholas Deoro highlighted it. So, I think Willy's
unaware like I've psychologically damaged. You're like, "This
is horrible." Whatever. I do feel horrible. It has nothing to
do with whether or not I consent this on the video. I just feel
horrible. something that I was involved in ended up leaking publicly.
So, he's saying he preserved the deleted DMs for the court case
only, but he's also recontextualizing DMs of him admitting fault.
If you remember, Destiny replied to Nick, I didn't Oh, look,
look, look, look, look. He's also recontextualizing DMs of him.
If you remember, Destiny replied to Nick, I didn't admit to anything.
Nick would reply with DMs of Destiny saying, "Yeah, I know. I
have damaged her severely." Seemingly acknowledging that he's
the one responsible. He's now saying that this is not the case.
Like even if she would have said like even if that wouldn't have
been sent to anybody, if somebody would have like hacked my Google
Drive, I would have said the exact same thing. Holy no, you but
but hold on. You wouldn't have said this part, right? You wouldn't
have said, "Hey, I know I violated your trust in the worst way
ever, but here's some money. Have fun." Right? Like I think we
can all agree that this is just an obvious dis obviously disproves
what he's saying. There's no reason to say that if you've just
been hacked and you did nothing wrong, right? Beep beep. I uh
put both of the time stamps into the dock so and I'll let you
know. Well, I mean, I'm probably not going to be super aware.
You just let me know when we're coming up to them. It's fine.
Yeah, honestly, we'll have lots of lots of So, he's saying he
preserved the deleted DMs for the court case only, but he's also
recontextualizing DMs of him admitting fault. If you remember,
Destiny replied to Nick, "I didn't admit to anything." Nick would
reply with DMs of Destiny saying, "Yeah, I know. I have damaged
her severely. Seemingly acknowledging that he's the one responsible.
He's now saying that this is not the case. Like even if she would
have said like to anybody, if somebody would have like hacked
my Google Drive, I would have said the exact same thing. Holy,
I feel so horrible. I'm so sorry. This is like terrible. Like
I'm sorry. You didn't deserve this at all. Like this is really
bad. I'm so sorry. Like it has nothing to do with whether or
not consensually. It just has to do with the fact that because
of like whatever my actions or whatever um like at some point
like [__] got leaked. God, if only he'd read the
rest of the messages. He like only looked at the yellow highlighted
part. That's so unfortunate for this video that he only looked
at the yellow highlighted part and didn't read the full messages
there. Literally just 8 seconds more of work and this would have
been Destiny would have been like asked about this and he would
have had no answer. Hey, why did you say you violated her trust
in the worst way ever? It's it's like an immediate slam dunk
and it's on the same screen. He's literally showing it. That
being said, oh god, who is he? Uh Willie Mac. I'm just saying
like he he he asked that question. Wait, maybe he asked that
question. Maybe I'm being way too harsh. Maybe I am maybe I'm
being way too harsh and he actually asked that question. Oh,
well, I was going to say that being said, one thing that I just
and maybe it was just me being stupid, but one thing I never
considered before was regardless of if I'm vetting people appropriately
or not for sending material, I never considered what if somebody
else gets on somebody else's account. So after stuff started
leaking like in November or like I think in early December, I
started to run a redact on everything cuz now I'm thinking well
what if like a boyfriend, a sister, a father, what if somebody
dies and like a friend gets a hold of their account and they
log in and they see a bunch of explicit material. I'm just going
to everything cuz I don't want to risk like other people or my
as a result of that. Did you delete anything?
Quick request. Is there a way to keep up that red bar so I can
tell what the time is?
No, but I we're not going to get Trust me. I don't think there's
going to be any issue here with like a millisecond of something
showing and there'll be lots of context going into these what
we're going to go to. No, there isn't. It's quite quick. But
also, I think if you just keep the mouse over it, it shows the
red bar the whole time. There is your I got it. I got it. I got
it. We won't miss it. We won't miss it. I got to hide stuff for
the corkus. Do that. No, I have I have digital copies of everything.
Just type two. Like literally has an auto archive thing and Discord
allows you to archive all of your conversations before doing
anything. I complied with every core request that I've gotten.
Yeah, the [__]
I feel like I've asked this before, but if you can't be on the
record, fair enough to. But I just want to reiterate since we
brought it up. Wait, what is it? The music is throwing me off
now again. Did Pixie ever know you were sharing stuff with Rose?
That involved her? It's both of you. I understand. But that involves
for claims that are like these are like the hyperspecific claims
that this court case is going to deal with. I can't advice with
council. I can't talk about those things in particular. Okay,
fair enough. Then I will say that when we recorded stuff, I was
either married to or I was um engaged with Molina at the time.
Um and so I mean at the very least like that's one person that
Oh, thank you. Oh, hold on. That was a fantastic What the does
that matter? I'd be sharing stuff with that you would know obviously,
right? But what is he on about? He's already said it. He's taking
responsibility without taking responsibility. It's hilarious.
If you're still defending Destiny over this Pixie stuff, why?
Like this is really bad. I'm so sorry. Like it has nothing to
do with whether or not consensually. It just has to do with the
fact that because of like whatever my actions or whatever um
like at some point like got leaked. I find it absurd that he's
apologized. Oh, that's I'm surprised he he gave up the but for
declaration there. But I guess that you have to, right? Like
but for Destiny's actions, these leaks never happened, right?
Like you cannot Destiny is a critical link in the chain of causality
here that you cannot that this never happens without, right?
It is his actions that guarant that sorry it is his actions that
are required there right the rose thing that was just the first
vector where it got leaked there's a thousand other vectors due
to his actions where this could have happened right but and without
his actions this never happens so not for sharing the videos
non-conensually find out that so the thing about like him sorry
did I interrupt am I interrupting I'm sorry you're good I just
want to say oh yeah yeah I was just going to say that like his
point about like well She knew I was married to Molina. Is that
supposed to be like implying that like oh so like her nudes would
be seen by Molina? Cuz that's interesting because Destiny and
I had a lot of arguments about that specific issue. And he promised
me multiple times that like you know his stuff with like girls
on Discord or whatever is totally private from Molina. Molina
wouldn't see that stuff. So like that's I don't know. Just interesting.
Yikes. Wait, you wouldn't have logs of that, would you? because
that would be very helpful.
I can look for them. I'm just not sure if they were like deleted
or I could certainly look for them, but I don't think I could
do it right now. But yeah, he Oh, yeah. We had that was a really
big issue I had and yeah, a really big concern I had that. Yeah,
that seems like if he's willing to say and wait, did he say like
for you all make sure it's private for Molina or do you feel
like he was just saying no, no, Molina doesn't see anything?
Honestly, I So, I you know what? I think this was deleted because
it was over Twitter, I think, that we were having this argument
cuz it was way back in like 2021. But yeah, I just I remember
having a really big issue with it and we got into a big fight
over it and him being like, "No, don't worry. Molina doesn't
see that stuff. He she doesn't see the stuff that I talk about
with different Discord girls or whatever." And she would never
see he would never leak. that's stuff to Molina or whatever.
But then I remember like because I remember him saying on stream
or something that like oh he and Molina share like their Discord
usernames and stuff. So I I think that's what triggered the argument.
But yeah.
So he said that publicly as well at some point. Yeah, I believe
so. Destiny, you are scum and you lie through your teeth as much
as you breathe.
True. Well, we're going to continue. like got linked. I find
it absurd that he's apologizing for defending Destiny over this
pixie stuff. Why? Like this is really bad. I'm so sorry. Like
it has nothing to do with whether or not I just consentual. It
just has to do with the fact that because of like whatever my
actions or whatever um like at some point like got leaked. I
find it. Oh, the whole section right here. The whole section
Destiny's narrative entirely crumbles if Willie just reads more
than the yellow highlighted part of those screenshots. The whole
thing crumbles, right? cuz he's saying, "Well, no, I didn't like
I didn't do something wrong. I just felt bad that it got leaked
through me at all." And it's like, "But you said you violated
her trust in the worst way ever." It's so critical. It's so critical.
Absurd that he's apologizing not for sharing the videos non-consensually,
but for the hacker leaking them. Bro, the girls didn't want them
shared in the first place. I can't get into it in the interview
because he wanted all of that off the record. But it all comes
back to this implied consent. Oh, maybe. Hold on. There might
be a chance that Willie did read that and maybe he's saying here
that he couldn't bring it up because he'd agreed to have that
off the record. Possibly. I'll give him that bit of charity.
Possibly. Argument, which we've already determined is ridiculous.
Now, I don't know what the result of their court case will be.
If what he did was illegal, I'm not a lawyer. I don't know. But
I do know that what he did was wrong, and that should be obvious
to everyone. I don't want to set the world on fire.
The biggest video to come out on Destiny was the content nuke
by Ryan Beard. And I wanted to touch on the pattern of abuse
he builds up in it. At some point, if you date enough girls that
are crazy, at some point, do you feel like you are the only consistent
factor there? That's a I just want to point out that um like
I wonder what Ryan Beard would say about this. When Ryan Beard
went out of his way to edit the video to present uh Kimmy differently,
when Ryan went out of his way to say very explicitly like the
like this is a slander he does to these women and Willy's like
immediately leaves it. That's just a tone thing. That's just
that's not a moral criticism. It's for me. I'm just like I bet
Ryan would be annoyed that it was being used that way. But he
is making the point. He's not making the point that like, oh,
all these women are crazy. He's saying, wait, are these women
crazy or are you crazy? So, or are they crazy made? I feel would
be more accurate. For sure. Or I mean, it's also possible that
you could still like attract like like obviously back then I
was mentally ill, okay? Like we all know that. But like I mean
it's also possible to attract like mentally vulnerable people
and then it's like well what's going on there? Why are you attracting
all these mentally vulnerable people? I suppose sorry. Go ahead.
Well, I was just going to say like you have to have a way of
dealing with that if you just if you attract people like that,
right? Which I would say, you know, doing content online is like
streamer content. It's already like a very small small niche
of people who probably have like a little bit like a slight lack
of socialization, right? Like you have to understand that when
you attract a certain level of person who will become like quite
um can become like quite parasocial with you, I think you should
have tactics for handling that and refusing to admit that it
happens in the first place is probably going to lead to you not
being able to handle it at all. Right? Like you're going to make
a lot of mistakes.
So yeah, just building on what you said, if you're attracting
those people, you probably have to acknowledge it and try to
come up with a tactic for dealing with it. I personally think
like he would make most women around him seem crazy.
Quotations being normal might even make that more of an obvious
thing. Normal, sorry, not normal. I don't know the right word.
Not mentally ill. Not saying all mentally ill people look crazy,
but you know what I mean. the vulnerability as Anna said, but
I think that he could do that to someone who is already healthy
beforehand. I think unless you have the mental of a fortress,
it would probably do that to you. And even then, I don't think
those type of people would go anywhere near him. So, it's just
like, yeah, sure. All right. If you date enough girls that are
crazy, at some point, do you feel like you are the only consistent
factor there? Neurotypical. That's a good word. Um, yeah, for
sure. But I mean, there's a lot of things about my life that's
like super atypical um that would draw those types of people
and would induce that type of behavior as well. Um, the issue
with a video like Ryan uh beard is Ryan Beard, right? Have you
watch Willie? Willy's kind of cooking here. I'll be honest, that's
the best question for this right here is um
Willie Willie gets him to admit like so Willie is saying the
whole time like I think if you took you know if you took accountability
for any of your wrongdoing like this would seem a lot easier
to stomach maybe we could start like thinking about you or feeling
okay with you. But what he actually does here what Destiny does
is he refuses to even take accountability for like hey like you've
you've said a lot of the women you're around are crazy. Doesn't
that feel weird that you're like the common factor there? You
seem to be running into all these crazy people. And Destiny goes,
"No, my life's really atypical, so obviously I'd run into crazy
people all the time." Uh, so Bucks, I think he's just um Well,
we'll go through it. Yeah, sure. Watched it before we comment
on it. I thought about Yeah, I watched it cuz I thought about
like Do I want to do like a long-term response and go through
like every single claim? The problem is that like one, you're
working with a full like 15 years of me having one of the most
public lives on the internet. So basically any anything I've
been involved in is is going to be out there for better or for
worse. Uh sometimes in the worst light possible. That being said,
like I mean there are things that I've done that are just like
legitimately bad. Like I shouldn't have done that. Like the Mia
Rose stuff that was bad. Like I admit that the Mia and Rose drama
was in 2011. Destiny got drunk on stream and assaulted Mia. If
I was a real friend, I would make you Okay, stop. Go get Oh my
god. Listen, guys. This is the first time he was ever drunk.
He had no idea how to process alcohol. He had no idea. He b they
basically him. Okay. They basically him. I'm going to apologize.
Like there was a time when I got like it was probably one of
the people say I'm like making justifications but I'm not like
it was bad but I got like super wasted for like the first time
in my life on a stream. I think when I was like 22. Um and I
was like grabbing me roses when we were streaming or whatever.
Uh we were doing a vacation thing in like Utah. Um and it was
bad but I mean like I've talked to her since like I've apologized.
I mean there's nothing else I can do. Um, it's always like strange
to me when people like Ryan will make videos and say like he
needs to take accountability and it's like this happened 13 years
ago like I've apolog I don't know what else you want me to say.
It's not like I don't think it's good behavior with bad. Like
I don't know what I'm supposed to do about that. And me as recently
as 2022 has corroborated this saying at the end of the day he
assaulted me. He apologized and we left it alone. And the point
of Ryan doing this was to show that Destiny has always treated
women poorly. His best example that he brought up was Ann of
War. Anna was somebody who uh you want to take a second here
Anna? the actual Zo thing. Yeah, it starts in about
Okay, I think 40 seconds, but I
The only thing is this is like uh they're not and then they get
into a fight. They show a video of it, but they're not covering.
Oh, wait. This isn't the You want to walk away now? Yeah. Yeah,
you should. It's a different panel, but yeah, sure. I got it
muted.
Okay. Do you Do you want me to message you when we're done? No,
it's okay. I'll just I'll just like She's just going to mute
the video. Yeah. Okay. Yeah. Yeah. Cool. Coco cool fight she'd
cry on
stream you lied you lied and like you and you misrepresented
so many things Stephen and you know you did this I mean you've
apologized to me in private but you won't do it publicly hold
stop trying to act like it's way so much
it is it is Steven don't hold this Destiny would label her as
a stalker like he can't get away from her I I don't know what
I'm supposed to do if anybody else here has advice Hold I told
you Stephen obviously. Are Are you saying you've you're being
held hostage? I told you what to do, bro. John, I'm being held
by an undefeable opponent, right? You understand? She has no
nothing to lose. She can carry this out for the rest of her life
and there's nothing. Oh, look. It sounds It's like it's the same
rhetoric. Oh, Pixie has nothing to lose. These people have nothing.
They have everything to gain by going after me. Nothing to lose.
But then in the meantime, he'd be did stalk me. Did she lock?
Okay, then. Why are you with her still? We're cool. We've been
cool for a year, Max.
Okay, so you acknowledge that you've been with her for a year.
I've Yeah, we've had on and off. Sure. Max, can you can you acknowledge
that I have uh the time stamp I got was way later. Un said anything
bad about her for a year. I said we've been fine. I've said that
over the last time I talked to you about her like a Oh, I think
uh based on the time stamps I got from Kelly, uh there's probably
more clips from it, just so you know. Okay. It's it's the max
part. Yeah, it's the max part right now. 2 weeks ago or 16 days
ago or something. You said that she locked you in the basement
of her mind and it was a traumatic experience for you in the
past. Locked me in the past. In the past, Max. Dude, how did
people take that argument seriously? That's insane. He's like,
uh, sorry, Anna. I I think you can talk through this Max part,
right? I'll just I'll say Oh, yeah. Yeah. This is fine. This
is fine. Destiny Destiny says Destiny said on stream she had
me locked in the in the basement of her mind. And he's like,
"Yeah, Max, in the past. Locked, Max. Locked in the past. I wasn't
talking about now." It's like, "Bro, you're literally going on
stream and talking about how you were like, you're literally
talking about her. You know, this irritates her. Like, of course
you're What? What are we doing here?" He's like, "No, I would
never say something bad about her on stream." I This is This
was an insane argument to get away with.
Yeah. And the thing is also like, how do you like that doesn't
really make sense? Like first of all I God it's just I mean you
we all know I well I'd hope but I mean we all kind of know that
like I so here's what I think. I don't think he was like maliciously
I don't think he was maliciously like oh she stalked me. I think
that I think part maybe partly it was malicious like in a I'm
really pissed at her kind of way and I feel like she's done really
awful things to me so I'm going to get back at her and say that
she stalked me kind of thing. I think that's possible. But I
also think that he genuinely perceived my messaging after he
blocked me which is not okay. Okay, that was really big up on
my part. really bad thing to do on my part. And I'm not justifying
that at all. Um, but I think he perceived it as like I think
he honestly perceived it as me being like obsessed with him.
Like I think he genuinely thought, "Oh, this girl's like really
obsessed with me and can't let go of me." And really here I am
being like, "I'm really scared of this guy leaking stuff because
I've heard from other women like other women have been in my
DMs warning me of course of his past with like blue tea and stuff."
And here I am being like, "Oh god, this guy is gonna like Oh
god, this is really bad. He's gonna like ruin my life." And so,
yeah, that was I just I feel like I feel like if he had more
I'm sorry, I'm going on a bit of a rant. I'm sorry, but I'm almost
done. I feel like if there was more less of an empathy deficit
there, I think he would have been able to kind of have empathy
and like empathize like, okay, wait, this is a really small streamer
who's like not really online much. Maybe she genuinely is freaked
out by all of this and the harassment she's getting and stuff.
And maybe that's why she's messaging me about that. I don't know.
It's just Yeah. I also think if it's not if it's not malicious,
then he should probably understand how you feel the need to like
respond to it even if it's not malicious. and then probably try
to deescalate there a little bit, right? Yeah. And it's just
when you block someone when you block someone and then you go
on to DGG and talk about how you're going to try and get them
fired from their job and like say all this awful stuff. Like
that's scary. Like that scared me. I was like, "Oh my god, I
got to make peace with this guy. He's going to ruin my life."
Yeah. Yeah. I I thought it was interesting how he argued um I
think it'll come up shortly after this. there's the uh the counterpoint
section that comes up and he argues that like well he wasn't
trying to do anything crazy to you and he was like trying to
deescalate by sending people to this other place and then when
you confront him on it he was like you're doing this to yourself
and you're going to keep doing this to yourself and then he's
like yeah I wasn't trying to get her to stop talking about me
and that's like literally his under his reason for like hey that's
why I did this. He like says you keep talking about me and then
the you keep you're going to keep doing this to yourself is saying
stop talking about me and this will stop happening. Yes. Exactly.
Yeah.
And for somehow counterpoints just took that and was like, you
know what, that sounds like he didn't manipulate her at all.
Sorry. I'm just I'm how insane that is. But oh jeez. Yeah, it's
fine. If you you might want to mute here cuz we're going to go.
There's another pass of the Zir panel coming up. Gotcha. Oh,
okay. Why? Tell me, Max, why hasn't Anna come forward with any
of this information now? Can you tell? Oh, this was also Sorry,
I don't know if you muted yet, but then Destiny asks, "Why hasn't
Anna come forward with any of this information now?" and he knows
that he's been DMing you here and that he has you saying like,
"Well, I don't want like I I want to be friends. I don't want
this to turn into a big thing, right?" Like he knows that. He
knows he's
It's crazy. Sorry. There is um there is another circle clip that
comes up in a few songs. Yeah, there is. And just to answer someone
in chat, uh no, me and Destiny are not friends anymore. So, okay.
All right. Okay. I'm going to You want to tell me or do you want
me to tell everybody why? Yeah. Thanks. Uh, I don't want to speak
on her behalf. Okay, I will. It's because she said she literally
wants to remain friends with me. And after seeing this, it makes
me feel terrible for Anna, who was crying about this very thing
for years. I've told you multiple times, if you don't want to
be friends with me, then stop. But like, you don't do that. I've
told you multiple times. Stop this narrative, Stephen, of like,
oh, stalker and stuff. You're the oneing calling me princess.
Thank you for the raid, Terry. Very kind of you. That huh? Very
kind of you.
Shut up. That was all cherry.
This panel is insane. Everyone's here to just suck up clout from
this poor girl's mental breakdown. Now Destiny claims the reality
of this situation was different. It's one of those things where
like when you dive into the details. Okay, we're uh we're through
that stuff now. I'm pretty sure.
3129. Yeah, this is the we don't have any more circanel left,
I don't think.
So, we should be good. Yeah, thank you. becomes a lot kind of
more murky and dumb. So like I think that the Ann of story is
is interesting to look at. Um like people will make claims like
oh like he was um he was her and then he was calling her crazy
at the same time. people will compress time spans of like months
into single days where it'll be like yeah I might have like we
might have had like a conversation like in November and then
in like December she is like tweeting or streaming about me again
on something that I can like on like Jesus this person is like
unhinged I don't know what to do and we like we went back and
forth like that um probably for I don't know man maybe a year
or something well I don't know here here this is my this is my
take on this okay so if you want after maybe I guess but like
this is my thing was like 30 something years old, 30 years old
maybe, and I think I was 32 or 33. Like, we're both adults. Like,
when people start applying terms like gaslight and crazy making
and abuse, does he not know gaslighting is like literally is
not the the exact like teaching example for gaslighting like
a husband and wife who are both adults? Yes. So, you're pretending
that you can't gaslight another adult. Guys, listen. We're all
adults. You can't gaslight another adult.
Bizarre.
That's a fantastic I you love to see that argument, guys. You
totally can't gaslight another. Could you imagine trying to gaslight
another adult? That's crazy. Oh god. Like I think she had really
unhinged behavior. She admits that she has OCD. She got medicated
for it. It was better. Maybe there's like better ways that I
could have handled the situation for sure. Like I think especially
in retrospect, even perspective, maybe there are better things
I could have done. But it's like it's two adults. The worst thing
that ever happened here was I don't even know what the worst
thing is. But I guess like we were she became like obsessively
streaming about me and then I said she was crazy online. Like
that's it. There's I don't know how people have found a way to
make this like one of the most abusive situations of the universe.
It's like part of me. You're calling her stalker. That's all
you did, Destiny.
He doesn't know what he did. The whole So just to be clear, cuz
I don't know if it comes up, maybe it'll come up later in the
video, but was it Destiny or was it Molina who was trying to
get you fired, Kimmy? So, I believe it was Destiny that said
it and then Molina like agreed with it and kind of laughed at
the time. Um, wait, let me think for a minute cuz just bear with
me because this stuff was like four, five years ago at this point.
So, he was also Yeah. No, it was it was Destiny. It was Destiny,
but Molina was just kind of, you know, going along with it stuff.
Yeah. In DGG. Okay. Yeah. Encouraging um people to go to her
KF thread with the docs on it. That wasn't yet. So in the timeline
um that wasn't what happened quite that wasn't yet. That was
later on in the timeline. Talking Destiny is talking to Willie
Mack now and he's saying what he had done to you and I'm like
no that's not true. He did a lot worse than just
Right. It must come up right cuz Anna points it out. There's
Anna Var's lies here. So, there's a whole section coming up.
We should probably go to it. Okay. Sorry. I just think it's probably
going to come up in the video. At the same time, you're her.
I don't know if I want to say, but you see the emotional confusion.
I understand. I understand what I'm going to say, but like this
is and I'm so sorry. Like, I've been so gentle with all these
online communities, but all of us are adults. We're 30 plus years
old, okay? Turn off the computer. Like, this is I think this
is so unbelievably overblown. Like, if you don't want to talk
to me or you don't do anything to me, then just stop broadcasting
about me and stop talking about me constantly. Like, that's it.
So, I inter H. That's fine. But why why would this Why can't
we hold up a mirror here? Are we Is he insane? Hold up the mirror.
Hey, you're calling this person a stalker? Hey, you're like you're
going unhinged talking about getting her fired from her job.
If that's how bad she is, why don't you block her? Why don't
you just walk away? Why don't you just stop talking to her completely?
Why don't you just totally totally walk away? Why don't you not
comment at all? What's like your average viewer number at the
time? Were you getting like a 100 viewers or something on Twitch?
I'm not sure. Oh my god, Kelly. No, I was getting like 20 to
30.
Any cared about that?
80% of which were probably DG embeds. Yeah, most of them were
from DGG, I think. But yeah, I was seriously like only getting
20 to 30 views. I mean, it would go up when like Destiny would
basically, you know, say like signal in DGG like, "Hey, Anna's
streaming and stuff." But yeah, no, Michael was a really, really
small streamer.
That is insane. Oh my god. He's telling people to log off when
he could have ignored all of that and nothing would have happened.
And he hasn't changed at all because he was skitso posting about
my 100 person Discord a few days ago. Like he must have gone
through like lotka skitso posts about absolutely nothing to find
the very few. Like I it's insane to me. Why does he care? Yeah.
The thing is that it does strike me as kind of minimizing uh
when he says that stuff that you just played because like well
you know you're calling me a stalker to your audience of like
I don't know like 10,000 9,000 8,000 people or whatever. You're
calling me, you're like making me out to be this like really
awful like psycho stalker who's like like threatening his I don't
know like threatening him and like you know it. So it's like
what do you expect people how do you expect people are going
to come at me then? Like that's that's kind of part of I feel
like that's another aspect of like the empathy deficit is like
maybe if there was more empathy there if he like utilized more
empathy there towards me he would have thought like okay wait
what I'm saying about her is going to have a lot of consequences
and it did because that's why I got harassed like crazy that's
why um someone made a Kiwi Farms thread about me because they
literally called me Destiny stalker and like that's why I got
docked. So it's like this stuff wasn't just he kind of portrays
it like it's just you know turn off the computer. Well this stuff
was kind of affecting my in real life you know I was really worried
about I was I mean people reached out to like family members
of mine and stuff and it and linked them like my Kiwi Farms thread
and stuff. It was really wild. So can I ask cuz I assume you
don't live there now. Were you living on your own at the location
that you got doxed at?
Yeah, that's scary. I know. I know. I There was like a time period
where I genuinely was like I would like literally check outside
and like keep all my curtains closed because I was genuinely
scared that like some crazy stalker from the internet would like
just come and find me or something like I don't know that you
know that could happen when you're when you're getting a lot
of hate and stuff. Not that I'm trying to make myself seem like
I was some kind of important figure or anything. know, but it's
just when I was getting so much hate and harassment and stuff
and so many eyes on me, I was just really worried about that.
Yeah. I just doing that to a single woman or someone who has
kids living in their house is just another level of evil. I feel
like I
just I don't know. It's just like uh yeah, I and I I'm having
a woman moment probably, but I just feel like you shouldn't do
it to anyone obviously, but it's okay to take into consideration
that that is just far more scary for us. And and look what someone
said in chat. I mean, yeah, of course. I understand. I was calling
him an abuser when I was streaming. I absolutely understand that
and that that was wrong and I shouldn't have done that. I just
think that he also shouldn't have done what he did also is all
I'm saying. Yeah, I I don't claim to be perfect at all in this
whole It was a disproportionate
very disproportionate response and not taking into consideration
his massive platform he's doing. Oh, sorry. Doing it from right.
It's ridiculous. Mhm. Also, Tommy, thank you for the five gifted.
Okay. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Sorry, I had to get that
in there really quickly. Tommy just gifted five. Thank you. Thank
you, Tommy. Thank you. Should be the stream going longer. We
appreciate you, Tommy. Sorry, I I cut you off. Kimmy, go ahead.
Oh, no. You're fine. You're fine. No, I mean, yeah, I was pretty
much done with what I was saying. Yeah, it was just like I don't
claim to be some like perfect like victim or something in this
situation. It's just I think that it was uh he went a little
overboard. Um Yeah. towards me. Yeah. Okay. Yeah. Yeah. I mean,
he's he's insane. He's clearly disproportionate. Everything he
ever said about Kelly Jean applies to him like 100fold. It's
very funny. Yeah. just a little viewed Anna and she claims that
he was her and sending her mixed messages recently after she
crashes out on stream. Yeah, our fighting has honestly been like
so on and off like it's been so Why do you guys keep in between
fighting each other? What is with that whole thing? You know,
it's really weird. I know. It was very toxic. Was there anything
abusive going on there? So, I used to say that I considered his
behavior um against me to be abusive. Now I'm I'm not really
so sure I would call it abusive. I felt like it was. I definitely
felt like it was it at the time it felt very abusive to me. I
would say that he definitely mistreated me, but I don't know
if I would go as far as to call it abuse anymore. Was there times
where you guys were and it was cool as he's talking just mad.
I'm pretty sure there were. I mean, definitely I am pretty freaking
sure that he still called me crazy and stuff when we were. I'm
pretty sure he would still be on stream cuz like we argued about
cuz wait a minute. This is this is literally a part of the Mr.
Girl um article. Hold on. We argued about it. It's all like coming
back to me now. I'm sorry. No, I mean you're you're going back
like what two or three years now? Yeah, for sure. Um, but yeah,
we would have cuz like we had fights about this like and him
being like, "Oh, well, you know, oh yeah, this one. Okay, wait,
I'll send you one." Like him saying like he can't publicly defend
me because he thinks it'll bring more drama or whatever. And
she sent me DMs of Destiny saying, "It's just me being defensive,
referring to." I just I love that this is probably the first
time Willie ever saw this. It's pretty bad. It's pretty bad.
It's pretty bad when he calls her a psycho. Yeah. So, I think
there's definitely I believe out there um I've provided like
pretty much evidence that yeah, it was a very short period of
time that I mean again to be fair there like I would also call
him abusive. So, just putting that out there for everyone to
keep in mind. But yeah, it was kind of a short period of time
where we'd sort of go from like having a fight and him going
on stream like calling me a stalker and then Seems pretty abusive.
Huh. Seems accurate to me. Oh my god, I have a character. Oh
yeah, I just added that. Thank you. Yeah, you you sent like some
of these like just like when you're being mean cuz you get too
way too mean and call me a stalker. And yes, it's like these
are all like a part of like um the same rough period, right?
Oh, I just Yeah. Yeah. Can I do this? I can do this. Okay. And
yeah, he kept kind of promising that he would like fix my public
like reputation and stuff. Um like cuz like there was a period
of time where like um and I remember this cuz we were talking
on Twitter, my old Twitter account, the Annavoir one. But um
and unfortunately all those log most of those logs are gone now.
But yeah, there was that period of time where I would be kind
of like bugging him like, "Hey, maybe we can like fix my, you
know, maybe you could like fix this and tell people that we're
cool now and you know, we're friends and we've been talking and
stuff." and he'd be like, "Well, I can't really do that yet."
So, yeah.
Yeah. When has he ever helped anyone with their reputation that
he has personally ruined? Has that ever happened? I just Yeah.
This is insane. I'll fix it sometime publicly. Okay. Until then,
I can you can work on your essays on your bed while I rub your
legs and feet. It's like I Dude, I'll fix the things I've said
about you that I clearly don't believe. But for now, let's just
continue with this. It's crazy. Oh, and yeah, this I think this
comes up in the video, the whole um that he says he can't publicly
defend you, right? Because then people will know that we're talking.
And I think really what I hear here and what comes through later
on is he doesn't want Molina or Dan or the other people to know
that you guys are talking. I think that's probably mostly what
it is, right?
Yeah. Yeah. Like and and Mutin and stuff. Yeah. He didn't want
like his stream to know. Yeah. Yeah. Anyway, we can continue.
Yeah. Well, I can't publicly defend you because then it's obvious
we're talking again. If I get defensive, that's the assumption
people will make. So, I have to act like I don't know why you're
in chat. So, he was just totally fine with people thinking she
was crazy as he's romantically involved with her. That would
drive anyone insane because we're It's obvious we're talking
again. So, he didn't want people to know that you guys were no
talking. But this is all the way in 2021. Did this go on for
like 2 years? Kind of. This went on and off for 2 years. Yeah,
kind of. Holy [__] It was It's very much like a toxic
relationship kind of thing. It definitely was. It definitely
except you guys weren't Did you Did you guys live in the same
state or was it all over online? It was all online pretty much.
I mean, he came to visit me, but yeah, you guys are full on Zoomers,
dude. You guys were were Discord before it was even a thing.
I know. Basically, when she went to leak their chat to prove
that this was happening, Destiny would then threaten his DG chat
to leak her news. Tell Anna if she leaks my I might have some
pics to share. But I gen and so that the important thing there
is that's uh November of 2021, right? Yeah, it looks to be November
of 2021. And the DMs of like the stuff that would have been super
incriminating like, "Hey, I like hey don't worry about being
called a stalker. We're cool. Like just let's just keep that
was 5 months before, right?" Mhm. Yeah. So So that that timeline
looks really bad. And he's clearly talking about this. Don't
leak this stuff that proves that I've been like in DMs with you
and talking to you about this stuff for like months.
So, yikes. DG chat to leak her new. Tell Anna if she leaks my
I might have some pics to share. I didn't handle it well at all.
I definitely came off as unhinged in a lot of it. And certainly
like obviously some like plenty of my messages to Destiny
um were a bit unhinged or very unhinged I suppose. But yeah.
So, just, you know, again, just putting that out there for people
to keep in mind. Yeah. Sure. Sure. Sure. Sure. Genuinely was
kind of scared of him. And when he blocked me, I was really scared
that he was going to like leak my things. What was the reasoning
beyond that? It was because I was threatening to leak his because
I was saying because I was saying, "What is going on over there,
man? What are you guys all doing? What are you guys all doing
over there? How is there always some Yeah, I know. I know. So,
the reason So, weird reaction, but I I'm glad he didn't like
quite cut you off cuz you're about to get into something important.
Why I was saying like, you know, I'm going to have to like leak
our if you don't stop saying that I'm stalking you because we
literally have been like and like you're saying I'm a stalker
and people are like harassing the [__] out of me
and like doxing me and like, you know. So that's basically what
the context was and that I was saying like you know I mean I'm
not going to leak much but I feel like I might have to leak some
of her or something to show people that like I'm not stopping.
Defend yourself is what you're saying. Yes. Yeah. The stuff Destiny
was telling me of oh she just needs to be an adult and break
it off. That sounds great on paper and Anna to some degree acknowledges
that. But you're also leading around while defaming her to thousands
of people. all the situ I think the the growth discrepancy between
Anna and Destiny between these two periods is insane like one
of these people took accountability for their actions took accountability
for where they were grew and decided they were going to be like
a functional member of society and the other one was like no
I'm good being this terrible person I I sorry congratulations
Anna I give me like I I don't think you it's it's like crazy
the difference between the two where it's like one of these people
is in the same situation again and again and again and you were
just like Hey, that wasn't cool. I didn't like that. How do I
fix that? Okay, now I'm going to go on with my life. It's just
so much better. Yeah. Uh I I definitely agree with you there.
I think I'm definitely um a lot healthier, like psychologically
healthier than Steven is. So yeah, I don't think any same person
would question that, honestly. And he actually regressed. That's
actually kind of true. I But like I also I'm not like um making
fun of him for being mentally unwell or something. I'm just saying
that like he has issues and he's clearly not worked on them and
it's very unfortunate to see. I would say to Housem MD in chat,
I would say that that's not quite accurate. I would say like
yes, he he did like media blackouts where he would be like, I'm
not going to talk about Anna at all. But that I believe that
was after like he had already like basically like I had already
been like harassed and doxed and everything. I'm pretty sure.
Um or maybe it was a little bit before that. But I think the
point is that I felt very much like I had to keep on defending
myself because he had such a huge reach and like and I had like
I felt like I had no reach. So, I'm not sure if I would say that
it's accurate to say that he tried to back away because again
in private he was still like actively talking with me and engaging
with me and stuff. So, yeah, it's messy though. But yeah. Yeah,
he's backing away could have been simply to cease communication.
That's not what he did.
No, no, it was like and and when he did block me, of course,
that wasn't because he genuinely like wanted to cease communication
with me. It was because he was angry with me and we had had a
really big fight. And so that was kind of our pattern. Um, which
tends to be the pattern in like a toxic toxic
relationship. I'm only speaking about mine. I'm only speaking
about mine. I'm not saying like I'm definitely not going to sit
here and be like, "Oh, he wasn't abusive to Molina." Okay. I'm
not going to say that. I would never say that. I'm just saying
in I am just speaking from my own relationship with him. So,
just to be clear. Yeah. I mean, it's someone is using blocking
like that is dysfunctional. And to then keep engaging with you
afterwards, it's like it's strange. But it's also he's just being
deceptive and odd because it like benefits him really. It's just
he cares about himself and his image more so than anyone else.
If he cares about anyone else at all, question mark. Don't know.
Uh I probably disagree on the whole like blocking is dysfunctional
thing, but I don't want to get a Yeah, I wonder why.
If you have somebody who's going to send you like dozens of messages
in a row, I feel like blocking them is okay to like give you
some time and some space away.
I think if you need to block someone, then you should just stop
being friends with them. I think it's a very dysfunctional way
of being. It's uh what is this? Stonewalling. Yes. Where you're
just like cutting people out. This this there's like a very variety.
It depends on how you're doing it, but 99% of the time is dysfunctional.
So like stonewalling is supposed to be basically when you
um block someone like intentionally to like try and like punish
them and like to get across that you're like punishing them.
It's It's not when you're just like, "Okay, I don't want to talk
to this person anymore and I'm just going to block them because
they're overwhelming me or something like that." But that's that's
why that's why the meme got kind of created about like the
I think that gasalling or whatever and like Yeah, because it
stonewalling, but yeah. Right. Which are less likely to provoke
any number of emotional responses. You can mute the person. you
can also physically walk away because yes, it's uh not on the
phone or internet or whatever. So, it's like um I think that
blocking someone is is inherently sending a message in of itself
and encourages and perpetuates very toxic, but that's the the
only person who behaved like this was my ex and he was definitionally
terrible at all of these things. So I relate that behavior to
him and I'm unaware of anyone who is healthy who does that behavior.
So yes, I I avoid people who do this. Yeah, I
situation like that. I'm some manipulative evil abusive person.
Maybe you could say I should have treated her like an actual
child and said no, don't don't do this anymore and blah blah
blah. But it's like I mean like these these are all adults and
the worst thing that's happening is like people each other online.
Like this is I think um the only reason why people are trying
to do this like Ann of situation where it is is because they
have this idea in mind of like I'm like trying to lead her on
privately in these crazy ways and I'm like publicly lambasting
her at the same time and I'm playing this I think Lab and Mr.
Girl coined this concept of like I get off on this sadistic abuse
of women or whatever. But like that's not it. It's like Yeah.
But it's like if you like there's like tons of relationships,
friendships, like friends with benefits, whatever situationships
where like people kind of like yo-yo back and forth at the end
like they each other, they get back together, whatever. It's
like it happens. It's who cares. Like none of this is that big
of a deal. It's all like like this is stupid. Like I don't know.
It's just dumb. And then people will say like that thing of like
you're and calling her like an abuser at the same time. Like
not really. There's like weeks plus between these events because
for like a whole like sixmonth period, there was a time where
like me and Anna were like friendly and then she would go public
and then she'd go on our stream and she'd be like, "I think that
Steven is lying about me." And then we'd talk a little bit and
then we'd be friendly again and then after like a few weeks she'd
be like, "I think Steven lied about people." And it's just like
but it's her getting I think the issue most people have is the
idea that like I feel like the sex were proof of like that Destiny
was being disingenuous with how he was framing Anna and then
he was like well if you do that if you show that proof I might
have some images to spread or whatever. That in and of itself
is like insane to me. That's really like it's not just it's not
that we're yo-yoing back and forth. You're explicitly threatening
somebody from proving that you're kind of being disingenuous
to your audience and disingenuous about them. That's and that's
a threat to do something criminal as well. She he's threatening
to revenge someone. That is a crime. And realistically, he argued
for a long time after that that a long time after that that leaking
would be the same as leaking nudes and then he leaked his with
like Pixie and leaked DMs with other people in order to like
try to fight narratives online. So I don't that just clearly
wasn't something he thought, right? or he's like a again just
a totally
principalist which I mean it definitely it definitely did seem
to me at the time to be like vindictive. Obviously, I'm not in
his head. So, but I I guess there is the argument that maybe
he genuinely felt like, you know, over by me threatening to like
leak the and stuff because they are very private. Like, cuz obviously
that's super private stuff. But again, like I feel like there's
that pattern there of when he feels over by someone, he gets
vindictive. So, yeah. I think he hates his being leaked more
because he's so cringey in the
um I I think it's I think it's that it proves he's just li been
lying about Annabore and that she's been telling the truth. really
vindicates her more than it says anything about him and he didn't
want her vindicated because she was saying he was abusive and
getting triggered by things in chat like over and over cringe
again and people knew they could trigger her so they would keep
doing it and then like we did that pattern for like six to 12
months it was but if she's crying and at the same time you're
her I don't know if that ever happened at the same time what
do you mean by same time these are like weeks these incences
are happening like weeks apart I don't know the I'm getting caught
up a bit in this interview whether it's days or weeks doesn't
matter He's her telling her to deal with the slander and then
when she goes to W. Willy sweeping for Willie. Let's go. Post
proof. He's threatening her. Willie sweeps for Willie. It's awesome.
With her nudes. Some of the time periods between them and fighting
was only 2 days. Anna wouldn't call the relationship abusive.
In her interview, she says that it was toxic and that Destiny
was right in the sense that she couldn't just move on. I love
when people can self-reflect and take blame. Destiny doesn't
do that with Anna. It seems like Destiny, right? Oh my god, Willie
actually cooked a little bit. Let's go.
He has a lot of scorn lovers that he then labels as crazy. But
when talking to people outside of Anna, it just comes off as
a bit silly to me. I talked to Lav who straight up admits to
spreading around revenge of destiny on Discord. I think it's
funny that like the most disgusting guy online who like has tried
to make my life a living hell for 2 years has like a dis and
it's leaked everywhere, right? So I was even like, you know,
don't get caught leaking it. Like but obviously it's advantageous
if it gets leaked. Like obviously I want bad things to happen
to this guy. And then I made a screenshot of the of the screenshot
or sorry I made the screenshot that Niko Sam sent me like a a
grab of just the top of his foreskin so that you I don't believe
Niko Sam sent this and I don't believe there's any proof he sent
this. I'll just I'll continue to like unless somebody shows proof
of that. I I don't believe it was him. You couldn't tell if it
was like you couldn't tell what the picture was. What was it
then? Um my profile. Uh, I don't know how she got a picture of
this or whatever, but from what I understand, it's not picture
in a private Discord server. No, there's like debate about like
how private the Discord server is, right? It had maybe 20 active
users and none of them were like DGers. It wasn't like a DGER
off. Lots of them were DJers actually cuz I know DJs who sent
me screenshots from that thing once I was like, "Wait, I need
to see proof of this couple weeks ago." couple. Yeah, there were
DJs who had that proof cuz they were in that Discord server.
It was like, so the reason I say maybe be careful about saying
it definitely wasn't Nikico Sam is because there's only two other
people that could have been I said I've seen no proof it's Nikico
Sam. I said I've seen no proof it's and I would not say that
definitely shared it with nobody else and I'm not saying anyone
didn't share it with anybody else. So it could have come from
a third party entirely who any one of those other people could
have shared it with. I just have no idea. So, I need to see proof
that Nico Sam did. I've seen no proof of that. We good? We're
good. And I never said that it was like I mean, my friends knew
that it was Destiny because I told them that it was, but it wasn't
like widely known that I I was like leakingness, right? Eco Samama
told me that Baby Peach had sent it to several people and that
this tape was already leaked. So, I just didn't I it it was under
I was under no like I was under no I did not think that like
this was something that like he didn't want going around. No,
he probably loves that. You shared that. Just call it implied
consent. She wrote to me how Destiny would make her send her
feet pics to get airtime on his stream. How he made her out to
be crazy and called her mid Jew. I've heard from multiple sources
this live story. The only one on the record was Destiny though.
What he tells is pretty much the same story. And it's hard for
me to tell if this is a story of abuse or just two scorned ex-lovers.
Kelly Jean is somebody that I've talked to and she was very upset
because you in statements I asked about in my first video, you
kind of like brought her in with Lav as somebody who was part
of a Discord that shared your nudes.
And now Kelly claims she wasn't ever part of this Discord, but
I the Lav thing is just odd. Lav has very much admitted stop
saying love that she did engage with revenge of you. It is undeniable
because she has bragged about Actually, technically under Florida
law, anybody she hadn't if she did not attach the identity to
this, she says she told her friends. I don't know if that happened
in the same Discord, but if she didn't go and say this is Destiny's,
then technically under the Florida law that would not be that
would not be okay. I'm just saying technically that would not
be. You need to have the identity attached or have the person's
identity be visible. Now, you could make the argument that Destiny's
is so disgusting that it would be recognizable and uniquely so.
But I haven't heard that argument from him or anyone else yet.
So, Lab's here. She'd probably make it for us many times on camera.
Even when I messaged Lab on my own, she was very upfront about
it. Kelly says she wasn't. Kelly might have said she wasn't,
but she uh she knew about it for sure. She knew about all of
it and she remained friends with Love and continued to chat with
her throughout all of it. But, you know, just saying. So, I asked
Kelly about this. Okay. Uh yeah, that was just with regards to
Kelly. That was just like a malicious lie. I'm pretty sure Kelly
was not a part of that Discord at all. Wasn't in the Discord.
So I don't Yeah. You're saying you weren't a part of any of that?
No, not even slightly. And uh the first time Destiny has alleged
this was about two weeks ago, around the same time that he messaged
you by the looks of it. Followed up with them clarifying. Uh
uh what was the timeline on this interview, Kelly? Just curious.
I think it was like a month ago. It was before my account got
banned. So, oh, I need to let you guys know. Yeah. Okay. Gotcha.
Guys, make sure you have both streams up, okay? Twitch and kick
at the same time, okay? You got to get the Twitch numbers up.
You got to pop the Twitch numbers. Twitch.tv/gdk with an underscore.
It's embedded somewhere. No, it's not, but I'll put it in here.
Boom. There it is. All right. Open up those. I love you guys.
Thank you.
Saying I was there because Kelly slander is like a hobby to him.
Well, he does he does like maliciously lying about you. Sure.
If you're on mobile, you can't do it. It's fine. It's just uh
it's I think he wants to break me but and well not just me but
also just all of the British people actually. I think he just
really hates the British cuz his big boner for us exceeds everybody
else's. But I will not be broken or scared by you freak. What
he wants to do Yeah. is intimidating intimidate people out of
talking about this or discussing it or whatever. He wants to
intimidate everybody out of this. Right. That's his primary goal.
Right. you authority. Oh, hold on. Black Iris, thank you for
the 3 months. Let's go. That's a primer. I think that was a primer.
Thank you.
He wants us all to stop talking about it. And and he comes up
with justifications, but he just maliciously lies. And he's he's
been trying to the lies get more and more insane cuz he's already
like blown his load. He's like, "Oh, well, I tried to dox them.
I did the death threats. I've lied about everything or I've said
I put everything out embarrassing that I could find. So now I'm
just going to come up with like increasingly severe lies." Yes.
But it's just why would you be a YouTuber if you don't want people
talking about you? Because the criticism that we've been levying
at him has been relatively reasonable. Like is he really upset
about me saying he's fast and should go to the gym? I don't I
don't think so. So it's like um he just wants to control what
everyone is doing and shut down all dissenting opinion. He's
just a little authoritarian Hitler. I don't it's like off. Okay.
Uh what he said about you and he sort of changed his statement.
I'm glad I'm glad you clarified Hitler was an authoritarian.
He's he's both Hitler and an authoritarian. We needed both of
those to be more of a guilt by association thing claiming that
you hung out with Lav a lot who said absolutely who absolutely
mic. Listen, I think I got my 5K down to 2630 today guys. It
was a 2630 time today. Very impressive. Very few people have
been able to do that. Okay. I talked to my doctor. He said nobody's
ever done that before. I My doctor said so. Okay.
Lee did do this. Yes. That's not true. The only place that I
ever interacted with her is in justical discord. So, you're not
really friends with Lav. He's grouping you in unfairly. No, I'm
not. Um, what I did say publicly quite a few times and even recently
probably is I think Lav is great content. Right. So, I'll say
like, "I miss Lav or I want Lav to be around because she's funny
and she's not boring." But that has no indication on our closeness
or friendship, right? Even if I was, like, what difference does
that make? A lot of people are friends with Lab on Discord, including
like a bunch of other orbiters, and like who cares? Like, well,
I I think the point he's trying to make is is just some hypocrisy
note because there is a video that I see that is uploaded by
a channel called Riyal Kitten House where it's lav bragging about
sharing Destiny's what royal kitten house? No way.
Just quick question. How does that make me a hypocrite? I'm lost.
There's the hypocrisy there. Maybe the idea the thing is supposed
to be that you hate Destiny because of him do posting revenge
or posting people's but Lav did it to him and you don't hate
Lav. I see that terrible argument. I mean there's something to
be said there but I think like the scale in all of this is quite
different. Yeah. I don't think it necessarily makes you a hypocrite.
I don't know. I I think I I banned Lav when I realized this happened
and then I once Destiny had tried to dox me. I was like I'll
ban Lav. There is also like I don't this guy's a terrible human
being. I don't I don't think he's a person anymore. There is
one more small point. I was unaware that it was considered revenge
because as far as I'm aware, Baby Peach was telling everyone
she had permission to share this tape. So that would make it
like how to grow cleanly, not revenge. So he's and he told everyone
this like she showed messages of saying, "Oh yeah, she had permission.
Share it with people she was in a relationship with." That doesn't
mean any of those people had permission to share it with others
necessarily or that somebody who gained access to those images
who was outside of that circle of trust had the right to publish
them. Yes, I'm saying I didn't like have this information. Right.
So, as far as I was aware, Baby Peach had permission to share
and I was unaware what the issue was and I hadn't seen Labs Discord
or what she had actually done. So this is all like I wasn't aware
I was away for a few weeks around this time because I was in
America for a few weeks and also I don't know it was like around
this time I was not around much and then people kept that I didn't
know all the [__] details of some schizophrenia that
went on when I wasn't here.
Okay. All right.
Kelly never truly responded to me pointing out the hypocrisy
of it. She just says Lav was banned and unbanned and it became
content. Hold on. President Trump here. Let it be known that
Kelly is vindicated. Destiny is a fragile authoritarian like
me, but he couldn't stop me being elected. Sad. Very sad, Mr.
Trump. Very sad that she got banned from Justical's Discord.
And then there was like a rule in place. She came back, but it
was under like the preface of you're not allowed to talk about
this banned topic. Mhm. And then Yeah. I think this is also on
Riyle's YouTube. I don't know if you've seen it. Why will he
put this part in Teeth Chatter? paying for this. 17 months. Wow,
we're getting up there in age, guys. 17 months now. That's crazy.
She was in like a bunch of calls like towards like the early
part of last year where it did get brought up and then they had
this debate back and forth about whether his is ugly or not.
I have not I have not watched that. This is such weirdo territory.
Like, what's my take supposed to be? Lav's a hypocrite. Is Kelly
supposed to be more mad at Lav? Am I supposed to say Destiny?
How dare you call Lav mid juke? Did you call L
Oh, it's unfortunate. I think Willie thinks this is like the
critical parts of the story and it's really not. That's unfortunate.
But it's I It's not bad to include. Yeah, I did. Yeah, I did.
Is there a thing where Lav wouldn't sleep with you, so you decided
to start like a crusade against her where you talk about her
and are negative towards her? No. So, is that a yes? So I said
no. Okay. But then he tells their story of them hooking up and
their falling out, which I end up hearing from like three other
people. I just don't think any of this is that important. And
we just like chat on Instagram and then eventually on Twitter.
I don't think it was ever really.
I think at some point we make plans to like hang out in real
life with the implication being where we get to a point to where
she wants to play California. I'm like, "Okay, fine." And then
I'm kind of tired of I don't know. She's like, "Oh, let's go
to gas station. We get a rumble. It's cool. It's whatever." It's
like, okay, whatever. Go to gas station. I go, whatever. Eventually,
we get to hotel room. I'm like, you know, like obviously none
of that affects this. Like, I don't care about any of that or
whatever, just in case. Like, I wanted to clear the air there.
And then she messages me back jokingly and she's like, "Oh, I
thought I had to you to come on." And I was like, "Okay, whatever."
So, like, we had that conversation, but she says later on with
Mr. Girl, she's like, "The only reason Steven sent me that message
was so that it seemed like it was okay while he was secretly
manipulating me." I've just been there for like I'm going to
say it three years and that's tremendously rare Willie MW W.
Okay, that's actually funny. Was that the edit? Yes, that was
the edit though. It's like dude, I can't listen. I sort of understand
this. I think um this is this falls totally outside the pattern
of behavior. Almost totally outside the pattern of behavior.
But um it's like the a bridged version of our time together.
When I told Destiny, if you have one crazy X, that means you
have a crazy ex. But if all your exes are crazy, that means you're
the problem. He responded with, "Yeah, I know it seems like all
of my exes, but I bang so many women in reality it's actually
a tiny percentage." What it feels like you are implying at times
is like, "Look, I've hooked up with a ton of girls and most of
them there is no problem at all." Is that Yeah. Yeah.
Yes.
Okay. Is there like a Dude, this is
so that I'm even asking this. Is there Wait, Destiny, how much
have you got? Destin Whoa. Destiny, have you gotten that much?
Oh my god. What is the percentage of girls? I guess is this what
I'm asking right now that areing buttth hurt as opposed to go
on fine. They're like, "Yeah, I hooked up with Destiny. No big
deal." I'm laughing because it's a ridiculous question, but it's
genuinely his defense cuz obviously those girls are never going
to complain. We aren't ever going to know Destiny hooked up with
them. Yeah. I mean, I would say like 1 to 2%. I don't know. Like
that's But every single person that has problems with me that
many girls though is what you're saying. You're all the time.
Listen, not Listen. Okay. Bro, how wet is your bro? How wet is
your It's little I don't know why he's polishing it like that,
but that's Listen, it's not like he um likes Destiny. It's not
like he's publishing a video that's meant to look make Destiny
look good. It's just like I can tell there's like a personal
thing where he's like he kind of likes the person a little bit.
I I feel like maybe totally crazy, but but the video for the
most part is appropriately like chastising of Destiny. So, I'm
not going to say he like loves Destiny. He's like sweeping for
him here. I don't think that's the case. I just like it's so
weird to be like, "Oh, it's awesome. I'm doing a like could you
imagine just in the example? I realize it's not like Harvey Weinstein,
but just like for an example, could you imagine gushing like
wait, you're saying you're saying you hundreds of actresses,
but only like five called you? Bro, that's that's crazy. The
past year and a half, I've slowed down considerably. Okay. Because
of the
Yeah, kind of. People like presented this as like some weird
thing that like it wasn't that. It's just that I took it I'm
like way more focused on work. I guess that makes sense. The
numbers are truly that high. Forget about what's like he's focused
on us. I don't know about his work. Are we his work now? Like
tormenting us. Interesting. I mean, he doesn't spend a ton of
time on that. He spends way more time like watching videos and
stuff, but uh it's definitely a split focus of his for sure.
Bold other content creators on that. I just want to focus on
the allegations. The allegations from Cherry about Wait, wait,
wait, wait. I'm talking about the time what he does in his private
life. He streams about the same amount of time now than he did
before, right? Yeah, Kingra. I would agree with you. Where's
the extra focus coming from?
I don't know. Uh, King Gidra, I I'm I'm giving him like little
cutouts for like, oh, I think um that's probably true. That's
probably like, oh, maybe this is what he's trying to do here
about Destiny secretly recording. I had some doubts behind them
because no stop. Um, the clip's going to start at 30. Yeah, 47
warning. Yeah. Okay. What?
3050 is Anna Zurka. That's a way different 47. But I seen the
recording. He claims he had consent to record. She said she didn't.
We need the courts to figure that part out. So I asked Cherry
if I could get a copy of the police report she filed because
that would at least The courts will never be able to figure that
out. By the way, that that's just going to come down to like
we either had a decision or not, right? Like Oh, what's up, Liberal
Chad? I uh I miss you. I wish I was still on YouTube cuz you
used to gift a whole bunch of money, but unfortunately we're
not there anymore. So, thank you for being on Twitch. Welcome.
Welcome. I think the courts can't really decide this. This like
the the consent or not thing is going to like it's like a word
versus word thing, right? I think you should probably have some
example of the consent if you're like using that argument, but
I don't know if that's a part of the court proceedings. Like
I don't know if there's any precedent for like well you don't
have explicit consent. So yeah, it's hard to say. We'll see.
I just don't I don't know that the court decides like a he said
she said necessary prove that something exists. She said no because
she didn't want to risk getting docks. But now we don't need
that because the record can we go to here? Sure. So Willie talks
about but this recording came out afterwards. And when I asked
him about it, he gave me a response but never I will say I don't
know why Willie put this recording in here. Um if it is what
he says it is, right? If he like the whole Destiny gay [__]
recording is out there as well and he didn't put that in here.
So, I'm a little I'm a little curious of why he would put this
in here at all. Assuming Yeah, if assuming he explains it exactly
after this clip, I won't. But yeah, I think I also would assume
he got Cher's consent to include this, but I would assume that
if I didn't literally know that that's not the case, but great
answer on whether or not it's not fine. I say it's fine sometimes
when actually something like fairly absurd happens. But he had
consent to record it, saying, "No, WTF, we were in my apartment
the entire time." She was literally staying over. I asked, "Is
there a reason why you would be recording in your pocket with
Cherry?" He responds, "I never was, lol. The phone was sitting
on the bed or on the nightstand." That doesn't answer anything.
Do you have consent or not? We're just going to have to wait
and see if the police report turns into anything because he won't
say, which, you know, fair enough. Oh, wait. That's a fantastic
point, Riyle. Wait, did Willie just say where he sourced um certain
certain things about Destiny andor? Yeah, he he basically just
referenced something that I've gotten death threats and docs
doc attempts for. Will Destiny be going after Willie Mack now
is the question for posting a thread for referencing this thread
for is Willie Mack a kiwi farmer now? Does he have to does he
must Willy Mack go down. I'm not sure if it Sorry. Well, I just
I think I've done less than Willie Mac has. I've seen Willie
reference a few things in here. Can you rewind? Well, we skipped
the audio, Ally, so we're not going to rewind and watch the audio
again. And I speak. Oh, sorry. I'm not sure if you skipped over
it, but he says that he included that audio because the audio
really doesn't sound like it was put on the table, right? Or
on the nightstand. From the audio, you can clearly hear movement
and it doesn't sound like it's sitting on a nightstand. That
was his reasoning for it. Okay, hold on. We're going to So, I'm
just letting you know. Trying to get through this without listening
to this at all. I'm like slowly going through this, but it goes
way the frames have not changed yet. Now, during our interview,
he kept the cherry stuff off the record, but this recording came
out afterwards, and when I asked him about it, he gave me a response,
but never a straight answer on whether or not he had consent
to record it, saying, "No, WTF. We were in my apartment the entire
time. She was literally staying over." I asked, "Is there a reason
why you would be recording in your pocket with Cherry?" He responds,
"I never was, lol. The phone was sitting on the bed or on the
nightstand. That doesn't answer anything. Do you have consent
or not? We're just gonna have to wait and see if the police report
turns into anything because he won't say why the is the audio
in the video. Uh because I I don't know. It's actually you certainly
shouldn't do it but to you.
No, I'm not saying that's the reason. Yes. I I said the explanation
was you wanted to share the audio because clearly the the recording
does not show that the phone was sitting on a nightstand. It
would Sure. But I would just say Okay, that's fine. But why wouldn't
you just say this is I listened to this audio and this is what
happened? Yeah, you can argue that. I'm just the the question
was why did he include it? That was the answer. That's Yeah,
sorry. The implication there for people who would care was why
would you do that? Um why would you republish parts of that audio
that are a part of somebody's like traumatic experience which
like I I listen probably if it wasn't somebody close to me who
I like have concern for I I might not care that much. It might
not bother me that much. So that's Listen, I won't say that that's
like a totally dispassionate criticism. Okay, you if you if you're
only here for dispassionate criticism, then listen, I feel like
that's weird, but that could be because I'm close to it. I don't
know. Which, you know, fair enough. I did find it interesting
though that when I asked Anna if she ever received nudes of other
girls, she said yes. Have you ever been sent um videos of him
and other people where they didn't consent to the videos? So,
I've been sent videos. I have no way of knowing if they were
consensually
like recorded or sent. Can you say who was in there? Oh, sure.
So, there's something in there, Kelly, somewhere where he does
say you told him about that audio or something, right? Did you
want to address that? I told him about it. Yes, I did not save
it anywhere or send it to him, but I did tell him that it had
ever happened because he was a bit flip-floppy about talking
about Cherry too much because there was no proof at that time,
right? And then I said, "Well, there's proof now." Yeah, sure.
Can you say who was in them? I didn't know the people. Oh, okay.
Yeah. I mean, that makes sense. I saw faces, but like I didn't
know who they were. Yeah. You have no idea who it is.
Yeah. And so like it's worth pinging Willie in public and uh
like to Destiny. Well, I I don't know, man. It's maybe I don't
know. I don't think listen I'll check it with some people, but
we should have a higher duty of care not to do that. But I don't
think it's worth making that argument. I just And we all just
like for once handshake and unite against the I don't you have
no idea who it is. No infighting. Okay. Directly at Destiny's
head. are not on this person's team. So, uh, if you're if you're
here to be on Willy's team, I'm sorry. This can be some chatting
about this. It's not about teams. We can be individuals all with
the same target. You don't have to be on the same team to do
We could be. Unfortunately, uh, this has a target on my back,
so we're going to have to talk about it. Yeah. When this stuff
came out, I was kind of like, "Oh, uhoh. Wait, wait, wait. Sorry.
Are you talking, Kimmy, cuz your mic's going on?" But also, I
know you're talking in the video. Oh, sorry.
No worries. Oh, you were typing. I see. I see. That means what
if they like didn't consent to that being sent? Yeah. So, that
was a little disturbing, of course, to realize.
Yeah. And I mean, I came out like kind of supporting Pixie and
and like and Cherry, of course. Um, were any of those girl? Well,
I guess you wouldn't know if it's Pixie or not, right? I don't
know if the I have no idea. I don't think so. I don't think so.
Yeah. I don't think I got anything about um like from any of
Pixie stuff basically or Cherry's stuff because like I like I
said, I didn't know who they were. And that just makes me wonder,
was this actual consent or more of that implied consent. When
Destiny was going through the Anna drama, he told people to go
talk about it on her Kiwi Farms. Her Kiwi Farms thread also hosted
her docs. And Ryan Beard made the point that sending people to
her Kiwi Farms is effectively just spreading her docks. and he
encouraged them to post in her thread. Oh, okay. Also, heads
up, this is my only non-media blackout time. Okay, this is my
only non- media black time over me. Okay, somebody on Kiwi Farms
has made a thread of Anna. So, if you are obsessed with Anna
and you want to talk about her all the time, you chat her. You
can actually go to Kiwi Farms and you can go and post all you
want, read all you want, go there, post about it, talk about
it. That's crazy, guys. I thought this was like I thought this
was like an unhinged I've never done anything like this. I don't
know that I've ever done this. But apparently this is worth uh
you know trying to dox and do death threats on people. Apparently
this is the kind of conduct put a lot of effort into. This is
about equivalent to you know somebody you know being in a discord
with somebody else you know that you're not a part of and then
that somebody else you know goes to like a different discord
entirely and then they talk about Kiwi Farms there. That's probably
about what this is equivalent to, I guess, in Destiny's World.
Is it categorizing and archiving everything? There you go. Okay.
And did he link the post? Yeah. No, he literally linked the post
in DG chat. He literally linked the post. Yes. And in the thread
about Anna that Destiny encouraged his fans to go message they
doxed Anna. In response to this, Anna texted Destiny, "You literally
ruined my life. You just doxed me on your stream. [__]
you. You put me in danger." And and Destiny responded to this
by saying, "You're doing it to yourself and you're going to keep
doing it to yourself." How could any I just That line always
kills me. How could anybody look at that line after he posted
her Kiwi Farms thread and she's justifiably upset
like me that line is crazy. That's it's crazy. That line is like
actually evil to me. And the implication is if you keep talking
about me, the harassment will continue. That is absolutely the
implication of that. And then he'll tell people, "Well, actually
no, I didn't really mean to harass. I was just trying to get
that conversation out of my space." Oh, and recently Destiny
has also called for the doctor. I remember he was really mad
at me at this time for something. We had some kind of fight,
of course, like usual, but yeah, we had some kind of fight. And
I think it was again over me calling him abusive. And then um
he I'm I swear I swear I'm pretty sure I'm remembering this correctly
that he absolutely was mad at me for calling him abusive again.
And so he went and did this. And I'm pretty sure we even had
a conversation about it if I'm remembering correctly cuz yeah,
it was further down from that conversation where I called him
a sociopath and I'm pretty sure he said something like, "Well,
um, you know, just like stop calling me abusive and this won't
happen or something like that or of course I did this because
you called me abusive again yet again or something like that."
And I don't feel like that's a really a good justification for
doing something
awful like that. Obviously, it's trying to silence you and control
you because the thing is I genuinely felt like he was being abusive
to me. And so, of course, this just like reinforced that feeling.
And that's not the proper response that you do when you're when
you when you're dealing with someone who feels like they're being
abused by you. You don't go and like you don't go and send people
to their docks basically. That's that's not what you do. That's
very
And yeah, and by um by saying you're bringing it on yourself
is like removing all responsibility for the harassment that he
knows he's targeting at you, right? It's like he knows that he's
participating in it and it's very much like happening because
of him, but he's blaming you for his actions. like he has no
agency. Just he's just like a volatile angry ape. I don't know.
Yeah. Basically.
Yeah.
Crazy. And of course, like I saw that incident as like, oh my
god, he's just, you know, piling on more abuse then. So, of course,
that didn't help anything. So yeah, it's the kind of thing that
men would say when they after they've hit beaten the out of their
wife. This is like woman beater rhetoric unironically. Oh, you
did it to yourself. It's like yum yummy yum yum yum. I do consider
that to be somewhat like victim blaming basically. Yeah, because
it's like well actually you made me do this bad action towards
you. Like it's I don't know. It's just, yeah, that's what it
kind of comes off as to me. It's victim blaming whilst also doing
the victimizing. It's like, h, yes, it's great. And again, I'm
not trying to say that I'm like some big victim here. I'm not
saying that. I'm just saying that that type of mentality seems
to be like a victim blaming mentality basically to be like, well,
you are doing it to yourself when it's like, no, you have the
you have accountability. You chose to do that. So, yeah. Yeah.
some and you're going to keep doing it to yourself. And recently,
Destiny has also called for the docks of some of his biggest
attractors. He asked, "Is this Queenman's full docks public yet?"
at another uh by the way, just um has also called for the docks
of some of his biggest attractors. He has just cuz it's here.
This is him trying to use what he thought was Queen's name. Now,
I again, you don't usually comment on this stuff. We didn't comment
much on the time much at the time, but he is literally trying
to menace Queen. hoping this message will get to Queenman like,
"Hey, I have your doxed. Hey, you're about to get doxed. Hey,
this is like an explicit threat, right? This is an explicit threat."
So, I don't know if Willie realizes that or realizes why the
name is in there. I don't know if he references it. Is Queen's
full doc's public yet. At another time, he was calling for J.
How many people are round this? Oh, and he asked for it in his
Discord as well. And he said in his Discord, I don't know if
the logs are in here, but he said, sorry, he asked for it in
his DG chat. He said in the DG chat that he would publish it
immediately if he had it. Person, can we harass or can we um
dox or swat or whatever and like that's just the goal for all
of it. Um it's pretty cringe. It's pretty gross. Uh I expect
the behavior from Kiwi Farms. It is what it is. Like I said,
communities like that will always exist. Uh he didn't think the
docs was fake. Alien mode. He's a but it's really gross when
people like
obviously I hope I can find soon. Um, sorry we cut that off because
uh I expect the behavior from Kiwi Farms. It is what it is. Like
I said, communities like that will always exist. But it's really
gross when people like Justicle um whose information I hope I
can find soon um are like trying to amplify or put a magnifying
glass on for over there and then have it spread to the other
world. That's just Oh, kind of like what Destiny did to Anna
explicitly. Not that I did that. I didn't do that. He's just
making that up. But he did do that. He has done that multiple
times. Yeah. Anyway, to me. So, I asked Destiny about it and
this is what he said. People accusing you of doxing, right? Because
you're referring to Kiwi Farms. Uh Ryan did this with Anna and
then um Jawk is doing this. Quean is sort of doing this where
there's DMs about you saying like, "Hey, I wish this person has
this person been docu." And he has explicitly attempted to publish
docs of people that ostensibly exist, although Que is dead that
he says are us. So, he has not he's just like executed on this
already, which I believe like considering Willy's publishing
it now. Uh, this happened actually before the counterpoints debate,
which I think he throws in here, right? I thought we had the
counterpoints debate in here at some point. I was told counterpoints
was referenced. We went by it, right? Oh, it must come up later.
Anyway, if that's in here, like obviously you should be able
to edit it and put that in, right? So, so he just doesn't know
or maybe maybe he doesn't know about the the actual docet. Yeah,
I you know what? He might just be showing the interview. Maybe
he'll bring it up later that the actual doces did happen. That's
for Jess and Queen. I'd kill him if I could. I choke the house
into it. Um, but not for Anna. No, we'll get back to the death
threat in a minute. I just want to address Anna's point of view.
It's you saying like you doxed me on your stream because your
doc was on Kiwi Farms allegedly. Is that true? Yes. Yeah. You
ruined my life, right? So, do you think what he did there was
him maliciously doxing you? I think it was malicious because
again, we were having a fight. It was over. I don't remember
what the hell it was over. Yeah. One one in a dozen between you
two. Yeah. So, the source of our Oh, well, first like Yeah, I
do think it was malicious because he was pretty angry with me
at that time. And yeah, he basically said like go to her. You
literally you literally just have to look at the logs to see
how pissed off he was. It was clearly malicious. Clearly attempting
to manipulate her into stopping talking about him. Sorry, Kimmy.
you're here, but I'm I'm just hiding forms page, specifically
page four or whatever, which was where my docs was. And yeah,
so I was very upset. So it didn't matter if he gave a page number
or not. It was four pages. Like when he linked it, it was like
three or four pages. It was it was not something that you would
take a long time to look through. It's like with Destiny's, it's
like thousands of pages, right? So with maybe just open
it was a DGER that literally made my Kiwi Farms thread in the
first place. So it's and yeah, it was only four pages. So it's
like yeah, you're going to find the docs. Like I I think I did
correct here that he didn't say the exact page number to like
go to. But yeah, ex exactly what you said. Yeah, it just wouldn't
matter if there's only four pages. It's like Yeah, all the information
is going to be right there. I think he did. Okay. Actually, I'm
not sure. Either way, I felt like, you know, oh my god, this
is basically doxing me. What the hell cuz he told people to like
go there and talk about me and stuff like that, make make accounts,
things like that. And yeah, I felt like he obviously when I asked
him about this framed it in a not a malicious way, but Oh, interesting.
whether he's naming whether he's naming the the page number or
not, which is obviously he's framing it as not malicious, but
if your doc is on there and everything,
well, yeah, I mean, you know, they it comes off that way. It
feels that way and and I would interpret it that way myself.
Yeah, especially since we were literally still at that time according
to alleged text messages only 2 days before. And it's not just
me who interprets it that way. Destiny interprets it that way.
Jtostalk and Queman sending people to his kiwi farms is why he
wants them dead.
I'd by the way we literally don't do the house and do it. I shared
that clip of the interview at the end of my I'm Alex video and
this is how Destiny justifi you [__] loser it when
he was asked about it this
he's a perma online
if you were like he's going to be scared of obsessively
posting and directing people towards docses of me my family members
and author I have no care in the world didn't happen and did
literally didn't happen and not only did it not happen uh almost
all of those doces were posted before Quean or I ever really
started covering this topic right? Like he he's literally post
hawk rationalized why he's doxing us based on like things that
happened before we ever covered the topic. All of the people
he's talking about who have been like threatened or doxed or
whatever that all happened before January 20th. There's like
one thing I think it's the Tom Foolery thing is the only person
who was like threatened afterwards as far as I know. And like
okay I get that like there's a there's a message about Tom Foolery
there and that sucks. Don't dox Tom Foolery. Tom Felery is fine.
Like what? Don't don't don't dox people. It's up. for you. I
will never have any. What isn't he only saying you're directing
people to the docks? One, he doesn't believe that's a problem.
He's done it multiple times as we've demonstrated. And two, I
didn't do that. I don't direct people to go there. I don't tell
people to go there. You can't he hasn't attributed that. He hasn't
attributed that to me. And if he has, he's I don't tell people
to go there.
Care in the world for you. And I will gladly as well, right?
Like this stuff matters. Like you you can't direct people from
your discord. We don't direct people to any docs or like it's
just insane. Screenshots I believe screenshots and links to Qi
forms are banned in my Discord. Yes, it's just stupid. And his
like now his cope is like actually there's like a Discord that's
a offshoot of JCO's Discord where people talk about this that
I'm probably almost certainly not a part of cuz I'm not a part
of any of those and I'm getting blamed and I'm getting like doc
doc threats death threats from this guy. Fully admit that. I
I don't know what you want me to say. That's the exact same reason
Anna was upset with you, but you called her a liar. I'll play
as justification anyway. She says like, "Hey, this ruined my
life." Or whatever, "Steven, you ruined my life." When you said
that, that's [__] But what what happened was again
the pattern with Anna was if anybody would bring up anything
about her that she felt was wrong, she had to go live and correct
the record. And the frustrating thing for me, and I'm sure you've
seen this happening right now, is what people will do is people
will pretend that they're not getting info off of Kiwi Farms,
but what they do is they get info right off Kiwi Farms and then
they chat about it in Discord or they talk about it on my chat.
So, I was getting frustrated and I told my chat, I was like,
"Listen, if you guys want to talk about it, go Kiwi Farms, whatever.
Get the out of my I don't think I ever had to get info from KF.
I just I don't I can't remember a time where I've needed to get
info from KF. I I had every piece of info that I've ever like
um like if I if I've shown like DMs on stream or something like
I know about all that before I before that's posted on KF. I
just can't think of it's not even that I like wouldn't source
things from there. I've said I'd like source the DMs cuz somebody
formats them nicely. It's not even that I think like sourcing
um you know things from there is like evil. It's just that I
haven't. Like it's just that it's the wrong criticism. I'm not
even saying like no no I wouldn't go to KF ever. That's not what
I'm saying, right? I'm I'm saying I just happen to not have I
don't need to for Destiny because I have a lot of information
that I have myself.
If you have firsthand info, you don't need to. I'm trying to
think like hard like what broke on KF before it we knew about
it. I I think there might be one or two things. I'll have a think,
but it's not most of it. Yeah. Put it there. Effort to doxer
is what you're saying. Yeah. No. What the like why would I even
want to do that? Like what? Oh, at most there could be information
that became public that I was aware of because it was posted
on like let's say KF or something um that I would have known
about before and then I could talk about because it had become
public, right? Yeah, that that would be like maybe the most you
could argue. Yeah, Solo was in my DMs signal for sure. What am
I once I like I do want somebody logistical though or laugh or
Mr. Girl or Queen those people can all die but not not Anna.
No, since you do want these people to die and they suck. Okay.
I All right. Well, Kimmy, you're off the hook. Okay. You're off
the hook.
I know, right? The low bar of not wanting you murdered. Yeah,
I know.
I want to mention that like at this part that like it's it's
it's possible that like, you know, Steven at the time maybe he
wasn't being like super malicious like, oh, I'm just going to
send people there to like, you know, for her docks or whatever.
Maybe he was that was his way of trying to get people to shut
up about me talking in his chat or something. I you know if I'm
being if I'm being more charitable if I try and have a more charitable
view of it. It's just at the time it really didn't feel that
way to me. So yeah I mean no but so I'm sorry he wasn't right.
He wouldn't have so we can literally go um so Mr. Girl report
and then there's the Anna section right here. So if we go to
your section of the Mr. girl report. I believe there's more DMs
that are kind of like just barely like you ruined my life. Uh
so doing it to yourself, you're going to keep doing it to yourself.
I believe there's something like um Oh, I have a media blackout
related to yourself and I wanted everyone to get it out because
people were talking about incessantly over the next two week
or talk about it incessantly over the next two weeks as more
and more people discovered it. You're constantly talking about
me. So he says he says the reason I did it was because you are
constantly this is a big part of his reasoning, right? You were
constantly talking about me on your stream, so I think it's fair
for me to bring it up. You went as far to say I was abusive the
last time you mentioned me, right? I remember.
He's saying I did this because you talked about me and I will
do it again. It will happen again if you talk to me. Oh yeah,
it's bringing back all the memories now. Oh my god. Yes, that's
that's right. Okay, that was the fight we were in. Yeah. Yeah.
No, that really did seem malicious.
The crime of talking about him. Brilliant.
To be fair, I mean I calling him abusive is mean, right? It's
like bad.
Yeah, because um he threatened to when he threatened to leak
my nudes. I was like that's that's abusive basically. And that's
a crime. I mean that seems and he got very that actually doesn't
seem bad. That seems like probably a reasonable thing to say.
At the time, nobody seemed to think so. At like I remember at
the time people were like, "Okay, you're being way like overdramatic
with this. He was clearly just joking about leaking your nudes."
I mean, I don't think that seemed like a joke to me, but you
know,
yeah, it didn't feel like a joke to me. So, you know, I was just
abusive.
Yes, it's a threat. There's no joke. There's nothing funny there.
you're saying you're going to do something nasty to someone that
is a crime that it shouldn't be ignored at all. And it's absolutely
fine to point this out. And it's insane when other people try
to cope and say, "Oh, this person that just threatened me with
something. Oh, they didn't mean it. It was just a joke." It's
just like minimizing.
Yeah. It did feel very minimizing for sure. Yeah.
Yeah. Bad. Yeah. Yeah. Sure. I do want somebody to logistical
though or Lav or Mr. Girl or Quman. Those people can all die.
But not not Anna. No, since you do want these people to die and
they [__] suck or whatever according to you. I mean
I think they'reing annoying too. When you're saying these things,
it is with malicious intent. You just genuinely don't care. Like
them. Yeah. Not for Anna. That's that wasn't the case. I just
Yeah. People That was the case for Anna. You're just you realize
you can't fight that that he can't stand on that hill anymore.
It was malicious. It was clearly malicious. were already going
to her thread and they were bringing stuff from her thread into
my chat. I was like, "Listen, if you want to talk about it, like
it's not like her thread was unknown and then I all of a sudden
publicized it." It was that people were um people were going
to that thread and I'm annoying, bro. I don't honestly.
What's annoying is he he made some points about me. He makes
some points a little bit later. We'll get to them. But like you
could probably make the points he made. He's just too lazy to
actually make them in an effective way. and then talk about in
my chat like listen go to don't talk about it in my chat because
if you say to my chat she's going to see it and then she's going
to want to correct the record on and I don't want to be part
of this [__] that's driving me crazy. Yeah, but with
JTalk and K.
The reason why I hate these people is because they're taking
part in this thing bro. I swear to God if I quit streaming I'm
going to go on an assassination mission. Okay, this start disappearing
one at a time. Okay, the thing that I is disgusting to me is
that because they don't get a rise out of me and they don't get
a reaction. This guy's never bench played. He's never bench pressed
a plate in his life, but he's going to go on an assassination
mission. He's going to take these people out. Literally never
bench pressed a plate in his entire life. Who's threatened? Who
is scared? Who is worried? Who is concerned?
Like, I'm I'm so much more concerned that he would actually like,
you know, lose his breath going down his stairs and then call
somebody to actually, you know, make good in his threats. That's
so much more concerning than anything else he says here. action
out of me. They start targeting every single person around me.
Blouse. If you go onto my Kiwi Farms thread and you look at there's
like 15 different sock puppet accounts that are all this guy.
He is saying it explicitly. He will say, "I am doxing this girl
because she's still with Destiny. I'm doxing this person because
he's my citizen. They did it with Does he want to Does he want
to point out that the actual doces all dropped before me or Quimman
got involved?" Does he want to maybe point that out? It feels
like it's important to point that out that he's blaming me for
this, right? He's going to say, "Oh, you've participated in this.
I literally I am not related to this person. I don't like what
are we doing? What are we doing? Why said that about Sherry?
Oh well. Tom, did you ever see I saw a screenshot where they
did with Tom? They're like, "Oh, why is Tom?"
No, no. Thomas
Tom Foolery. Oh my god. Tom Foolery. Yeah. I don't know. I don't
I don't I'm not Tomy tweeted one critical question one time about
like the narrative about me or the crazy narrative. This stranger
me guy. That's um stranger me as a blab. Like look at that response
because he tweeted one thing when he was I'm apparently responsible
for this despite the fact that this guy apparently that this
guy like was doxing people for the past like 2 or 3 years. I'm
apparently responsible for this guy's conduct now. I don't I
don't understand how you can do this. And then look at what his
response is. That guy, that stranger me guy that's left. He's
docked like 20 people in my life. Yes, he docked Zoe and Jacob.
They know it. I got DMs from Zoe where her and Jacob quit the
whole internet cuz they were so terrified of him. Uh, he's doxed
my girlfriend probably like in the past like 20. Wait. Yeah.
Yeah. He's doxed a whole bunch of people around you. When? When?
All before like any of us did anything. He'll like redox her
like every few weeks when he's bored. He has a competition for
biggest footsyard. Come on, dog. Yes, but he's saying that because
he won't come out and post a video like unequivocally calling
me like a Stranger me is literally blab. Wendy, I don't know
what you're talking about. That's crazy. Mask. This is what they
do. So whatever like you're working on right now is aed waste
of time because if you post this, you're going to have Hassan's
community. You're going to have these people. That's fine. But
you say that now, but it'll turn into them going after you and
then they'll try to dox you or your girlfriend or they'll listen.
I totally disavow doxing. I totally disavow like trying to do
the uh what is it? The collateral damage stuff. I totally disavow
that. After your family or they'll go after friends of yours
or they'll go after other people in the commentary community
until they make videos about you. Like this is what they this
is like the pattern. It is soing irritating. That's why people
like Jistle and Queman, if I could, I would put their balls in
a vice and crush them and then slice them off and then feed them
to them and then slice and kill them. Okay, them. Because they're
amplifying all this and they're knowingly playing a part of it.
They know what's going on. But like Kelly Jean, dude, I amplifying
what? What's being amplified?
Hold on. I just like is Willie ever going to ask? What are you
talking about? What did they amplify? If it's from this, it's
also I just want him to ask at any point, Kelly. I want him to
ask. Please, can you just give me an example of what they amplified?
Can you give me an example of the conduct you're upset about?
I need him to stop being so violently aggressive when he's pathetic
in like real life. You're not going to turn up and do any of
these things. You sit at home being a doughy fat boy all day.
Like, come on. I I literally want any proof of any of these things.
Just show me anything. Show me an indication in any direction
that you're not just schizotiple right now. You're not just having
a skid dipple breakdown and losing touch with reality. Please
show me you're in touch with reality at all. Post something.
Post anything.
Just don't understand why he talks like someone who's ever won
a fight against someone that wasn't a woman.
You're right. He has physically dominated his ex-wife before.
That's like the only person we've ever considered. I can send
you like 50. Like there are so many albums of them just constantly
talking about me, talking about my talking about my girlfriend,
talking about my kid. Like, okay, I did do that once today. Constantly.
It never ends. To be fair, this guy has like tried to dox me
and threatened to kill me and stuff. So, I I feel like I earned
a little bit. And he links his shell lock. Look, this fat from
Alabama's been talking about me. She posted a tweet. It's never
ending. Constantly talking about me. Constantly talking about
my girlfriend and stuff. So they're like getting off like Kiwi
farms. They're just discussing it like in their servers. Poor
Hannah. But by the way, what is what is this?
This is referring to Shell Bunner picture. I was going to post
this under that tweet. Young Thong defends James Harden for wearing
a pro police face mask. You don't have internet. This is totally
unhinged, guys. These are totally unhinged messages. It's a tweet
about Destiny with his cat. And then it says it says his lawyer's
Andrew Breler. That's true. Constantly.
Who the walks around Miami with a loose house cat? That's totally
dox and these people in a video game. Not actually literally
I'm basically just being hyperbolic based on what Destiny was
saying. But like he's he's literally arguing like apparently
we need to dox and kill people who do this. That's insane. That's
I'm by the way I'm totally criticizing this behavior. What what
are we doing? How how could you possibly say that we need to
This is his proof by the way. my girlfriend and half the stuff
that's they're like getting off like Kiwi farms and just discussing
it. This guy is completely schizophrenic. There's literally a
link to a tweet of him carrying a cat and somebody going, "Who
carries a loose house cat around Miami?" And he's like, "Yeah,
this is why I I tried to dock Squeam and Jtock and uh this is
why I'm calling for their death now." That's his that's this
is the evidence he sent Willie back like in their servers. Poor
Hannah gets no grace for going through the exact problem that
Destiny is complaining about. As far as the messages Destiny
sent me, yeah, people are talking about him a lot. I'm sure it's
annoying, but so what? Why am I getting Destiny's girlfriend
tweets on my personal Twitter? Neither follow never followed
either. This is That's crazy. Oh, hold on. Here's the worst one.
It's Kelly Jeene saying, "The only Desi can get are drag traffic
from the bottom of my free cams and an actual cat." That's That's
apparently, by the way, that's Kelly Jean. That's not even me.
Where am I participating? Can I get my participation, please?
Got the Destiny is fat screenshots, too. Can I get my participation
from somebody? Where's my participation?
how the internet works. I hate doxing on the internet. It is
the worst part of Kiwi Farm because doxing is when Please read
the deranged androider one. Wait, what did Androer say? There
was a couple with cat backpacks. When we were walking in Cali,
we were, bro, when I was in Cali, we were walking at the beach
and there was a couple with cat backpacks. Like, oh my god, this
is insane. I can't believe Andrew posted this, dude. I totally
understand Destiny calling for people's death now, actually.
Oh my god, this is crazy, guys. We got to get everybody. Oh my
god. That's nuts.
It's completely valid to be excited about cat backpacks. Whoever
Whoever owns this Discord needs needs to uh apparently face the
wrath of God. Okay. Messages Destiny sent me. Yeah, people are
talking about him a lot. [__] There is one more here.
Hold on. This is way safer. This 40-year-old short fat guy walking
around with a house cat that's as big as him doesn't seem smart.
I a lot. I'm sure it's annoying, but so what? This is how the
internet works. I hate doxing on the internet is the worst part
of Kiwi Farms because I literally I I don't th those Discord
logs were supposed to prove that um that basically that's his
justification for trying to dox me and calling for my death.
Anna was like those logs right there. Are you serious?
That's that's what he sent Willie. He's like look at how crazy
these people are and he sent those logs. Well, he pulled them
up. How can you read these things and not laugh occasionally?
Like it's funny. I I just like that seems to me actually. Yeah.
Why didn't he read those and look at like how insane that was?
Like he literally got sent those. Did he not feel like you could
laugh about how insane it was to That was the proof he got sent
and he showed it on on the video. Okay.
It's wild. It's unfortunate. It's unfortunate that I joined that
one call with uh with Willie. I feel like Willy's video could
have been so much better if he just wasn't like if he just didn't
have like an unhinged dislike for me based on me. Literally,
I just hopped on a voice call cuz I was like, "Oh, I don't think
he's like listening to Kelly or like he's kind of trying to crazy
make Kelly right now." So, I hopped on and I was like, "Yeah,
I" and I communicated poorly to him. I totally communicated poorly
to him, which I admit, by the way, but I just I don't know. I
was doing fine. I feel like if if that was about somebody else,
I feel like he could have evaluated those logs right there and
laughed about them appropriately. But online hate becomes offline
hate. It starts affecting people's real life, allowing unhinged
individuals to then swat them. People have died from this, but
he is being completely unsympathetic towards Anna, who had the
same complaints of uh Zezy. I literally let him on me solo on
Twitter and said, "I'm not going to fight with Billy. I'm not
going to fight with Willy. I'm not going to fight with Willy
Mack." This is about the eighth time that he's come after me
or talked about me and now I'm responding. So you Okay. I think
you [__] on him too much. No, I stopped on him. I
literally was like, I'm not going to talk about Willie at all.
And he had to have his little unhinged seedfest on Twitter where
he got super assad about everybody talking about him. Okay. He
got super ass mad about it. Now I will just talk. [__]
him. Okay.
And now he wants to be the uh Soap box society thing for the
five gifted. That gives us a another hour on the stream or sorry,
two hours on the stream. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Breaking.
It's Saturday. I'm in the middle of editing, but I've just been
made aware of Destiny addressing this exact argument I make.
And I think it's important to let you know Destiny's mad because
people are linking to his uh Kiwi Farms. Destiny's mad about
that, but he linked to Anna's Kiwi Farms, right? Well, if you
look at the two differences in context here, it's it's not even
remotely the same. There was a Kiwi Farms thread that was posted
and everybody kept basically doing whatical service doing. They
would link it in my chat like, "Oh my god, did you see this?
Did you see And I think I said something on stream to the effect
of, "Listen, if you want to talk about her, go to our camp thread
and talk about her. Don't do it here. I don't want to see this
here. This isn't going to be talked about here. Get out." Okay,
that we literally went and looked up the Mr. Girl thing where
he's clearly saying, "You have to stop talking about me. You're
constantly talking about me. That's why I'm doing this." Right?
And he says, "You're doing it to yourself. You're keep doing
it to yourself." So, we watched we we've gone through all of
that. He's just lying openly, but people don't have the context
to call him out on lying openly. That was my statement on it.
He's they're trying to pretend like listen like do not talk about
me or I send you to the goolag like who does this? That statement
is the same as the 50 extra discords and the room that uh you
know just has where they explicitly talk about all of my stuff
on there over and over and over again and they're linking to
it and they're referencing it and talking about it constantly.
It's clearly not the same thing. Like if or any of those side
servers made the same
Sure. Sure. Sure. Sure. also where he's like, "Oh, I wasn't trying
to link I wasn't trying to link uh Hannah's docs and him in DG
chat. Please, if somebody's bored, please re link Jacob's docs.
I'm not reink I'm not linking your docs. Wait, somebody please
link Jacob's docs, guys." Oh my god, this person's
I honestly I start to get concerned that like he's having like
an actual meltdown and is like severely not not concerned cuz
like him. Okay, I don't want to I don't want to pretend like
I'm Hassan and I'm like, "Oh, I'm very concerned about his mental."
No, no, no, Kim. But like I start to think like is this person
actually a rational actor anymore or have they like kind of lost
touch with reality and they're just like attacking anybody they
can? I don't know. I actually like I start to think yes that
he's like actually losing touch with reality at some points.
Not in a and a not in a way where I empathize with him just in
a way where like trying to analyze what he's saying is like is
there a logical way to analyze what he's saying at all? I'm actually
not sure like actually schizophrenic about me that I made about
um Anna. I would be totally fine with that. If they were like
listen guys we're not going to talk about their personal anymore.
If you want to talk about it or like their ducks or whatever
if you want to talk about it then go to CF and talk about I'd
be totally fine with I'm totally fine with you talking about
Destiny's conduct in a way that doesn't dox him or his friends
or anything along those lines. You want to talk about how he
is complete
psychopath. I'm cool with that. But don't but none of the stuff
that like obviously there's a whole bunch of stuff that's not
allowed on the server. Yeah, but Destiny I don't know. He he
doesn't really care. But realistically, he's got nothing else
to threaten people with. So that But here's the difference. Anna's
story isn't breaking from Kiwi Farms. It's breaking from Anna's
in Destiny stream. Meanwhile, the sources from the Destiny drama
come from Kiwi Farms. They kind of have to reference it to some
degree. I mean, would any reasonable person say that I do Keles
because I referenced her Kiwi Farms? Absolutely not. I'm not
set on this opinion. It's probably a case-bycase basis and I
don't know everything J Stalker Queen have said. So, I could
probably be persuaded depending on the circumstances. Let me
So, did you ask for like the evidence of this? Did he give you
anything besides like Discord logs of random?
I just like he's clearly doesn't have the evidence. I know what
you guys think. Destiny sent me a message implying that he wanted
to use these docses to sue Jstalk and Queman. Uh, I guess that's
better than posting. He publicly posted them himself. Is Willie
unaware he public that that Destiny publicly posted these things
himself? Wait, wait. Is Willie can't possibly be unaware that
Destiny publicly posted them himself? Right. He's not That would
be so lazy.
Hold on. Depending on the circumstances, let me know what you
guys think. Destiny sent me a message implying that he wanted
to use these docses to sue Jtock and Quean. Uh, I guess that's
better than posting them publicly. You said
Jtock uh has green lit. He could be unaware. Yeah, that's generally
my criticism of William is that he's an unaware that doesn't
do any actual work. He is basically going to take whatever people
give him and say that's what happened that he won't actually
cross check it. He won't use any third party source. He's just
generally like a completely lazy disgenic.
Everything coming from Kiwi Farm just includes doces of everyone
around you and they're now proceeding to uh harass you. You're
you said you have a girlfriend, right? I mean I don't I know
you probably want to keep that private maybe. I don't know. People
know you. Well, it's not because it's everybody points to Kiwi
Farms where they're doxing her constantly. or and Kelly Jean
is also like bringing up things on Kiwi Farms about her and she's
posting about those things. It might have been one of the albums
I sent you in like just Fuel's Discord and everybody knows it's
coming from Kiwi Farms. But in this message specifically to me,
you said um if I'm after any information regarding JTO that's
for my own purposes, are you going to sue Jtock or are you looking
into that option? Oh, that option. It' be nice to have that option.
Okay, it's either that or he's actually going to murder them.
One or the other. Oh, I did. Or he's just going to post the docs
and suggest people murder them via you. He's literally using
you as a vehicle for the threats thinking that that won't be
tied back to his channel. Troll the of the DOS kid. That's a
guy that's one of the people like legitimately like I was so
you have no like it's actually kind of scary like how close he
just implied no one knew they were dating. Well, I think he just
doesn't know, right? He didn't look it up. He doesn't have any
idea close I was to getting people together to go down to his
house and kill him and his family or it would have it would have
just been him and his father. I don't cuz I didn't know anything
about dude that that was some of the most
upiting close to doing it, but I was making so much money on
Twitch and I had and I'm I don't know if Nathan was involved
in yet, but for whatever reason I decided that the current life
I have wasn't worth the risk of I can't believe like unless I
missed it in the video. Willie appears to be unaware that Destiny
published those doces, right? Can somebody I'm looking at chat
like did I miss it? Which maybe, hold on. But also, wait, wait,
wait. The way he's talking about it, maybe he's trying to protect
the fact that that Destiny did do that. Maybe, maybe he doesn't
want to. No, no, no. Maybe maybe possibly he doesn't want to
draw attention to the fact that those were published. I think,
right, that could be possible. So, maybe I shouldn't be Maybe
he's just like, "No, no, no. I can't I can't mention it or also
draw attention to it." It's possible that's his argument, right?
But then he says like But then he asks questions about it and
he leaves them open. That feels like a little weird thing to
do. Oh my god. Oh my god. I was so close to this dress. I had
streets mapped out and every You had no idea. That's when I first
started getting an interest in like owning a weapon. I got a
permit to own a gun and everything.
[__] the bad times don't pass by. These are just
some other things from my journey that I found interesting. Denims
threw herself in is one of the victims who was secretly recorded.
like he's he has so many victims and he has done this same shtick
over and over and over again where he reaches out um or other
women reach out to him who are 18 or 19 or 20 and he does the
same song and dance where he tries to use and abuse them and
then discard them when it's no longer relevant or useful for
him. Unfortunately, I made the mistake of not having had with
him and after that point um he decided to just do a full smear
campaign on me and threatened to
leak in this case. I feel like it's important to recognize that
illegal recordings of me. Okay. Okay. So, Denims went out of
her way to say, as in like, I don't have the same claims as these
people, but I think he's a complete piece of
um we had a conversation and he recorded it in California, which
is a two-party consent state. Um, which you This House MD3 guy
is actually brain damaged. Yelling into the void, all leaker
dudes didn't come off as necessarily malicious. Okay. cannot
record people without I think I would love to I would love to
respond to that like in a way that is appropriate but I am live
on Twitch and literally any appropriate response to you in particular
would break the Twitch to so consent to hold I basically didn't
talk about it because like I said he is like revenge
someone it wouldn't make sense that you could do revenge
I think that person might be saying that Destiny is more impulsive
rather than like planning out like more more impulsive than like
calculated. I I'm getting the sense that that's what they're
arguing. And I mean that may be true. Um that may be true. He
certainly can be very impulsive.
Yeah. But impulsive malice is arguing that somebody like somebody
like losing their mind and um yeah, losing their mind and beating
somebody to death is like a malicious act because they didn't
form like a solid intent beforehand to do it. I think that's
crazy. Also, by the way, I'm going to get going, guys. It's late.
I got to get up for work tomorrow.
Good night. Talk to you later. I appreciate you coming by. Bye.
Thanks. Bye. Cole, he's a cynical piece of black hole whose only
goal is to abuse women. I saw this and was like, man, Destiny
must have really victimized her in some way if she's talking
like this. Uh, so I asked Destiny and he says that Denim stayed
in his apartment for 2 days banging a dude without his knowledge.
However, one weird thing happened where two days before TwitchCon
ends, okay, Denims, all right, she said that she um had to catch
a ride back to LA early that you can form a malicious intent
like immediately though. That's the issue, right? This is the
entire argument of like, oh, did Oh, there's there's a bunch
of arguments like this, but you can you can basically instantly
form a malicious intent and only one guy could give her a ride
back. Okay, are you following me? Yeah. Okay, now to be polite
and because I'm mindful of like I don't want some girl like I'll
let this play. I'm going to use the bathroom really quickly.
I'll be right back. Whatever. I told like, "Okay, yeah, no problem.
That's fine or whatever." Um, however, like if you need to like
use my apartment cuz you need like a place to stay so you're
not like trapped with some random dude or whatever. Like here's
how to get into my apartment just so you know. She's like, "Okay,
thanks." 2 days later, me, Molina, and I think Karina or whatever.
Um, we end up like driving back to uh LA. Uh, pull into my apartment.
It's in Glendale. uh go upstairs, open my apartment door, and
then in my loft up pops Denim's head and the guy. And I realized
that Denims and the guy had just spent the last two days in my
apartment with my computer on like all my I'm like, "What the?"
This was incredibly weird to me. I don't know why she thought
I would have been okay with that. It was so dramatic. I sat them
both down. I was like, "Listen, okay, this is all too much. Too
dramatic, too weird. Like, I don't want anything to do with either
of you guys. This is like crazy. This has gotten like way too
wacky." Um, they both acknowledged that they had both been like
unhinged and crazy and they understood and blah blah blah. And
then after that, like we like all kind of went our separate ways.
Now, I did record that conversation because the big fear I had
and this happened 2 days later. Denims goes online with her new
guy and she's like, "Stephen kicked me out because I wouldn't."
And that's pretty much what she's claiming now. So, when Destiny
offered me the recording, I took it. I listened to it and he's
right. She's just lying about the whole thing. By the way, uh
it's so awesome of Destiny to give a to give a third party evidence
that he broke California's wiretapping laws, that he broke California's
like um multi-party consent laws. I don't know why he would do
that. It's actually probably I think this may be like the dumbest
thing I've ever heard in my life. Like, "Hey, Willie, you want
proof that I broke that I don't care about the uh the legal system
in the state I'm in? You want proof of me breaking this exact
corresponding law that's in California? Oh, sorry. That's in
Florida while I'm in California. Do you Would you like me to
do that? Oh, yeah. Here we go. Oh, is that the recording Dems
was talking about? Yes. Is not allowed to be in the apartment?
[__] no. Really?
[__] no. Why was I not told that he was not allowed
to be in the apartment? I wouldn't assume he would bring a stranger
into my apartment without asking me when. To be clear, Destiny
is incredibly incredibly redacted guy's name. Wait, Atlas. She
just said Atlas multiple times. But uh but also really quickly
um Desi's clearly just pissed that he wanted to denim and she
this other guy, right? Like that's why he's so angry right now.
I'm sorry. He can act like it's like, "Oh, I thought it's insane
that you bring another person here, but he is absolutely more
upset that Denim's another guy." I'm sorry. That's super easy
to put together. Uh you can you can be mad you can be mad about
both, in fact. And maybe he is mad about both, but I I'm sorry.
He's way more mad about that. I do think it's like for Denim's
it. I'm trying to think. He also leaked some like emails from
her. I'd love to know the timeline on this cuz I don't totally
remember the um the Atlas timeline. But yeah, it's super funny
that he posted this though that he's like, "Yeah, I don't care
about multi-party consent laws. Volunteers to drive you back.
I I don't I don't know what how you feel 100% cuz you don't talk
about any of this stuff." which is fine. So like if you're like
in an awkward situation, right? I'm trying to be a good guy and
give you a way out like, "Hey, well my apartment is open if you
want to go in." So that gives you the ability to either say like,
"Oh no, it's okay. I'll go with" or "Okay, thanks for offering.
I'll go to your apartment." Why is he censoring Atlas now that
Denim's Denim said it multiple times at the beginning? That wasn't
like bring into my apartment for him to have free rain in here
for a day. Holy sh That is so weird. And not only that, but you
couldn't even lie about it correctly. You told three different
lies to her people. You told Molina, "Ew, I would never." And
I got into that. I never said that. You did. I Wait, wait, wait,
wait. Why? Hold on. Revoked was like, "No, no, no." He's not
mad at all that he that she this guy, right? But now Destiny's
like, "Wait, you told Mina that you never this guy?" Wait, that's
super relevant to them having in his bed, right? That's super
relevant. I think I think that's clearly what he's pissed about
is that she this guy that that it's just that there's another
guy in his house, right? It's not at all that she's like another
It's not at all that he wanted her to himself. I I'm just saying
it's very interesting that that's the first place his mind went.
That's the first question he has. No, I've never heard this recording
before. I looked at the text. You did? OMG, no. Yes. You Okay.
OMFG. No. So, I come home and you're both still here. Why? Why
would you Why would you put me in this weird spot where I had
to come home and see an incredibly creepy that is such a weird
position in my Wait, why is he an incredibly creepy guy? What
What did the guy do that was incredibly creepy? Did the guy even
do the guy even do anything? Did he even know that he wasn't
supposed to be there? Or as far as I know, Atlas was a DG chatter.
He probably loved Destiny. Did he even know he wasn't supposed
to be there? I'm sorry. The question he's the questions he's
asking just prove me so correct. Every single coper in chat who
was like, "No, no, no. He was just mad cuz there's somebody he
didn't expect in his house." Actually, end it. End it now. Pay
homage. I was correct. Such an easy call. Thank you very much.
We won. Community that's been trying to get me to stop talking
to my ex-girlfriend because he's trying so hard to is now somebody
else in my bed, dragging his hairy balls across my blankets.
Okay, this is this is a totally fair thing to be mad about, right?
This is a totally fair thing to be mad about, but he's mad that
it's this guy. He's mad that it's this dude. Okay. Oh my god.
And so we leave for an hour. He's like, "Holy [__]
by the way,
it's totally reasonable to be mad about this. This is This is
totally reasonable to be mad about."
100%.
Right. It's totally reasonable to be pissed that some random
dude's in your bed your bed. That's totally reasonable. I'm just
telling you that's not the thing that annoys him most. That's
not it. It's that it's this guy who he's had a little feud with
who's denims in his house. It's not It's not that he want he
didn't want balls dragging across his bed. It's not that. It's
that this guy him in a metaphorical sense, which realistically
I mean some DJers I I thought Yogi would be like totally jumping
on this. This is proof that he doesn't like getting How is Yogi
not holding this up as like evidence that Destiny actually isn't
a You'd think so, but apparently Yogi is not doing his job very
well. Bro, you need to ride way harder than this for an hour
and come back and and you're both still there. Oh god. I don't
know if he's like I need to get like a few more logs or pictures
off of Destiny's computer. Holy [__] I don't think
I've ever had somebody me that hard where I've tried to like
offer somebody to somebody in my entire life. I don't think I've
ever been like so burned on somebody before. I don't know if
that's Jordan Peterson. Destiny kicks her out of the house and
before she goes, she says, "I thought it was okay because I thought
this weirdo guy changed for the better." completely missing the
point for why he didn't like her there. At this point, I'm like,
am I a like I thought I was a pretty good judge of characters,
so now I'm like, am I a really bad judge of character? Um, has
he changed since the last time he's been in your community? Uh,
is everything that like um I've been told like fake or something.
And it's like really me because
do we have access to the whole call? We don't need access to
the whole call. We heard the things that he was actually emotional
about right off the bat. Generally speaking, I have a relatively
good read on people. So,
or you wouldn't be in Destiny's house. Denim's trying to throw
herself in with these victims. It's so disgusting. She sees all
these alleged victims and she goes, "I want to be one of them.
Let me hide behind Kelly." Oh, we got to signal to the I law
so he can't prove me wrong. It had nothing to do with hooking
up with Destiny. She lies with a smile. I also want to address
what? Okay, one second. Isn't that the first thing she said was
that it wasn't anything?
She did say it wasn't. She I think she sufficiently differentiated
herself from the victims, but um he's going to he has to do this
basically. I guess he included that in the clip he played of
her. So, I'm not sure why he's bothered because it came out at
the same time and she was saying and I think like probably, you
know, realistically Will Willie might not like this, but this
take being out there and then Destiny posting evidence of it,
Destiny is accused in the in the Cherry case of basically wiretapping,
recording conversations without consent. Right? This is proof
that he doesn't care about those laws, that he will hand off
evidence of him breaking those laws from another state. It's
the same law. He's just offered this proof to Willie Mack directly
and he has said repeatedly he does not care about these laws.
This is
evidence. So I mean I guess this has worked out well for everybody.
Also replay him saying she is hiding behind California law. Wait,
really? Hold on. Did Willie really say that? I think he
Yeah.
Denim's trying to throw herself in with these victims is so disgusting.
She sees all these alleged victims and she goes, "I want to be
one of them. Let me hide behind California law." So he can't
prove me wrong. It had
Wait, this is I realize he thinks he just doesn't understand.
He just doesn't understand. This is the same law that he is going
to be charged with in Florida if the cherry thing proceeds. We'll
be be wiretapping, violating this multi-party consent for recording
conversations. Now, with that law, there is an escalator, I believe,
for recording stuff that makes it into a felony. Right. This
is but this is literally evidence of him committing that crime
before and not caring about the laws. There are also monologues
he goes on where he talks about how he doesn't care about you
know whatever however many like sorry multi-party consent. He
doesn't care about any of that because it's all about you know
his reputation. I mean that's fine but he literally talks about
it right. Yeah. I think you could just extend a little bit of
charitability there when it comes to people being able to prove
that somebody is something. being able to add this like bad character
behavior. Um, it makes it easier to prove a pattern. So, I don't
think it's bad that Denim said something. I think she gave enough
qualifiers before. I legitimately feel like this could absolutely
be evidence in uh in like Cher's case. Unironically, I think
this video could and you know what? I'm going to be way more
charitable than Willy Mack because for some reason Destiny thought
it was a good idea to publish this this uh recording that he
recorded without the other party's consent um in knowing violation
of California's laws and published it in knowing violation of
California's laws, right? That's awesome that he would just go
and do that. That's insane, but it's cool. Nothing to do with
hooking up with Destiny. She lies with a smile. I also want to
address one particular guy who has determined that I can't upload
this video until I respond to him. Well, I work wait a lot of
people in Queens chat disagreed about what Missy Elliot did Que
like this is obviously evidence towards that same crime cuz I
Queen is not I think feel like he would make that point. Denims
is listed as a witness in Cher's thing maybe. Sorry in uh sorry
in Pixie's thing maybe but Pixie and Jerry's things are
disjointed. Was the Bob 7 also in the states with the law? Well
uh when you go to Discord stuff it's a little different. I'm
not totally sure how Discord stuff gets resolved, but for uh
for the inerson stuff that just state laws apply to that, right?
So, this is an in-person recording for the Dems thing with the
Cherry thing. It's an inerson recording. It'll just be the state
laws in those cases. Also, I don't know. Like, this is um this
is California law. I wonder if you could be charged in California
for this. I wonder what the statute of limitations is. I'm interesting
to know. Sorry. What is the lie he's accusing Denims of making
here? Like what what is she lying about? Willy. Willie, he's
saying that that she's trying to get attention for herself and
that it's sort of that she's lying and saying that it was because
Destiny didn't have with her, but it was not. It's like that
she feels I don't know caught. Okay. So, it's not a very obvious
lie. This is uh her interpretation of something or what is I
mean, yeah, it's like an opinion thing. I don't I don't know
if she's totally correct here, but yeah, it's like more of an
opinion thing. It might also be I mean if you're trying to recollect
events from how many years ago when you're not the one with the
recording. Yeah, maybe it's a bit hard. Hold on. Somebody's sending
me this clip which Yeah, that's just I'm going to say somebody.
It's obviously Wendy cuz he has the video. But hold on. Generally,
most people usually take advantage of like I think if I try to
be nice to somebody almost every single time it gets Oh, the
denim's recording. Um I actually sent that Denim's recording.
Oh, this is like a good example actually. Um, I sent that Denim's
recording to a few people, but um, he's also he's also like a
totally Machavevelian gigad apparently. What I did was I loaded
that recording into Audacity and I cut off like 1 to 7 seconds
from every single recording. Um, so that when I sent it to somebody,
I wrote down in a notepad like what length of the recording I
sent to each person so that I knew that if it ever got leaked,
I could figure out like who in my friends is ever leaking. That's
like an example of like that I do because I don't really trust
people that I interact with. Um, I still have that notepad on
my desk saved. So, if you ever leak that recording, I'm going
to know it was you. He's paranoid as well. That's funny. So,
yeah, threatening all the people who he sent this recording to,
the illegally made recording. The um the thing about like Molina
though is that Molina is like 21. Um, by the way, I actually
don't even know I don't even know if the rest of this is relevant.
Honestly, this isn't that relevant, Wendy. It's like not and
Molina is super like trustworthy of like most people like Molina
um Oh, it isn't. Okay, there isn't. But I will say it's like
him referencing the recording. There are other there are are
other places in his VODs where he does talk about how he records
conversations and people say that's illegal and he says I don't
care about that. I'll deal with whatever penalty from the courts.
Okay, I record everything. I don't care. It's like, okay, I guess
that's definitely to put that on tape, but hey, whatever. All
right, we are getting near the end of the video on this video,
so I better get to it. It's called Willie Mack PR for a predator.
He's mad at me for interviewing Destiny as if I'm somehow giving
Destiny clout. So, Willie Mack is choosing to platform a violent
psychopathic criminal who wants other creators doxed murdered
and is laughing about it on Twitter. These two are so unlikable.
Referring to the people Destiny Daxton wants dead, even when
they're being threatened with their docks. Notice how he doesn't
mention the death threats. I can't help but notice how big off
losers they are. He wants me to pearl clutch over Destiny's violent
remarks where in the tweet I'm quoting, Queman is making violent
remarks towards another Twitter account who simply post.
Yeah, Queman is not speaking in a literal sense here and he actually
clarifies this. And when we asked Destiny to clarify, he's like,
"No, no, I totally want these people." When Willie Mack asked
him to clarify, he says, "No, I totally want these people."
And how? Yes. By the way, and because Willie Mack is too and
too inbred to actually make this distinction, I don't make violent
remarks. In fact, I disagree with Quimman. So, I don't I don't
know what more needs to be done here to say I like I literally
differentiate myself from other opinions all of the time. Who's
in my pant?
Just for reference, also don't make violent remarks. My violent
remark response is simply come come here then I would love to
see you turn up. You never will. Uh also Desi had published the
docs before this which Willie still doesn't know about apparently
because again he is a completely like he is the laziest commentary
YouTuber that exists. Although I will say hold on I should give
him his props. I think this is the best Willy Mac video that's
ever been made. This is the most work that's ever gone in. I'm
pretty sure. So, I will give him props on that. He has worked
at least five times harder on this than he did on the previous
one. So, you know what? I'll give him props on that. Pretty good.
I think I can't really criticize any of the Anna stuff. The laugh
stuff was okay. I have a few criticisms of mine, but it's nothing
Um, it was, yeah, I would say it was better overall, but I remember
Willie showing a screenshot of Desessie threatening Queen's docs
in this video. He did. He knows that Desi threatened the docs.
He just doesn't know that the docs were published. that desech
tried to publish docs on us right just for um just for reference
there is a latency delay this has been shown when I've sung for
example so yes I do talk over justical
I do talk over justical occasionally it's accidental does anybody
have that clip that was very
that was a very good clip but it's like from the first like two
months of the stream so I don't know if anybody has it anymore
that's for the old heads they'd know that clip uh so he's comparing
Destiny doxing and then um talking about how he wants us wants
somebody else to kill us, right? And then actually going into
far more Willie would be understanding. Willie would know cuz
he recorded the interview that Destiny goes into far more detail
about how and how he would try to kill us. How if he stopped
streaming he'll try to kill us how exactly he would want us,
right? So there are a lot more death threats and he knows about
the doc's threats. Obviously there's no comparison between Quimman's
comment here which again is metaphorical although it is possibly
you could say feels like it's threatening. I don't think anybody's
concerned about that. But hey, if you want to make that argument
is clearly on a totally different level. So comparing these is
totally disingenuous. And the only reason you do so is cuz you're
a sthing like a pathetic
hack loser, right? He needs to be like absolutely kicked into
the dirt. I think he just hates his son. But stomped into the
dirt. This guy, if you want to say that these guys say violent
things just like Destiny, they were a huge fan. I think I can
make violent jokes, but I will obviously clear up that they're
jokes and I obviously I try to make it clear that it is a joke
in the moment, right? But again, these guys, he just like blamed
me for Quan's rhetoric, which I don't know like how how much
globbing can you do? Although he to be fair, he might not be
able to tell the difference between our voices. I I can't tell
like once you reach, you know, the 50s in terms of IQ, can you
differentiate between different voices? Do you like lose that
capability?
fans of him up until recently. I don't feel like anyone's in
any actual danger. Violence just like Tidy. Is that Is that irony?
I assume that's a joke. I think Pensive Goat's joking. I have
no idea.
But if they feel like they are, they should thank me for giving
them the warning and call the cops. He says I'm downplaying Destiny's
crimes for predicting that his career won't end over this. You're
totally right. Just like Destiny, they were fans of him up until
recently. I don't they were huge fans of Oh, he just said Queen
is a huge fan of Destiny up until recently. Well, if there's
any question if the was back on Willy Mac. I'm pretty sure that
solved that. Damn, Queen was the biggest Destiny fan up until
recently. Damn, Queen. He got you. He just boomed you. He just
you. It's over for Quean. Huge Destiny fan. This guy's Okay,
it's fine. This guy's like actually completely completely completely
brain dead. don't feel like anyone's in any actual danger, but
if they feel like they are, they should thank me for giving them
the warning and call the cops. He says I'm downplay I wasn't
mad at Willie for publishing that. Wait, I I think you probably
could argue that um the combination of doxing and death threats,
like I probably am entitled to call the cops. I just don't think
I would. It's just not something I want to like pursue. It just
doesn't seem worth the time, right? It's like a it's like an
internet threat. I don't know if anything would be done, but
I think there's like probably precedent under Florida law that
I could do something, right? Like I almost certainly could file
a police report. I just don't think I'm going to. I would much
rather I would much rather do what I'm actually going to
do. Much better. Much better answer. Okay. Why would I want to
go to the cops? You'd have to dox yourself to do it. Yeah, I'm
not concerned about that. But um obviously through one of these
police cases, I'm pretty sure I'll get doxed in the end anyway.
So, or sorry, one of the crim one of the court cases. I think
I'll get doxed anyway, probably eventually. But yeah, I'm I'm
way more happy with like the course I'm taking, which I'm not
going to really elaborate, but that's way better. And it would
probably be way more upsetting to Destiny, right? Destiny doesn't
care about like a criminal thing at all. Playing Destiny's Crimes
for predicting that his career won't end over this. You're totally
right, but I have never seen someone's career end over some like
this. There's Willie Mack downplaying Destiny's Crimes who gets
interrupted by Nicholas Dioro. Yeah, know that's probably just
true. or commentary's top janitor. The Oreo downplays Willy's
downplaying of Destiny's crimes, then make sure that they're
on Destiny hard enough. Destiny's videos are getting hundreds
of thousands of views. He's streaming live to over 30,000 people.
Why is me being factually correct about how this will affect
his career, downplaying what he did? I think the bigger problem
is when people like this guy equate what Destiny did to Jeffrey
Epstein, especially when we're talking about a guy with the nickname
Epstein, or when JTO says Destiny has created a machine. I think
one of the big I mean a massive talking point here is the infinite
machine. Okay. How does the infinite machine work? You guys make
what I so so like this. So like I I have a hard time putting
like ver verbalizing precisely how that is and how how poorly
researched your video has to be to take me quoting President
Sunday's metaphor,
right? and and then say I'm saying Destiny has a machine or an
infinite red machine. I didn't come up with the metaphor. I am
literally quoting I'm quoting Sunday's metaphor. And if you want
to see just how bad it is, let me go grab because somebody sent
me the clip and I'm like, wait, I'm pretty sure I said that I
talked about Sunday. I'm almost positive. And I'm I'm pretty
sure one of the big What is the What is the mission? I can explain.
Well, I'm I think I'm about to explain the infinite dildo max
9,000. No, I think I'm I'm about to explain the infinite machine.
I mean, a massive talking point here is the infinite machine.
Okay. How does the infinite machine work a massive talking point?
That's Sunday's like predicate for for releasing this information
and disregarding Pixie's wellbeing, right? Which you'd know if
you're a part of if you watch the Sunday video. This it's not
just about nudes, bro. This I literally I literally like this
guy is actually just a complete [__] loser. Like
he didn't watch 15 seconds beyond. This is like the second time
that he could have gone and spent 10 seconds and been a thousand
times less than he actually is. He's actually that stupid. It's
crazy. He's actually like I can't even really describe how dumb
he is. It's amazing.
It's amazing. Could you imagine being this lazy? Does he edit
his own videos? Do you think he edits his own videos? Do you
think like who do you think gave him this clip? Like at this
point, I'm just like like who could possibly be feeding you information?
I can't believe that Nicholas Deorio watched this and was like,
"Yeah, I add this clip. Yeah, add this clip." Like why didn't
he check this with Doro? Doro is is your janitor. Doro is the
one who does keep you from being a complete like bumbling stumbling.
How did you How did you this up this badly? Lazy or intentional?
I don't know. It's just it's almost it's like comical how stupid
he is. The infinite machine is a metaphor for Destiny's channel,
right? Is practically the conveyor belt for women to be abused.
Yes. It's like the Destiny platform orbit. All of this is like
the Sunday called it the infinite machine because it's like yes,
women will come in and be abused and then they'll be discredited
and it will all keep running like clockwork no matter how many
women get discredited and go through. Right.
Autist. We need a picture of Willax Palm to help determine if
he has fetal alcohol syndrome. This is a noble goal. I hope we
can all get behind. I mean, to be honest, the Lynx person seems
far more capable of high level reasoning than Willie Mack, and
she clearly has fel syndrome. So, all right. I do want to say
something.
Lynx versus Willy. I got $500 on Lynx beating him in an IQ test.
Okay. Lynx versus Willy. If we can both get them to get officiated
IQ test. I got 500 bucks on on Lynx beating him. Okay. Let's
go. Let's go. Let's get it set up. Okay. I don't want anyone
to complain that I interrupt your sickle after that. Jesus Christ.
I'm just saying. I'm just saying. What I would say is it's very
easy from where we sit from our perspective to point out the
bits that Willie Mack has got wrong. Right. But we're terminally
online in this space and it directly affects us. So, of course,
we kind of know far more without having to do any real work or
research because it involves us, right? So, it is a little bit
easy to be like, "Oh, he's got everything. He's got this." It's
easy to be a bit nitpicky in this instance is mostly what I'm
getting at. I'm not saying you shouldn't criticize any of that.
Oh, no. No. He's a completely pathetic. I wasn't really listening
to you, but sure. If you were like kind of saying like, "Oh,
well, he wouldn't know this." No, he has to know this. Literally,
he made a video where he criticized President Sun. He said he
watched video watch President Sunday's video. Brilliant. Oh,
what did you say? Sorry. Go ahead. I said that he's not in the
scene. We don't have to do any research because it's happening
to us. We're already aware of Yeah. So, that's a totally point
because he made a video about President Sunday's video. Yeah,
that was a totally No, I'm not saying the point was about this
point. At no point did I say that. You've been criticizing him
for not knowing a lot of things. It's not necessarily about the
president Sunday meme at all. Yeah. The two things I criticized
him for primarily are this one where he could have spent 10 seconds
watch a little further and see me say that it was Sunday's thing
and then he did a video on the Sunday thing so she should just
know that. And then there was the one where he could have read
the rest of the non- highlighted yellow text and had a completely
like like a dagger argument against Destiny saying that oh no no
no I couldn't have possibly thought I didn't have her consent
because he literally was talking about how he'd violated her
trust in the worst possible way. Those are the two primary claims
I made and they were both 10 seconds away. So, what I was talking
about Great, if you let me talk finish. Yeah. What I'm talking
about is the broad sweeping statements you made about Willie
being the worst uh YouTuber who does the worst research, worst
cont. Okay. Yes, you if you can find me another commentary YouTuber
who can who who literally is incapable of reading to the end
of the paragraph and actually making his point. If you find me
another one, I will retract that. But I need you to find me another
saying is it's easy from like he interviewed you and you were
trying to take his side a little bit and I totally get it but
I don't really care so I'm going to go is the infinite machine
okay how does the infinite I am being a you're you're making
really bad points being disrespect I need you to make better
points please you can still criticize him I have not you you're
correct the stuff on President Sunday it's does look very stupid
but I'm just saying from our perspective it is quite easy to
say this because we know everything whereas if you asked us for
example, to do this type of in-depth analysis on something that
has nothing to do with us, doesn't involve us, isn't in our community,
would we do any better? Probably not. So, I'm just I think I
would think I think I would. I just don't have a YouTube channel.
As soon as I have a YouTube channel, I will actually endeavor
to prove that I can do this a thousand times better. Yes, you
are delusional. But anyway, I'm going to continue. Think of all
of the callers that we have in that have absolutely no clue what's
happening all of the time and they're in our community like ingesting
your content and they still don't know what's going on. So like,
yeah, okay, Willie could have done better here and the President
Sono one is pretty funny, honestly. To get wrong, but like I
I just saying probably saying he's like the worst research YouTuber
of all time. Probably not quite for the worst commentary YouTuber
that I'm aware of. Yeah, like pretty. I think you're being uh
Yeah, it's a bit harsh. Yeah. No. Um, and these two points that
I raised, the two primary like uh actual arguments I made, those
are proof of it. But we can continue work. You guys make what
Destiny actually did wrong seem not that bad because Destiny
didn't anybody. He didn't traffic anyone. He broke people. Oh,
is is me referencing Hold on. Is me referencing
is me referencing the infinite machine saying the word rape.
That's really bad. So he would have this criticism for Chud Logic
who put in his thumbnails repeatedly, right? I wish I had the
chud clip. I don't have the chud clip, but I wish I had the chud
clip right now where he's basically like, "Oh, you're mad about
me saying, well, you're a waiting loser piece of [__]
Don't come in here moralized to me about how I can't say with
regards to this guy violating multiple women's consent, right?"
But again, Willie Willie probably wouldn't make this point if
he'd known Chud had made that point, right? And he obviously
he would spend a lot of time attacking Chud for the same point,
right? It's not just that he's seething about me that he has
to go try to find a quote of me. Sorry, a a quote of me where
I'm literally referencing somebody else's point and somebody
else's hypothetical, their metaphor for the situation. You're
the mind. Yeah. Yeah. The or the mind. It's um Yeah. I I can't
believe it's just a sad sad attempt. Wrong seemed not that bad
because Destiny didn't anybody. He didn't traffic anyone. He
broke people's trust who were intimate with him so he could the
19-year-old egirl leading to these people's image. What is being
forever? Oh, he still Oh, he still thinks that um Rose had the
cherry audio. I see. He just used a bunch of cherry texts to
say, "Oh, this 19-year-old e-girl, Rose didn't ever have the
cherry audio." Cemented online. Their employers, their kids,
their family members can be harassed forever now. That should
be enough to hold him to the fire. But the minute you make it
about people go, "Huh, he someone
I I just I hope he would do the same thing for Chud." We'll see.
No, I said Hassan is bad when you said it. when you sent it,
Zuul. I did it. I did it. Just so you know. Oh. Oh, no he didn't.
He sent nudes. Oh, well then who cares? You also Again, this
is just him wanting to make a criticism of me and he's totally
failed to make that criticism. Like embarrassingly so, right?
He literally pulled a quote of me talking about somebody else's
hypothetical, right? Literally only because he wants to fight
with me apparently. Like he he just We all agree on that, right?
That he just totally like made that up. He just didn't understand
whatsoever. also risk getting sued for calling it. But that's
just me sweeping. I guess common sense is sweeping. He says I
shouldn't reach out to Destiny for comments. Reaching out for
comment can be helpful sometimes. However, it is not the ultimate
journalistic tool, especially when we're talking about a guy
with the nickname Epstein. I think he did it intentionally. Uh,
somebody said he references Sunday again and Sunday specifically
with regards to Pixie. I thought he did it right away, but I
didn't hear it right away. Maybe I missed it. You shouldn't reach
What was that? Who is this speaking right now? the glitch poachers
thing. Oh, rewind and play it again. Wait, what are you confused
about? The whole Yeah, Kelly did kind of distract from that whole
thing. Yeah, she she does that often. Um, the whole point with
regards to me
Yeah, the whole point with regards to me was he used this clip
entirely disingenuously. This is me saying, "Oh, the machine."
I'm talking about the machine here, right? But what's actually
happening is I'm quoting Sunday's talking about a guy with the
nickname Epstein or when JTO says Destiny has created a machine.
I think one of the Yeah, this isn't my thing. I didn't come up
with this and I'm quoting Sunday here and I literally say it's
Sunday's thing. I mean a massive talking point here is the infinite
rate machine. Okay. How does the infinite rate machine work?
You guys make what? So I'm literally using that to analyze what
Nicholas is talking about. And if he'd watched, you know, 10
seconds long. I think one of the big I mean a massive talking
point here is the infinite rate machine. Okay. How does the infinite
rate machine work? It's a massive talking point. That's Sunday's
like predicate for for releasing this information and disregarding
Pixie's well-being, right? Which you'd know if you're a part
of the if you watch the Sunday video, this it's not just about
nudes, bro. I literally I literally say if you watch the Sunday
video, you'd know that this is Sunday's talking point. You'd
know about all of this. It's very very funny that he actually
he actually totally totally this up in like an embarrassingly
this is like Idubbbz tier actually right this is like anything
you any criticism you can make of Idubbbz this is like significantly
more embarrassing classic Willy Mac classic Willy Mac oh it's
about a system that let this happen for so long when there was
a ton of By the way this is not the video we're going to keep
watching my bad actually did wrong see this is malicious it seems
malicious uh hold on we got a Chudlo logic clip. Let's see it
here. What is this one? Apologists. You are apologists. And that's
the [__] end of it. And there's literally nothing
you can do to stop me thinking that because that is what I believe.
She also repeatedly claims that the main purpose of the statement
was about preventing me from harming. Hold on. Wait. Where's
the Where's the You are. She also repeatedly me from harming.
Maybe when I was an orbiter. Too late. Maybe when I was an orbiter.
Maybe when I was an orbiter, I might have been pressed by your
presence, but I'm not anymore. You're nothing to me. You're worthless.
You're useless. This is like Dr. Disrespect fans getting upset
because you're talking about him having admitted to doing something
and then his desperate backtrack is accepted by his most cretinous
fans and they all come in and they're like, "Oh no, actually
Charlie was doing it to trick the journalists." You're exactly
the same level of subhuman low IQ freak to me. Okay. So, you're
wasting your breath. You're wasting your time.
Get attack me at all prior to releasing it. Why was her publishing
this? Okay. Hold on though, Wendy. You understand? The whole
point of this was to find the part where he says uh that the
people who are crit this is him talking to the people who are
calling or criticizing him for having in his thumbnail. Right.
Right. Am I crazy? Statement contingent on my response to her
and but she didn't include that part. I could have sworn that
was this part
come out than a video of you sucking with your face visible and
you being identifiable. So, I think that Pixie's framing of this
with the primary concern being her somewhere in here. He does
this. He He does it somewhere in here. He's like, "Oh, don't
come and [__] moralize to me about using the word."
Like, obviously the word is so much closer to what the actual
conduct is here than like what you're willing to admit. You're
you're just disgusting. You're delusional. You're waiting for
saying this. Her being leaked is totally destiny, dude. That
type of stuff. You got to recognize and okay I'm speaking like
you said he would someone with a trouble whatever this you need
to recognize guys all these people that are making these arguments
in chat
they're wanted any possible excuse to justify and rationalize
Destiny's disgusting despicable behavior and they've got it now
and then as normally happens the community goes out to the broader
internet had this yesterday a bunch of on his tweets and they
spin the narratives and they spin the narratives it's okay they'll
go back into their cave DG And you know, they'll go back to jerking
each other off about what great they are, right? How do I make
money after depressed people? It's irritating to deal with, but
here to be a lot of movement to deal with [__] shaming
in the It is definitely this stream. Uh yeah, DG is the That's
awesome. I have no idea how Destiny thinks this will look good.
Thank you for the super chats. Thank you. In that photo, you
show with Destiny sending the Eirl the video 2022. Is that guaranteed
a video pixie? Uh that is the message chain that results in Pixie's
video getting leaked. And uh yeah, you see this is the other
problem too. You get these people and they engage in this malicious
skepticism where every piece of information is scrutinized to
a certain Banana Bender became a member. Banana Bender celebrates
one month of membership. Me bro streamer got exposed for secretly
recording a woman's obfiscation level 5,000. Imagine thinking
we can we can get here eventually. I can feel it. Sometimes I
feel like the the spirit of Chud grip me and I say some unhinged
unhinged. Sorry. like uh Tim Pool like views the worlds through
through uh Trump's like stretched out scrotum over his eyes.
Like that's the lens under which he views the world. I think
I think I'm like I'm getting there. Okay. I'm slowly becoming
like more blackpilled and more unhinged. And eventually I'll
have spent so little time around the rest of humanity and only
streaming to you guys that I will be able to say the level of
unhinged that he does. Okay. Eventually. Eventually. This is
logic. Women actually and this actually experience literally
don't care about rape victims. So, you know, good luck next time,
but I don't care about rape victims where you're going to be
able to [__] moralize because I'm calling you rap
apologists. You are rape apologists. And that's the end of it.
And there's literally nothing you can do to stop me thinking
that because that is what I believe. She also repeatedly claims
that the main purpose. Sorry, that's it right there. That is
my thoughts towards Willy Mack. You're never going to be able
to moralize this or make me think that I've done something wrong
when I'm literally quoting a Sunday thing by the way. But I have
said I think I've said uh I've I've used some analogy towards
rap in this before. But that is the point right there. Right.
And of course, like Chud's defended that way harder. Chud had
a whole stream about this. But Willie Mack tries to use a clip
of me quoting somebody else's metaphor and then say I'm the one
who's making this about I'm the one who's overblowing this and
making it about rap. He's actually So listen, and you could never
get me, okay? Many, many times I've said the word, you know,
and possibly overblown it a little bit, but Willie Mack is the
now. He is completely he's never been in his entire life. And
that's not that's not overblown, okay? His [__] is
the size of a [__] tennis ball right now. It's [__]
of the statement was about preventing me from harming other women.
Sorry we don't have to keep watching this but thank you. Thank
you Chud for the backup. Not that bad because Destiny didn't
anybody. He didn't traffic anyone. He broke people's trust who
were intimate with him so he could the 19-year-old egirl leading
to these people's images being forever cemented online. Their
employer. Sorry. Where's Zezy? Is Zezy still here after he was
like sweeping for Willy Mac earlier to watch all of this? I hope
Zezy is still here. Zezy, sound off in chat. Show me that you're
still here after you you were defending this guy for being such
a I don't I don't see Zezy typing in chat. So, oh, hooligans,
hold on. You were also saying some in chat. Can you admit that
you're completely now or this guy's such a disingenuous piece
of for doing this? It's actually
disgusting over over a beef over like I I literally got in a
call with him by the way. I think he brings it up later. It's
another clip I got where he talks about how I didn't watch his
full video. I watched the video the parts I was talking about.
Oh, you were saying you were saying Willie Mack won or something
in here earlier. Who? That's all. Here's their kids, their family
members can be harassed forever now. That should be enough to
hold him to the fire. But the minute you make it about people
go, "Huh? He someone." Oh. Oh, no he didn't. He sent nudes. Oh,
well then who cares? You also risk getting sued for calling it.
But that's just me sweeping. I guess common sense is sweeping.
He says I shouldn't reach out to Des. It's not common sense.
It's literally not common sense. I didn't call it. I talked about
the infinite machine right there. And anytime I have used like
a a metaphor for rape and people get mad about it, I am very
very very obvious in saying no, he didn't rape anybody. And obviously
like this is a this is a metaphor. This is like comparing something.
This is talking about a violation of consent. And is not something
I get sued for. And Destiny can try to sue me for calling him
an Destiny, you are an that is like, you know, nothing but net
on that one. That is just true. Destiny for comment. Reaching
out for comment can be helpful sometimes. However, it is not
the ultimate journalistic tool. Especially when we're talking
about a guy with the nickname Epstein. You shouldn't read Oh,
the Epson. He's only going to talk about the Epson thing. Will
he talk about how firsthand comment is not literally the best?
Right. Well, cuz that's just true. Yes. Like literally, you can
go get facts. You can go get third party facts. You can go get
um literally like primary sources that are just the actual events
as they unfold. And those are better things than first party
testimony. Reach out to Destiny for interview on his crimes for
the same reason you shouldn't platform and befriend someone like
Mr. Girl. It doesn't really matter if you speak out against touching
kids and violence if you befriend and platform people who advocate
for such things. You are giving them an opportunity to downplay
and normalize their behavior, maybe even make it look cool. I
am investigating a story. Reaching out to people to get more
information again is common sense. If I didn't do that, I'd be
no better than President Sunday and Becket, who didn't reach
out to Pixie. Sunday proceeded to slander her horribly because
he fundamentally misunderstood the story. Both wounded up. Wait,
did he did he watch the Sunday video? Wait, does he understand
Sunday's point? Hold on. Now he's going to say that, "Oh, well,
Sunday failed to understand failed to take Pixie's consent into
Okay, so you understand the Sunday video. Did he even watch the
Sunday video or did he just get points from Noto Aerodite on
it? Did he just write whatever Natsu told him into his video
or did he actually look anything up himself or watch the video
himself? I would love to know. Getting their videos cited in
her court document. Quote, "The videos include screenshots of
private messages of Pixie discussing the situation with friends
and claims that Pixie took hush." Oh, just so you guys know,
he did get a lot of notes from Notite on his on the president
Sunday part of that video. I hope Nicholas Doro knows that, right?
That Willie got like a whole bunch of notes from Noterite on
the Sunday part of that video. I think I think Willy's talked
about it, so Nick probably knows.
That's definitely I would I definitely want to take I would definitely
want to take notes from the guys that we we call or sorry, the
woman we call apparently the DG Glain Maxwell. You definitely
would want to take notes from her on how to do the Sunday part
of the video, right? What were the notes? Did you see them? I
have no idea. It might have just been watch Kilo's video. I have
no idea. Who told you that then? Lots of people. Don't worry
about it. Only cares about money. Uh, let one of them contest
it and doesn't care about the other victims of the defendant.
All of this is false. That's why it's important to reach out.
You saying that I'm irresponsibly platforming Destiny is ridiculous
because this video I believe Willie has said that he talked to
Natsuer about this. I believe he said that now somewhere. I'm
pretty sure wasn't even out yet. You don't even know how it's
going to end up. You know who's not mad at me? Any of the victims
or Pixie. I've been talking to her side as well and I'm going
to have an on thereord conversation with her and her legal team
in the future. There are people that are so obsessively mad at
Destiny, they'd rather me not do a good job when making a video.
It's very odd to me. I'm going to go through a few other clips
and then start asking Willie some pointed questions, knowing
the commentary community that Wait, I think we defended Willie
on some of the stuff, right? Some of the some of the points in
the Glitch Poachers video. I think me and Quan were watching
this. We defended Willie on this. No, they will never be answered.
Well, it's your lucky day. One, how much and what kind of input
did Destiny have on Willie Mac's video on Destiny? Has Destiny
had input on Willie Mac's other videos? Oh, but that's not the
answer. That's not the question we want answered. The question
we want answered is who had input on Willy's Destiny video? Destiny
has no input on anything I do. Do you think he likes that I'm
dragging out this career defining drama another month? I showed
up on one podcast and people think I'm an
Willie. I thought Willie pulled some stuff up from when we watched
this industry plant. I don't know how to battle this level of
delusion to in the initial video. Were there parts of the conversation
between Destiny and Willie that were left out in an attempt to
hide Destiny's influence on the video? Particularly in regards
to President Sunday and Becket. Destiny never brought up President
Sunday or Becca when we talked. Pixie Side did because President
Sunday slandered her and Becket leaking her document with her
intentions to sue before it was ready. Gave Destiny notice to
delete evidence. This is all in her court papers. I knew about
this beforehand because I reached out to Pixie and she told me.
Crazy how that works. Has Willie Mack ever received any funding
or payment? I think uh I think it would have been nice basically
for Pixie to get a heads up. I maybe I maybe understand some
slight arguments they had about oh we thought Pixie but like
Pixie should have gotten a heads up. Pixie could have Pixie could
have gotten her legal team to do stuff. She could have gotten
things in order a little bit. I I think a lot of people wanted
stuff to get pushed out. I wish I wish I'd been included cuz
I feel like I would have had that opinion but like hey you go
to Pixie and tell her like this is getting published. You have
like a week to make your preparations or something.
From Destiny, Dan Haltman, is it will he sweeping for Destiny
or not? No, I don't think he's sweeping for Destiny. Uh, he just
maliciously lied about me or is like actually just completely
anyone else associated with Omniiberal Studios, that's Destiny's
media company. Not a single dollar. Again, why would he pay me
to make him look bad? These people are so stupid. four since
Nicholas Dioro has given Dan Alman optical advice. But I spoke
to him and I'm like, listen, the problem with you and and Arerite
is you guys knew for months, so you've come to terms with this
and you've engaged with it. That's not what the public wants
to hear a day after they find out. When you start the initial
statement being like, "Guys, rehabilitation is the answer before
anybody gets their licks in, people are going to hate you." And
considering some of the other behind-the-scenes conversations
that the commentary community has had with Dan Salman regarding
his lawfare against Twitch, among other details alluding to collusion,
can Willie Mack speak to the collusion between the commentary
community, Ethan Klein, Destiny, Dan Saltman, and Omniiberal
Studios? I'm guessing this guy I just don't think the commentary
community is involved there. I mean, I think that's like a collection
of interests that happen to be aligned on Idubbbz's bad. He also
thinks a cabal of Jews secretly run the world because that's
the same logic. I've never even spoken to Ethan. I think Nick
talked to Destiny once on a panel. Does this mean I could never
go? I've never even spoken to Ethan. I think Nick.
Okay. All right. I mean, you talked to Destiny once on a I think
he's mostly correct that like it's this is pretty bad panel.
Does this mean I can never go on someone else's podcast or show
again? Because if the person ever gets into a scandal, that means
I'm best friends with them. You're all way too Why does Nick
no longer like you? What did you even do to upset him? Um, it
was the Aerodyite tweet and the debate I had with Aiden over
it, which like basically the public facts that were out that
I'd seen that earlier that day were just apparently incorrect.
And I basically was like, "Oh, these are incorrect. Like whatever.
We can't have this debate." And then there was from there it
went to the me criticizing Willie Mack, I guess, and he got really
mad about it. Then the weird thing was was so here's what I think
happened is basically I I criticized Willy Mack, but I was mostly
just going off the cuff. I was like, "Oh, it seemed like you
probably should be talking about this like pattern of abuse where
he continues to threaten people and then make good on those threats.
And if you cross him, he will threaten and try to humiliate you
in public, right? Like that seems pretty important, right, to
me." And and I think that that was like my general thoughts,
but I I was pretty I didn't communicate well in the in the content
with Willie and but I I hadn't prepared at all, right? And then
I went off after that and Nick reviewed that and Nick like got
super pissed at me and I was like, "Oh, if you want to talk,
we can talk." And he agreed to talk to me. He agreed to smaggle
to talk to me directly about it and then he went back on that
and I'm pretty sure he went back on that because he realized
that Willy's video was complete dog. Willie had totally fumbled
and he didn't want to actually go and have that conversation
because when he originally reviewed the content he thought that
he was like solid. He thought Willy's video was solid and then
after that he realized, oh wait, there's like a thousand really
good criticisms of Willy's video and oh, I actually don't want
to have this conversation.
I'm confused cuz earlier you said you felt bad about not speaking
to him when he asked you. Oh, I felt bad as in like I gave him
for not speaking to me, right? And then I felt like I couldn't
talk to him. But he asked to speak to you. I also reached out
to people for him, right? Yeah. Yeah. I I was asked not to speak
to him about certain things and I was basically like I'm not
going to go have a conversation. I don't So, I don't know how
to trust him cuz he'd had this whole week long see on on Twitter
or whatever and or two week long see that where he was like constantly
complaining and talking and then he continued to do it later.
Um, so I was like I don't know if I could trust him with much
and I'm just not going to I'm not going to bother. I also had
a lot of going on so he did offer a conversation. I said that.
Yeah. Okay. That's that's fine. I aware of him. Oh, okay. Sorry.
Yeah, I'm talking about Nicholas. Yeah, you should probably listen
if you're going to cut in. Too parasocial. Five. How much is
the commentary community people like Nicholas Dioro talked about
avoiding backlash from Destiny's community or being fearful of
Destiny's community or something along those lines? Can Willie
elaborate on that hidden influence of fear within his community?
Look what Sorry. I'm sorry. Uh I'm sure Listen, Kelly, I'm just
really still seething about that comment about me being fat from
earlier. Okay. I'm just I feel like when I say sorry first, there's
no need to be a
Okay. All right. Happened with um Chud Logic and Lauren Southern.
He had Molina coming to him and you should get Willie and Nick
on tonight. I I don't think Nick wants to talk to me ever again.
I think I'm not sure. I actually don't know why. Um because I
don't know what changed between like him agreeing to talk to
me and then him not wanting to talk to me. I actually have no
idea what changed there cuz I never said anything else. I literally
I think Chud messaged me and was like, "Hey, would you agree
to like not uh escalate this? Would you agree to like uh peace?
Well, we'll just make peace. And I was like, "Oh, yeah, that's
fine." And I was the last person who got And then Willie like
me like four more times on Twitter and I still let it all go.
And then Nick was like, "Oh, no, no, no. Um, now I'm not going
to talk to him. I I actually have no idea." Yeah. I I have no
idea. I really don't know. What were you going to talk to Nick
about
about? He had a whole bunch of like really heavy criticisms of
my conversation with Willie. Oh.
Um, so he got really mad about that conversation and I think
he realized that he didn't make good commentary on that and I
was going to ask him about it and then he just didn't want to
talk. I guess
I was a bit confused as to why Nicholas seemed to care that much.
I guess he did seem to care a lot. It was He's close friends
with Willie. He's close friends with Willie. Yeah, but that doesn't
Okay, just cuz you're close friends with someone doesn't mean
you have to react that strongly when somebody Yeah. Well, you
know what? I should be a little more fair to Nick. So after that,
and regardless of me, even though I was saying, "Hey, I'm not
going to fight these guys right now. I want to focus on Destiny
stuff. I'm not going to fight these guys. Yeah, I'll let Willie
Max see on Twitter." A lot of people, a lot of commentary fans
went and talked Nick and uh Willie on Twitter and in their Reddit
and in a bunch of places. And I think they got they felt like
they were under attack. And they might have attributed that to
me. Not that I have pull with any of those people, but um yeah,
they might have attributed that to me. I did call Dioro fat quite
a lot. And I went into like four or five different servers to
do it. Yeah. But like you call a lot of people fast. It's not
a lot. It's like three. Sure. Yep. Yep. Telling him these things
directly. And he was put in a position where he can either eat
and be hated by that community and lose a huge percentage percentage
of his audience to the point where I had to pick up the other
half of the slack and like help him out, right, to keep him afloat
or he could just leak those messages and be justified immediately
and it would start like a huge conflict. and he did I guess he
did the right thing um by loyalty. This guy is completely taking
Nick out of context. Nick is giving the sound advice to not go
forward with the story unless the victim is willing.
Uh James Spinosza, thank you for the 3 months. I can't tell if
that's on Twitch or on Kick. Let me take a quick look and see
if I can figure that out. That was over on Kick. Oh my god, that
is a threemon subscription. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you for
the to go public as well. Is he really saying he disagrees with
that? This YouTuber is bad. But do it for what? Can we I said
I am a video. Can I finish the sentence? Why have me here if
you don't let me like speak
Cuz you almost never comment on the actual content, but I'm supposed
to allow you to speak on other stuff. So you be It's other stuff
as in Nicholas
It's not like I'm talking about [__] I don't know,
the king of Spain. Like what is your problem? Oh, Hassan is bad.
Hassan is bad.
Yeah. What does Hassan have to do with this? Uh, people pay.
Also, if somebody pays, it doesn't matter how relevant you are.
You can just say whatever the [__] you like. Assan
is bad.
Someone pays so that I'm allowed to speak. Is that an option
I'm allowed to like opt into?
Assan is bad. Hold on. Yes, it will be an option in two seconds.
Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. That is a perfect reward, guys. Is
it not? I think that's a perfect reward. Channel points. Uh,
create new. Let Kelly speak. It will be 5,000 points. Okay. Let
her cook.
Let Kelly speak. That's 5,000 points for Let Kelly Speak. Okay.
All right. Let me pay to mute Kelly. Well, you'd have to pay
the actual money to mute Kelly, not just channel points. Assad
is bad. You couldn't afford it. Assad is bad. Assan is bad. Oh,
do you have to whisper it? It's disgusting.
Assad is bad. It's like grotesque ASMR. Yeah. Okay. Kelly, you
wanted to say you're not a body, you're a body shamer, but
Oh, it was like the Okay, the Diorio stuff came after him for
some reason denigrating me as like what was it like? He accused
me of running, which is bad. He accused me of like being so mind.
Why did you mute yourself? Cuz I was saying Hassan is bad so
it didn't interrupt you in a low whisper. Hassan is bad.
unlikely. You want to just do that for No, I did it already.
You can keep going. Oh, okay. Don't let it Don't let it with
you that I'm letting you speak.
Well, if you're speaking over the top of me, are you really letting
me speak? Well, it's not cutting over you at all. It's just a
little thing in the
Still kind of rude though. Feel like you've got like you've got
like you've got like 5 seconds to go on your stupid body shaming
rant before I just hit play. I was just giving the background.
I'm so done. I'm so done. I was just giving the background as
to why I was being a bit obnoxious and calling the Oreo fat everywhere.
It's because he had said like
given me as an example of someone that is like so mind and then
Turkey Tom was like what does this mean? And then he kept going
on for some reason. Okay, that was it. Cool. All right. Willing
to go public as well. Is he really saying he disagrees with that?
This YouTuber is bad faith or has an IQ in the single digits?
This fanfiction is out of Ain't no way Willie makes that criticism.
That's crazy. Troll. I've never had a conversation about being
afraid of Destiny. Destiny doesn't even have a million subscribers.
I talk about bigger, more combative people all the time. Realistically,
what? Wait. Okay. Is he pretending he doesn't understand? Okay.
Nicholas is like clearly a more popular person than Willie. And
Nicholas was the guy who was saying, "Yeah, I I don't want to
go anywhere near this guy unless we actually unless we're ready
to kill him, right? I think that's totally disingenuous to say,
"No, no, no. I have no no problems." I think Oh, man. It's hard
to say for sure. I feel like Willy wouldn't be making these videos
if there wasn't a whole group of people there. Right. I And I
I'm not even like criticizing him. It's just like to pretend
that like Destiny or DJ hadn't like totally obliterated people's
reputations online before. That's That's crazy. Maybe. But hold
on. I don't know. Maybe he totally steps outside of like the
normal commentary line to criticize people that they're aligned
with or
What is there to be scared of? We make YouTube videos. It's not
that serious. It's time that we get an understanding of just
how much coordination, fear, and middle school shenanigans go
into making it seem like someone like Willie Mac is a journalist.
Like Destiny is a real political Wait, I would just ask Willie
Mack. You I think Willy Mack said it. It's somewhere. I'm pretty
sure he got input from not soite on his video. I'm almost positive.
Fund it like Dioro is a media expert. They're not. Other people
call me a journalist because I aim for the incredibly low bar
of reaching out, which you don't even want me to do. Destiny
is a political pundant. What What do you think a political pundant
is? All it means is someone who talks about politics with authority.
And I've never heard anyone refer to Nick as a media expert.
I don't even know what a media expert means. If Willie Mack doesn't
answer these questions, and I'm betting he won't, then I would
advise everyone to disregard his coverage of Destiny. He is too
close to him to Too bad. That wasn't a Wasn't a very good video.
Wasn't very good set of questions. be reliable.
Well, there you go. I answered them. You absolute schizophrenic.
This is all unhinged. It's like when JTOK was asking me why I
didn't cover cherry in my video. I don't think you worked very
hard on this video and like for example, you know, you didn't
really include much of the cherry stuff which is required which
is what really struck this whole situation up when I point out
that I much of the cherry stuff as in like the zooming in to
me. I don't know. But I think I think that was me talking through
my criticisms and I think I still have those criticisms is that
you missed the pattern of behavior, the harassment, the clear
like I'm threatening you if you keep coming after me. I'm going
to keep like releasing information about you. But I I think in
that moment I said, "Hey, um I didn't watch the whole video.
Like I didn't watch his whole video." So I was just coming in
off the cuff because Kelly was arguing with him and like this
seemed like a reasonable criticism to me and then he basically
got super assad about it. By the way, he repeatedly uh says that
that conversation like I made no good points there. He totally
just conceded to me that it would have been a much better video.
It could have been a much better video if you just asked Estie
for evidence, right? Why even include this session uh section?
Because he's ass mad. He's giga ass. He's giga ass mad. Okay.
Booty bother
to reveal info. What was that? What destiny was Tushy Touch?
He kept talking about him. I'm asking question. Sure, sure, sure.
Destiny like continuously threatens people who like talk [__]
about him. Like he continuously threatens people who are talking
about him, who are basically saying that he's like a piece of
He will continuously threaten those people. He he threatened
threatened me. He released messages about Pixie. He released
message about Cherry. He's done like all these things. And I
think that pattern of behavior when you go into that and when
you say like, "Hey, is this guy telling the truth or is he maliciously
lying to like spin narratives?" You can you can actually prove
this out. And Willie Mack is the person who's had the connection
to prove this out. All he has to do is ask for Destiny's evidence,
right? When when Destiny sent those albums, is that are those
albums actually a pretext for doxing and calling for the death
of Quean? That that's the question Willie Mack should be asking,
but he is too assigned, booty bothered, tushy touched about Quean
to actually do an effective job, right? Like he he he can't see
the vision. He's just like a mouth breathing. So it is what it
is. You did include the cherry stuff. He says I missed important.
I don't even think so. It doesn't even matter who you're saying
those things about, right? Like some things just seem bad enough
by themselves, I guess, to like incite violence, right? I don't
know what William's opinion was on like the Trump.
Sure. I don't know what the what are we saying when it comes
to like inciting violence, like doxing you guys and saying he
wants you dead.
Isn't that just universally bad? Like I don't Why does it have
to be like
Yeah. It's just all part of the same pattern of behavior over
time of him like menacing and threatening people, right? Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. No, I'm just I'm just saying there are certain things
where I feel like your biases shouldn't really affect your objectivity,
but maybe they still do. I don't I don't know. Well, they clearly
still do. Although I mean I think he said it was bad, but no,
but I think like missing the Kelly Gene, missing being able to
say, "Hey, what proof do you have for these allegations you're
making, just missing being able to ask that question, I think
that's like really critical to these videos, like missing missing
certain parts. This video is way better." I just think it's um
it's very funny how he fails some things that are just very obvious
and his swings at me are just embarrassing. Uh if you know that
Destiny as bad as he is, no one is talking about it. When are
you making a hit piece? Where am I publishing the hit piece,
David Forest? I don't have a platform for that. Yeah. Okay. Which
is what really struck this whole situation up. When I point out
that I did include the Cherry stuff, he says I missed important
tweets. So, I asked them to link me them. Uh I I said it was
important tweets and Cherry had deleted a bunch of tweets. Unfortunately,
those tweets did exist and they were archived in some places,
right? But the real thing I thought I was talking about was mostly
the logs, the DG logs. And I think he said, "I'm never going
to that chat." But I I think that's left out of this. Anyway,
um the sad thing is is he pulls this from me being like trying
to be genuine. Be like, "Hey, Willie, I I actually should just
find it. Hold on. Give me a second. I think I got linked to time
stamp for this. I should just pull it up because I was trying
to be genuine and be like, "Hey, I express myself badly. If you
ever wanted to talk about it, we could be we could be fine."
But clearly that's never the route you should take, right? Me
just hopping on a stream and letting it fly and just being like
like I I didn't like prepare that in any way. And like I said,
I hadn't even watched the full video yet. I done my like clickth
through like my little quick skimming and my um my skimming and
then I'd gotten linked stuff like obviously Kelly I knew was
annoyed and then obviously um Yo Gay I've relieved you of the
burden of typing in chat for the rest of the night. Oh, sorry.
I just got a text. Um, what did he even say? Obviously, I just
lost where I was. I got a text. My bad. I got a text from one
of my friends. I I lost my total train of thought here. How do
I go back and find where I was? I'm so sorry. Oh, yeah. No, sorry.
Kelly was annoyed. I just done my clickth through. And then um
somebody had been like, "Hey, you didn't cover very much of the
cherry stuff either." And like I watched the cherry section.
I'm like, "Oh, it's missing all of the harassment." And so, yeah,
I just started building from there. I watched like a decent amount
of it. You're Yeah. So even in the sorry in the exact section
that he's pulling from
right sorry in this like exact VOD that he's pulling from I talk
about what's missing saying how you didn't do research I'm saying
I'd watched enough to make the criticism and I was like I thought
I was like hey you missed like really important like the cherry
harassment stuff is really important to be in a Desty video you
don't seem to have included much of the stuff after like the
initial allegations here right and it's like if he says okay
I just want to include like only that stuff it's like I mean
why it's Like could you imagine going to the making a video on
Harvey Weinstein and then just like actually including like Courtney
Love's allegation or something and talking about Courtney Love
and making it like about Harvey Weinstein months after he'd been
found like guilty of um of like his actual crimes, but you just
make it about like some allegation where like a crazy girl was
accusing him of, you know, you don't want to go to his house
or whatever. Like it's like it's like so out of place. It doesn't
make sense to make that video given the timing. Right. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah, the the criticism is basically that there was a bunch
of other information that was out there and the video had like
it could have been an amazing video, right? Like literally he
had the key. The the key is, hey, this guy like maliciously malign
people, maliciously lies about people. He maliciously lied about
Pixie, maliciously lied about Cherry, maliciously lies about
these people. Sorry, I don't know, maybe not maliciously lied,
maliciously published information about Cherry, like public or
private information. Uh because Cherry was going to the police
about him, right? And he does these things like quite often.
and you just got an interview where you had him maliciously lying
about Kelly and you could have proven that by asking him for
evidence of it and you didn't. You had like the golden ticket
to making the right video, the the best video, but you didn't
know that you should have been talking about the pattern of behavior.
So, it's just it's a little crazy to me that like he had all
the pieces there and he totally failed, totally fell apart. But
yeah, I I hadn't watched his whole video. I'd watched the videos
I gave criticism on, right? Cuz somebody was like, "Oh, he's
like talking to Kelly right now." And and like Kelly wasn't Kelly's
Kelly's what? Kelly wasn't convincing him. Okay, I totally went
in there and convinced him. I was like, "Hey, if you'd asked
about this stuff, you actually like you'd actually like get a
perfect perfect video out of this. It just doesn't make sense."
Anyway, so I got to ask why was I not This is in the same VOD.
This is like 2 minutes after the he grabbed. So, it's just like
I don't know if he basically asked for somebody to just prove
the things. Also, this is like way after and this is I'm talking
about it. I literally describe my actual criticisms in here,
but he doesn't want to he doesn't want to address the actual
criticisms, right? From the from the clip he cites, he doesn't
want to address the actual criticisms. He's just going to totally
totally misrepresent what my criticisms are of the video.
When I point out that I did include the cherry, he says I missed
important tweets. So, I asked him to link me them. She tells
you explicitly apparently. Why say that? She didn't tell me explicitly.
What I've posted publicly is all I would have to contribute.
So, she's basically saying, "Go, like, if there's anything you
want from me, I will post it publicly." And she had her tweets.
All right. Link me her tweet right now. That's the new thing.
With all the information. I don't know if there's like an Link
me tweet with all of the information. By the way, this is just
a completely paradigm to engage in. I should have just asked,
"Wait, don't you do like research to try to be informed on your
videos?" That's all I actually should have asked, right? Don't
you like actually do research? Aren't Isn't it your job like
to to make videos that are well informed? Isn't that basically
all I should have had to ask?
It shouldn't be like
imagine being that Imagine being that like cuddled. Where's the
tweet with all of the information on this? [__] you
might have to click a link or two. Okay, which everybody said
like literally you Google this and it pops up on like DG Snark
or whatever drama YouTube drama like all of these things pop
up everywhere. Archival tweet for this, but there were tweets
about it, right? Okay.
Tweet can he couldn't link me a tweet because I didn't miss anything.
He then says I should have reached out to him about Cherry. There
are a ton of people around Cherry who could. This was uh I shouldn't
have said this specifically. I was like, "Oh, you could have
messaged me about this." That was like I meant to I meant as
in like you could have reached out to somebody you knew. And
then this is why I felt bad about not doing an interview with
him. But you are delusional. They're giving you information.
Me specifically. I was like
why would I go to a secondhand source about Cher's allegations?
That's literally how Sunday screwed up his video. But then I
realized Jark only had this opinion. Wait, a secondhand source?
No, no, no. Like I could have given you the source material at
that point. I would have actually cared enough to give you the
source material at that point. That's um that's my argument there,
right? Like I would have cared about this enough to give you
the source material. I wouldn't have given you my side of the
story. I would have given you the source material for this, which
obviously the source material here is Destiny posting um conversations
with Cherry in his chat. Destiny posting conversations and maligning
Pixie. Destiny trying to maliciously lie about Kelly. Destiny
trying to maliciously lie about me. All of these things, right?
It's all of it's this is the pattern of behavior. This is what
it's about. But it wouldn't have been like just my opinion. I
wouldn't have just given him my opinion obviously opinion because
he didn't watch my video. I didn't like prepare that in any way.
Um I'm trying to focus on the video and like I said, I haven't
even watched the full video yet. I did my like clickthrough like
my little quick skimming. Fury then crashed out against JTO after
this with these insane tweets. I think JTO, Destiny, and every
other person in my life. Okay, see you. Kelly is trying to get
me to myself. I think when JT told me I'm Dr. K and he promises
to be my friend for 2 years no matter what because he often blocks
me if I disagree with him or don't do what he wants me to do.
He means for me to depend on him so I eventually myself like
Reckful did. Wow. J, you seem like you're doing great work over
there.
Great work. True. That was uh this is 100% how this went down.
Yep.
Wow. Jtock, you seem like you're doing great work over there.
Reality is this isn't a careerending job. Gets threats in my
DMs and ignored. Uh you're sending me Discord logs trying to
get me to litigate Discord drama instead of actually focusing
on the content. Kelly, yes, I didn't like that. Obviously, I
didn't like that. Obviously, I don't want to litigate Discord
drama while I'm covering the Willy Mac video. I think that's
probably pretty obvious. I thought that should be obvious, but
apparently wasn't obvious. So, I don't want to do that. I don't
want to talk about Discord drama. Is Okay, perfect. Hold on.
I'll rejoin this. If she wants to rejoin and yell at me, it's
fine. But it is defining. Every time his name comes up, people
will bring up this situation. And they are correct in doing so.
You can't demand accountability of people where week after week
he demands it of all these Republicans. But then in your own
personal life, you're just excusing your actions with implied
consent, which is just an excuse to share nudes of other people.
It's caused real harm to Pixie that he has in the past acknowledged.
So I want to wrap up with do I think Destiny has a pattern of
abuse. Holy assaulted a woman on stream, apologized, and years
later slandered Anna on stream while she doesn't describe it
as abuse, but I still think it's pretty bad. Dan, Destiny's co-host,
advocated for his wife to leave him. I'll say this also, I think
Steven was a really husband to Molina. Okay, I'm coming out here
saying it right now. I don't think Steve would deny it either,
but it's not good the way that he was. Like, I talked with Molina
a lot of times and she was crying and miserable and everything
else. And Steve would say, "What do you want me to say? I'm a
selfish mother. Um, that's why I'm in the relationship that I'm
in. He was like, you know, what should I do? Should I leave?
And I'll tell you this, I never was like, um, I was never like,
no, you should stay and make things out. I told her multiple
times like, listen, if you feel like this is abusive relationship,
get the out of there. So, I don't think I'm sold on it being
a pattern of abuse because they're different things. We really
don't know the details with Molina. But if other people think
this all proves a pattern, I'm not going to argue with them.
The clear pattern to me is that Wait, did we do we get Hold on.
Do we do we not get the doxing and death threats? No. We get
the doxing and death threats at all. Feels like that would be
a pretty critical part of the pattern, but I you know I don't
know. Maybe maybe that's just me being obsessed. Maybe that's
me trying to be the main character. I thought Destiny's pattern
of abuse might include him attempting to dox me and doing multiple
death threads. That Destiny is always sharing nudes. Whether
it's threatening Anna with hers or sharing pixies, Stacas, Molina's
cherries. Anna claims that she received other girls nudes that
she didn't know. Was this also without consent? We'll probably
never find out. He has to apologize at some point, hopefully
when the trial is over. It's like Sneo calling out people for
being heartless while he says hit. Sorry, Max. You're telling
me right at the end here I missed the the death threats. That's
why it either go but it's not after the way that he was like
I talked to Molina a lot of times and she was crying and miserable
and everything else and he would say, "What do you want me to
say? I'm a selfish mother." Um that's why I'm in the relationship
with that man who was like you know what should I do? Should
I leave? And I'll tell you this. I never was like um I was never
like no you should say and make things out. I told her multiple
times like listen if you feel like this abusive relationship
gets us out of there. So I don't think I'm sold out of it being
a pattern of abuse because there are different things. We really
don't know the details of the other people think this all proves
a pattern. I'm not going to argue with them. The clear pattern
to me is that Destiny is always sharing nudes. Whether it's blue
tea or threatening Anna with hers or what? He's always
nudes. What? Oh boy. Yikes. Where's the threats here at the end?
Maximus. Oh no. I don't I know that he mentioned the the threats
earlier. Obviously we knew about the threats because of him.
I'm just saying it's a part of the pattern but it's I don't know.
Well, whatever.
sharing pixies, Stacia, Molina, Cherries, Anna claims that she
received other girls nudes that she didn't know. Was this also
without consent? We'll probably never find out. He has to apologize
at some point, hopefully when the trial is over. It's like Sneo
calling out people for being heartless while he says Hitler did
nothing wrong or him calling Only Fans girls harab and hanging
out with them all the time. It may seem like an extreme example,
but Destiny has victims and Sneo doesn't. Contemplate that. As
far as people just watching Destiny for his politics, I think
that's fine. Turns out there's a lot of hypocrites in the political
space. At the end of the day, I'm not here to be anyone's friend
or enemy. I'm here to get a laugh, shed light on a story, and
do a good job. So, subscribe to the channel and be sure to check
out Aura. Wow. Crazy. All right. Okay. I Yeah, I feel like uh
I feel like I've kind of highlighted my issues with this. The
malicious lying about me is just weird. Very weird. And then
trying to use trying to use those cherry tweets to like get a
dunk on me also seems really weird. Um if you're concerned about
like Destiny's victims in any way. I mean, I guess no, hold on.
Hold on. He did say he's not concerned about the victims at all.
So maybe I just feel bad about that. Seems odd, but hey, whatever.
Oh, he played the audio, too. Yeah. I don't know. I Hey, maybe
it's a little interesting that he didn't play the other audio
of Destiny walking up um with the gay guy, right? Yeah.
Huh. Yeah. Very strange. The audio was like a few seconds of
nothing. I think pretty much everybody's been like, "Yeah, you
don't play this on stream cuz it's um it's just very weird to
do, right?" Take the win. What do you mean take the win? What's
the win here, Kingler? I just think that I just think it's funny
that he could up his own video because he hates Queen to me so
much that he can't focus on that and like draw the obvious like
obvious um line between the threats to those women and the threats
to him and uh to Queen and I. But you know, it is what it is.
Oh, are Zena and Darius fighting right now? Is that what we're
covering now? You think Willie would go much softer than he did?
Um no. I I knew he had to do this roughly. I knew he had to make
like a video that was aggressive on Destiny. He's aligned with
Nicholas and Nicholas is Nicholas needs Destiny not to get back
up, right? Like I think I think they don't want um for all the
reasons that Nicholas gave to President Sunday. I think Nicholas
wants Destiny kind of, you know, done away with too. Maybe that's
just a little too Maybe that's how I read the tea leaves. Don't
go Darius and Zena on Twitch TV. Okay,
that's basics. Thank you for the 10 gifted. Let's go. I looks
like I didn't refresh my from before, which is unfortunate.
But thank you. Thank you. Thank you for the 10. Let's go. Let's
go. Let's go. I think that gives me Is that going to give me
more time on the stream? That would be more time in the stream.
Yes. Another hour on the stream. God damn. Okay. I've got some
other stuff to do, but I was going to see if other people were
coming around. Also, we've got the Kelly whatever. Got the Kelly
thing. When is the panel? Well, I thought Kelly I thought Kelly
and Lav and Anna were going to be a part of the panel, but we
just didn't get people coming in cuz we're in a different discord
and stuff, so people don't even know what's going on, unfortunately.
Let's do the Kelly thing. I think Kelly had to go to sleep anyway,
so you had some stuff in her Discord. What the [__]
on about? We just had Kimmy in. I told you what her times for
like needing Sorry, I was talking about the title. I thought
I was talking about the title of the video. I thought it was
going to be panel on the video. Okay, but like you said you didn't
want to speak. I just misunderstood. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. No, I
just misunderstood. So, I put panel in the title, but I I didn't
know if we're going to do that or not. Yeah, you need to communicate
things cuz I did everything that you told me to. I just mis I
just should have updated the title. I think I took it out of
the title on some other platforms, but yeah, I just I failed
to update the title. Did you not make it sound like my fault?
I don't No, that's not Kelly's fault. I don't know if I tried
to make it sound like your fault, but it is what it is. Guys,
we're going to go ahead and leave Twitch, though. Okay, we're
going to go over to kick only. kick only for the rest of the
night. Okay, nobody wants to join stream anymore. What happened?
Um, who knows? I We're just in a different We're in a totally
different discord right now because um Kelly can't be in my Discord.
So, hey, why is people don't even know to join stream over here.
People don't even know that we're at all. And you can invite
more people. You could do that. That would be us in that thing.
Okay, you're the one that changed
Okay. I'm just telling you nobody knew her in that channel. Yeah,
because you wanted to hide from Lav. You're creating the problems.
I Yeah, I was like, why did you invite Lab to the server? True.
Then I said to come relevant to this video.
And then I didn't want I didn't want four people and annoying.
Okay.
Okay. You like make things woman. It's so Why? Why? Why? Okay.
I you can say that I'm gonna like do you want me to start pointing
out things that other people that wouldn't be public like lab
being the discord? You want point me me to start pointing things
out that aren't public? You want me to start leaking and [__]
Uh yeah. I feel like it's kind of like leaking to try to win
the argument. And if you want to do that, we can do that. I feel
like that would not be to win what argument. You said you made
some comments about lab. So I pointed those things out because
it was relevant to what you were winging about. Sorry. What am
I leaking here? Nothing. Kelly, you're perfect. We're going to
watch this but she was underage.
End up 15 people including people like Crow in the beginning
of the video.
Very clear at the start that I don't think he's a if she's 17
I don't think he's the age of consent in the UK is 16. Okay.
If you [__] a 16 17 year old I don't really think
you're a I just think you're a freak and very reckless and irresponsible
whatever. But this is about like that's theation kind of the
interesting Destiny's a freak and reckless. I got it. Equification.
It's about creating like video content and them sending and distributing.
That's that's a problem. It's a like separate problem, right?
Um but I think that it seemed like at certain points like you
sounded like you were making the case that she was underage or
that she was 17. I think that's why he like refused commentary,
bro. Mhm. Well, a case is being made that he doesn't know her
identity and we don't either. That's the case I'm making. Not
that she is 17. More so that we don't know if she's 17, 18, or
19 at this point. We don't know. And to
and to then like speak to someone in that kind of a context when
you're not sure of their identity is irresponsible, right? So,
I think he then treats your claim, which I think is actually
very fair and reasonable. It's our tag as well that we just had.
I think he takes that sort of ambiguity and sort of fact that
there wasn't such strong ev there isn't strong evidence for it.
I think he takes some of that ambiguity and then like frames
it as the claim is definitively disproven. He says at the end
of that segment, I don't have
I don't think that there's a conflation going on between your
moderate claim and the strong claim. He treats your claim like
a strong claim. And then yeah, I think I don't have strong evidence
for her being 17, but he doesn't have strong evidence for her
being 19. Nobody has strong evidence for her age. So the default
being that she's telling the truth. I'm sorry it's too much evidence.
If you want to say what you want to say, go ahead. Okay. That
as there is I have for her being 17. I believe I literally said
I don't want to say. So right. The point is nobody knows. Therefore
to engage in that way is reckless. So you say that you don't
want evidence. We're just talking about any evidence is like
sort of destiny sort of messages.
Nope. I won't do it because you're a woman. You will not stop.
You will literally not stop arguing. So I and I've pointed this
out multiple times and then every time I point it out, you refuse
to stop arguing and actually continue on with the content. So
I literally can only not speak. Yeah. I'm literally completely
by Kelly into like actually ignoring having interesting conversations
because if I ever want to go back to the content at any point,
I'll never be able to do that because she will never ever give
up on the other argument. So I just have to basically ignore
having any of bring those up or bring up any other side thing
cuz Kelly will Kelly will constantly constantly sideline into
a different thing.
It's not a different thing. You just made a comment in your chat.
All those messages where he's but he's micious and then there's
just circumstantial stuff. But she was on Twitter instead of
the verified platform. So there's not really anything particularly
compelling. Yeah. He also tries to bring up Tinder which is stupid
cuz anyone that's used Tinder knows that like there is no like
default verification for age on that thing. It's just not true.
I don't know why he brought that up as an example. If she'd been
on Only Fans, that would have been legitimate because they do
verify. He literally just say, "Here's the problem is that uh
Willie asked a question that let let Destiny slip through the
cracks a little bit cuz he asked, "Is there is there any like,
you know, any anything where you like to get an account, you
need to like verify your age?" Obviously, meaning like you have
to, you know, show your ID to prove that you're age. But Destiny
goes, uh, yeah, on Tinder, you have to say that you are above
18. It's like, yeah, but there's no verification. talking. He's
talking about verification, not in terms of like she claims to
be 18. We all know she Wait, at what point does this start to
go into fighting? Is Riyle still here? Ryle was like, "Oh, this
gets into like fighting and like starts yelling at Kelly." Does
that happen? Claims to be 18. Um or and then obviously had a
birthday, whatever. Um but Destiny's able to say, cuz it's an
honest representation to the word of the question, obviously
to the spirit. It's um yeah, he kind of slips out of that. I'll
just point out that Kelly tries to bring up an old argument here.
I cleverly sidestep and just hit the play button. I think he
asked explicitly for D or something like digital identity. Does
he have something? Sorry, what was the old argument I was making
that impatient?
I mean, I just have to argue trying to prove he's a because I
just don't believe that's likely to be true. So, like why would
I try and make that argument? That's the first thing I say is
like I don't think he's a and I don't think anybody does. Yeah.
No, we saw it. No, we all we all that. Yeah. And then he says,
"So, wait, does think that she was implying he was a Well, actually,
she sounds like one here. And I'm like, where where in this conversation
does it make me think that I sound like I think he's a I'm like
baffled. But So, who brought it up first? Did you bring it up
or did Willie ask you about that? The um I didn't record our
conversation. It was quite long. Like, we spoke for probably
about an hour and I think he only used like what 10 minutes or
most of the entire conversation. So, I honestly don't remember.
The only other time I heard of the allegations of Rose being
potentially underage is when I interviewed Kelly G. And then
it goes into like a you know Oh my god. Okay.
Wasn't me that uh was circulating on her age at first. That comes
from Sol.
Wait, I thought there was that the source for that is Solo completely.
Yeah. Yeah. I mean, everybody was aware of this as an allegation.
Uh the fact that I was the first to bring up to him just means
maybe I was putting in more effort than other people were. But
I don't I'm surprised he doesn't solo's messages on the Kiwi
Farms thread. To be honest, that seems a little uh I think also
the problem is is like it is fair that you don't platform an
allegation that he is a I get where you're coming from on that.
But I do think since Destiny has stated he didn't know the age,
that is worth platforming. But Willie didn't do that, did he?
Well, I think here's the thing. When Destiny says he doesn't
know the age, it's like, what do you mean you don't know the
age? She told you her age. But I think what he's saying there
is like he's not certain of her age. Yeah. I mean, can we all
agree that I think that that's just not adequate? When you're
like exchanging nude videos online, somebody says they're 18.
That's like good enough. It's not good enough. Probably not.
Not for a 35year-old content creator who's like online to know
about these things. It's just an unverified platform like that
probably is not sufficient. And then you're sending them videos
that you haven't even okay with other people as well. Yeah, if
you're giving the uh just on the point of like verifying someone
else's age, I don't know if by default we usually expect people
to like ask. Kelly is not DMing me at all right now. You guys
are just speculating for no reason. Why would you say that? I
don't like Destiny. Sounds like I am. Literally just put in chat,
Kelly going ham in Jay's DMs right now. I was responding to that.
I I think that obviously like everything around it has been reckless
and it might be that she's, you know, under when we first started.
you don't necessarily even need to do that, right? But for him,
his like the bar of like being responsible should be higher,
right? You can't just take someone at their word for especially
if they're saying they're like 18 specifically. That is like
you should obviously be more skeptical. In the UK, I think if
you look under 25, your ID for alcohol, you're still on Twitch.
Oh, we are still on Twitch. Oh [__] We shouldn't
still be on Twitch, should we? My bad. My bad, guys. We're going
to end on Twitch. We're going to go over to kick.com/jok. All
right.
kick.com/jst. Boom. There it is. Right there. There it is. JST.
Okay. On kick. Go over there. I'm going to leave this up for
a long Oh, wait, wait, wait. No, no, no, no. Pin for longer.
Unpin after 90 minutes. Sure. Oh god. Oh god. Oh god. All right,
guys. I'm going to end on Twitch. We're going to go over to kick
only. Goodbye. Well, actually Twitter, too, but mostly kick only.
Okay. Goodbye. Goodbye. Goodbye. Goodbye. I definitely just accidentally
ended the kick stream. Whoops. Hold on. We might have we might
f for two seconds on kick. Whoops. How long was that out for?
My bad. I should be back on kick, I think. Whoops. Whoops. Whoops.
Whoops. Whoops. That's definitely going to with the viewership,
too. This it's like not going to reconnect viewers who don't
have like the tab open right now. I'm going to lose like 300
viewers from that. [__] [__] Anyway,
we're we're good. We're good. Yeah. So, like, but this guy is
like, "Oh, 18. Yeah, that's fine." No, it's not fine. No, no,
no. The VOD will be fine. The VOD will be totally fine. I just
don't know. I don't know if anything else will be fine. Be more.
Here's Lauren Southern son's name. Here's a video of the three
people I've been with last. Okay, I Okay, here's the thing. Ideally,
it'd be a lot better, right? But in terms of like if somebody's
asking for the age, they are checking to see how old the person
is. And I don't know if we can like create expectations. I don't
I might have I might have restarted it quick enough that we didn't
lose anybody. It might not have broken the connections. Thank
god. The bar is actually somebody's like a picture of somebody's
we made It's by his standard. He doesn't know. He by his standard
that wasn't. No, no. I I don't know if I like by his standard
argument. Go on. Okay. Well, I can criticize him by his standards,
right? People for not like asking for like ID if he wasn't she
was of age and she had he had already sent her videos. Then meaning
he isn't sure if he sent someone underage videos, then yeah,
I feel fine criticizing for that. The thing is also the law doesn't
care because the onus and the responsibility is on you. If you
do something like significant with someone that's underage, them
lying is not in your defense.
Kelly's screaming internally. What are you screaming about, Kelly?
What do you think? I don't know. What are you screaming about?
Right. So, I have to explain my messages, but you don't. What?
So, when you write something in chat saying, "I don't want to
bring this up cuz it'll cause us an argument." You don't have
to explain that. You don't need to explain my screaming internally.
No. If you don't want to talk about it, that's fine. Okay. She
doesn't want to talk about it. Work. The responsibility is always
discretion. Well, I think I haven't I haven't done criminal for
a
Well, I haven't done criminal for a while, but I do remember
if it's like there's different offenses for different age brackets.
And for the age bracket that's just low age of consent, you can
get that there is a defense for mistake of age or like deceit
of age. But obviously like for like 12 to 11, that doesn't work.
It's only for the one that's just on the borderline. But that's
like from like you just explained it. It's an asymmetrical relationships
with chat. What? What are we talking about? What? What? Griffith
code provision that I'm familiar with. I don't know if that applies
in the UK, but ignoring the law though and talking about it like
morally, I don't think that we generally have the expectation.
I don't think it's reasonable to have the expectation that you
know people should be asking for like an ID or a photo of somebody's
ID um before like online. You're talking about flirting videos.
You shouldn't do it. I think you shouldn't do it on these unverified
platforms at all. You just shouldn't do it unless significant
context clues. This person's like a doctor or something. I don't
know. I think like this is probably a situation where he should
have asked more like realistically, but I don't know. I don't
know if I I guess there could be statutory penalties. I don't
know how old this person was. I wonder if there's precedent for
this like basically a 17-year-old sending videos across, you
know, across the US to somebody they're representing themselves
to 18 as 18 to like would that person be charged? I have something
obvious that they already an adult. Yeah. And also there's multiple
issues with this, right? If she was under 18, that is receiving
a child born. And if he's sending videos that he didn't have
the consent to share, that is an additional issue. Okay. So,
it's not just like But that's a different issue, right? Well,
I'm just saying you're saying it's not to with someone you shouldn't
have to see their ID, but that's not what we were talking about.
No one cares about someone just although like probably you should
have more responsibility when you're as Yeah. 349 viewers now
because of the reset. God damn it. That sucks so badly. Old as
he is. I think we do have like higher to someone when they're
in their 30s.
That's so annoying on the refresh with randoms that he's never
met and sending their tapes and receiving tapes, especially without
cons. Literally, everybody would have had to reconnect. No, it's
like picking back up, but everybody would have had to reconnect.
So, that's annoying. But that's the thing we we're now trying
to bundle it into everything whereas I'm just focusing on the
the verification of the age. That's all that I'm talking about
currently. He should have simply stopped speaking to this person.
Obviously,
yeah, this conversation sucks. Who? Who? Why? Why was I told
to do this? I was told like and Kelly get in a fight, but I literally
haven't heard a fight and this is just them like calmly speaking
through this. I was told this would be like funny fighting content.
Where's the funny go? I'm sure what it does. We do fight more.
You trying to stick to the like the every person and what they
should do if they were in the situation like I'm talking as like
a rule in verifying somebody's age. Cool. Cool. So, wow. Destiny
could have had somebody else. Cool. But I'm not talking about
Destiny. I'm talking about the general principle or the general
rule that we told 60 seconds where I was going to make my point,
right, that you interrupted to remain. So, the rule we would
hopefully have escalations, right? Flirting or basic DMs, right?
Asking is totally fine. We wouldn't ask as a rule that you get
a DM with a ID before you start flirting with somebody. You probably
ask for the age and then you engage in the flirting. And then
maybe as things escalate where you're exchanging nudes and things
like that, then especially as someone who has access to multiple
people or a creator who engages in these quote unquote multiple
dynamics, maybe then we would say, okay, if you're going to exchange
photos or videos, we would say as a rule, you should have an
ID or have some additional I would even substitute for the ID
something like a face shop or a picture where you can infer,
okay, god, it doesn't look like they're under 17 or under 18
or you have a verified platform, right? I would substitute the
ID for many things in this scenario, but he doesn't have any
of that. Verified. What kind of verified platform though? Only
fans unless they're like an only fans creator. All right. It's
a perfect example. You can verify yourself properly on Tinder,
but you have to opt into that. There's like different verification
options. And one of them is Well, and I don't even think Destiny's
like argument was that he found her on Tinder. It was that she
told him she used Tinder, right?
Like I don't think his argument was like, "Oh, I know what her
verification status is on Twitter or on Tinder." It was like
she used Tinder. She talked about using Tinder to like find people
for to sell nudes to or some
I think that just verifies that your face is real, right? No,
there is two different types of verification, but you have to
opt into it specifically.
Um, but there's also other things you can look for
on Facebook. I don't think I'm muted. I think I just talked right
there. Are you sure? They're quite specific with what you can
put on Facebook with your names and stuff. And then you can look
at like people's classmates and like when they went to school
and like figure out from those years and these things like well
I'm just giving you examples of what you can do to like check
that someone is within the age range that they're claiming to
be. You're worried that ID asking for an ID is a tough ask when
I think it's weird to I I don't think it's fair to hyperfocus
on the ID. That would be perfect but there are other things that
would give you that ability. Yes. Their friends who they know
where they've lived like their family and these these are all
like indicators of like where they are in life. Do they still
live with their parents? like these are things that you should
just check and if you're not sure and you can't find enough information
on a person then probably don't with them like I don't know.
Yeah. I mean sure in terms of best practice I agree with you.
I'm thinking about what I'm going to morally condemn somebody
for. I don't think it's going to be condemnatory if somebody
doesn't go onto somebody's like personal Facebook account and
tries to see what year their friends were born. No, we're just
giving you the stream shouldn't be down. You guys should just
be able to refresh and the stream will pop back up. But it's
going to kick you out if you had a VPN or anything. God damn
it. That's so annoying that everybody got knocked out. God damn
it. That's so annoying. Oh well. Oh well. Thank you. Kick w kick.
Give you a list of examples. No, I know. But here's the thing.
To verify and be certain that somebody is of a certain age. That's
going to be quite a substantial reveal of somebody's personal
information, right? And I can understand why people wouldn't
want to give that out. And so I I don't think I'd be able to
like morally condemn somebody for it because it's just not going
to be what you think. Hang on. Hang on. Hang on. Let me This
is pretty easy to just say. So there's something like that you're
supposed to do when it comes to these type of situation. It's
called due diligence, right? If you can demonstrate that you've
done due diligence to avoid like committing a crime like these
would be, right? Then people are going to look at you differently.
And if you're not making any of these steps, like I know that's
not good enough. That's simply not due diligence. Yeah. Well,
how about you're hiding into the word due in due diligence rather
than what the 12 years old on the other end using Chad GBT. He
would have there would be nothing different about the situation,
but you would say you wouldn't condemn him. the photos you'd
be able to tell Royal if it's a hopefully pick gets like really
I don't know I think there's like something about autoreonnecting
um browsers that it's like trying to block bots or something
so they get really it like it basically if you get disconnected
it doesn't auto reconnect you ever have to like manually fiddle
with it to get it reconnected to the streamy kind of annoying
person using other photos the person could be using other photos
but you're saying there was no verification right there was no
yeah here's the thing we're always going to be able to think
and they've stolen they've stolen their sister's ID and they've
proven pro proven right there's always going to be a way that
you know this can happen that a child can like you know end up
looking like an adult without either of them acting maliciously
right right there are indicators that you're not in that situation
you get on a like if you know I wouldn't fall for a scam either
right cuz I would usually have indicators like a video chat or
a call where I'm not talking to a 12 but in your situation he
did have calls with her we had a call I don't think we actually
know I don't even don't think we actually know if that's I don't
know. They um they said they had called her. Well, he said that
he's had it to He said he called her, but then he didn't actually
dispute in the logs when Solo tells him, "You've never called
her." No, you've never been on a video call. You never been on
a call like that. He doesn't dispute Solo on that. He said that
to Pixie. I was close to
Okay. Well, anyway, I think I'd probably say that in terms of
somebody like beginning to like uh like with somebody probably
asking the age, that's fine. due diligence in terms of then it
isn't in any at all. I'm just laying out my position, Kelly.
It's not true though. What do you mean it's not true? Is there
a moral fact here? No, I'm going by like legal definitions of
what digital talk about morality. So, okay. So, you think the
absolute low effort just asking someone's age is good. No. Well,
the standard is that's probably that's probably the bare minimum
to avoid being like morally condemnatory. Yeah. Or avoid moral
condemnation. Okay. But if I'm going to finish what I was saying,
I think that's probably to engage or to start engaging with somebody.
that's like like a fine barrier to entry, right? But then if
you have like warning signs thrown up or something, maybe you
should ask for like a certain amount of extra information to
try and like verify it, right? So like the whole parent thing,
you would encourage like laziness in this type of situation.
I'm just you
morally I want to encourage everyone listening right now to be
lazy. But like you can I'm not encouraging anything. I'm saying
the standards by which I would judge doing this anyway on Twitter.
I agree. It is completely fine and completely understandable
for me to think that only asking for someone's age when there
were additional tone indicators within the things that she was
saying is simply not good enough. Yeah.
Did I not reference the additional information that would make
it make it more suspicious?
So you would need to ask more information, right? Without all
right without tone indicators, right? So there are no so say
there are no tone indicators. Say she didn't mention the parent
stuff or whatever. That's it's still not good enough. Um, is
like,
dude, I for a due dilig is this a fight? I don't even hear yelling.
There's like mild annoyance right now. To be there. That's what
I've got. You would need to know more about the person and to
not know who they are. And this doesn't require an ID. Am I being
criticized for not flying up? Give your full name. Oh, but I
I was told there was like yelling to look up a lot of things
with even that we do get
like we just have an alias that is exactly you're thinking perspectively
of what somebody should do to operate in the best and I'm saying
yeah I agree in terms of best practice and how to like operate
morally I agree
I sense it I sense what's actually going to happen here's about
to come up with a hypothetical
has clearly a lot with complete random he doesn't know anything
is about to come up with a hypothetical justification is
people who do that are degenerates and they deserve to get like
by playing this Russian roulette with randoms. Go to jail. So
my moral judgment is that that's still reckless if you they've
said their age when you don't know who they are. You don't know
their name. You don't know where they're from. You've never met
them. You don't know their friends, family circumstances, where
they live. You know nothing. They could that's not due diligence.
You would have to include at least some other personal information
to think that that age could therefore be correct. If Gamma and
I right, if we were to get off this call, end the stream and
I was to send Gamma a picture of my and he was to send me a picture
of his back, right? I know that he's like 21 or whatever, but
I've never seen his ID. I don't know what his real name is. I
don't know what what state he lives in. I know very very little
personal information about him as most people don't with like
most online uh most online interactions they have. Would I be
what improper in doing that? Would Gamma and me recently to be
honest, right? Both Gamma and I would be acting uh improperly
in doing that cuz we haven't seen each other's ID. We haven't
looked at each other's Facebooks to look at personal information.
We don't know each other's like full names. Here's the thing.
I think we're thinking about this. Do we judge really? The moral
condemnation is recklessness, right? That's all condemnation.
Both Gamma and I would be reckless. If you don't if you if what
you just said is true, you don't really know each other and you've
only spoken in like a Discord call a couple times. You have no
reason to like believe that his age is actually 21 based on anything
else that you know about him. Then yeah, but I get the impression
that's probably not accurate. you probably there probably are
reasons why you would believe that he is actually 21. We know
he's got monetization set up. We know he's got like, you know,
you can hear him, you know. Yes. Right. Things that you can
Major Windy hasn't got any any hasn't got any YouTube monetization.
We've spoken a few times. Okay. I know that he's like supposedly
in his like late 20s, right? Yeah. Don't remind me. It bothers
me. It would not be it would not be reckless. I don't think it'd
be worthy of like moral condemnation if he and I were to not
having personal information.
You're also treating this like it's a vacuum.
You're treating this like it's a vacuum, which is incorrect,
right? Cuz people know you and Gamma and therefore you're aware
of like the community. Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Did Karen Reed's trial not start today? I thought it was Oh,
it's starting tomorrow, isn't it? It's tomorrow morning. Okay,
never mind. Sorry. Around this, the mutual friends and like the
information that might make this sound absurd. How does that
How does that Did you just meet him? No. So, there has to be
additional content. Oh, I'm sorry. So, I was looking at the Karen
Reed thing in a side window
and I just realized that Kelly just got the gamma hypothetical
came through that you're implying is there that I'm unaware of.
Social circle, how does that give me any information? How does
that verify that major windy?
Knowing the information of a social circle, knowing that other
people also believe this person to be 21 for information they
might have, these are additional things that you would take into
consideration. I would take it does not make it verifiers.
No, it's not as hundreds of people in Twitter messages where
she's like showing off. Is that verification? Most people believe
it. I'm not talking about verification. You're setting the bar
for moral condemnation. That's the what I'm now going by. Your
bar. Okay. So, this is not as high as ID verification, but this
is simply more information and that makes more reasonable to
like morally condemn someone. If a whole social circle and a
whole other bunch of people believe someone is a certain age,
then it's probably more reasonable to think that that person
is that age. Yes. I don't think relying on the fact that other
people believe it will ever mean.
Okay. Okay. Okay. Actually,
is someone being bad faith? Actually, is Kelly is saying like
this would add weight. This would make you look less bad. And
is like, well, if you relied on that entirely, Kelly's like,
"No, I'm not relying on that. I'm saying it would add more weight."
And and then he's like, "Well, if you did that entirely, I think
it's like I think Kelly might not be the one here." He He's gone
from like this is about moral condemnation to actually this is
about verification. I'm like you stupid. I'm trying to talk about
the thing you want to talk about. Dickers is normally pretty
smart. This uh this crazy escaping moral if there's a risk of
if yes I know I'm saying the words moral condemnation. If there's
a risk of moral condemnation we'd never we'd never give we never
give the fact that like oh other people believed it therefore
it was like fine. I think or trying to recklessness we absolutely
need to verify that in of itself. Oh not it own. is after asking
their age. So, it's only shut up. Riyal, shut up. This is
we don't have I've been trying to get this point out for like
15 minutes. Unfortunately, this is a tricky one because Destiny's
got some context clues that we don't have, but it's as a result
of his really reckless behavior cuz he's had got photos and conversations.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Is Wendy from Australia or is he from New Zealand? Cuz he just
said he I feel like he just said context clues. Like he said
context and that's like more of a that isn't that more Kiwi than
Australian? I feel like all the Kiwis say that gixed gond. You
complain if I even slightly deviate and you're going on about
what was this guy's accent. Why? After just talking about some
random woman political thing. Can you tell me you are worse than
me? Top left corner of the stream. Could you tell me what I know
the royalist said there? You can find Kelly on Patreon and Twitter
over in these places. Is that what it says?
twitch.tv/kelly.
kick.com/kelly jean. Is that what it says there? You shouldn't
be a about things that you are worse. Is that actually what it
says there? Right there. You should be nice about it. That's
actually what it says. I didn't even realize it. Is not be a
Why are you talking over me on my stream? J, what are you doing?
Because I'm far more interesting and funny than you. I'm far
more interesting and funny than you. No, you're not. I've been
here since you had like 20 viewers. Yes, I
Okay. All right. If you think so.
I know. So, okay. Whatever you say, Kelly.
Sorry. Canadians, go live by yourself, Kelly. See how many years
you get. No, no, no. Go live by yourself, Kelly. See how many
years you get. Okay. What a silly thing to say when you know
I have like 100k followers on Twitch
and go live right now. See what happens. And go live right now
and see what happens. Go live right now. No, it's 5 a.m. I had
a I had a thousand I had 100,000 anyway cuz I don't sell. Let
me go find Kelly Jean right now. We're gonna go We're going to
view mo Kelly Jean right now in real time. View the Kelly from
my last stream of over two years ago. Luck. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep.
Kelly G E. Is it a bunch of N's? Bunch of A's. It's a bunch of
A's. Wait, does this not even come up? It's not. No, cuz you're
Kelly Jean. Also, what are you doing? There is a Kelly Jean.
Is this Are you Kelly_? It is. Just question. Why are you doing
this? I don't know. I'm bored mostly.
See, you're the one that complained about this. I know. And you're
just like going deep into it. Yes.
Now, now we can go on tangents, Kelly. Okay. Now, but what? Because
it's like half an hour later, an arbitrary time that you've decided
is okay to be.
Yeah. Then I tried listening to a debate you were in and now
I'm like, "Okay, I'll take anything else." Actually, uh-huh.
That's the problem. Is me in this debate. Is it? Because it was
Dickers you were just criticizing, not me. That's true. It's
your rewrite history. Brilliant.
Brilliant. Brilliant. Content getting [__] Wendy,
you are an does not make it verified.
No, it's not as there were hundreds of people in Twitter messages
where she's like shown off a text. Is that verification? Those
people believe it. I'm not talking about verification. You're
saying the bar for moral condemnation. That's the one I'm now
going by. Your is
I don't think relying on the fact that other people give. We
never give into the fact that like other people believed it,
therefore it was like fine. I think you recklessness. Absolutely
need to verify that in of itself. Oh, not on its own. See, it's
like leaves, right? Is that the only thing you can get?
J's patience is endless. My patience isn't really endless.
I can do a bunch of things. Not remotely. You are the most impatient
little man that I've ever seen. Kelly becomes like a female Kermit
the Frog when she gets mad. You are the one that sounds like
Kermit. J, you are unbearable right now.
Why? Why did you just Nazi? Either female either female Kermit
the Frog or possibly British Mama JF. I'm not sure. You are unbearable
right now. I need to see something. Little little tinge of psycho.
I think a little tinge of psycho from the from the Discord. I
think I think just a little bit. Like a tiny tiny bit. Okay.
I'm not bad at accents. I'm permanently I'm sorry. I'm perfectly
imitating Kelly Jean when she gets mad. No, you are. No. Terrible.
You sound like Hermit the Frog when you're talking about ice
hockey. When your like voice goes up like five dibels for some
bizarre reason.
When is that? When does that happen? You were watching ice hockey.
Oh yeah, like Kanye tweets reading. That's just whole there's
a whole different thing. Ping bar down. Bar down when you're
watching ice hockey or whatever. Who says ice hockey? What other
kinds of hockey are there? Ellie, don't say field. You mean I
can't say the other kind of hockey? Table? What's table hockey?
Like the uh What the is that? Air hockey. Yeah, air hockey is
what you meant. There's no table hockey. What are you doing,
Kelly? What? What is it on? It's on a table, isn't it? What are
you doing, sad? Oh, yeah. It's roller hockey as well. Water hockey.
Does polo count as hockey on a thing? Probably. What? What is
water hockey is made up? That doesn't exist. That's fake. You
just made that up entirely. I'm just saying there's a lot more
hockey variants. I want to talk to people who watch the Willy
Mac video, but now I don't have anybody who watched the Willy
Mac video is coming in. Hold on. Where's at? Is awake? Uh, hold
on. I'm I'm going to message a bunch of people. See if they watch
this video. Give me a second. Kelly, you're going. You're going
going where? What does that mean? Have you tried like explaining
a cohesive thought so I know what the you're on about? Uh, you
have the helm, Kelly. You need to talk. I don't know what I just
asked you a question.
What question did you ask me, Kelly? What did you ask? What are
you doing?
Oh, I'm sending messages to people to see if they want to come
on. Oh, actually, hold on. I don't care. I I I'm like bordering
on at hearing in the Discord, but I kind of don't want to do
that cuz I I don't know all of I don't know if I want any I don't
know all these people. Who do you not know? What are you on about?
I don't I It's crazy because now we have people in here and it's
like I think Perry's really good content, but I don't know if
I want Perry having like unfettered access to my stream voice
if I'm on Twitch. Seems terrifying. Okay, stream voice if you're
on Twitch. I don't know what this means. You mean inviting them
into this Discord? What do you mean? Yeah. Well, then we already
made a channel, right, that they can't come in or did you just
delete the channel?
Nope. Channel's still there. Where did it go? I just figured
I I'll I'll add here. Get get all out of here. I'll see if anybody
wants to hop in. Get Did you just kick me out of the channel?
No. What are you talking about? Well, I can't see the other channel.
Oh, hold on. Yeah, you could never see the channel. You took
my perms. No, I could see perms. There literally aren't perms.
Riy gave me perm that channels, but I could see it. Oh, I didn't
touch anything with that. I didn't kick you out or anything.
Likely story. Okay. I literally didn't I didn't kick you out
or anything. There there were no I gave her move perms. Oh yeah.
So I didn't have there are no perms. I don't know what you're
talking about. Kelly, I can't see the other channel. I could
see it before. Okay. I don't Yeah, I have no idea. You are so
dumb. Okay.
This is Riy. Just
stuff so I can do stuff with the stupid discord. There's 10 people
in it. Kelly wants admin so that she can like invite people.
I would rather she just go back to the other discord to be honest
with